on I'm on my uh laptop so I'll see if I
can speak a little louder
all right you're all set representative
all right let me let me start
um
uh let me start
with my uh introductory script for the
public and then we'll uh
we'll take a roll and we'll uh go to the
pledge
well as chair of the house committee
for municipal and County Government
I find that due to the state of
emergency declared by the governor as a
result of the covid-19 pandemic and in
accordance with the governor's emergency
order number 12
pursuant to executive order
2020-04 this public body is authorized
to meet electronically
please note there is no physical
location for members of the public to
observe and listen contemporaneously
to this meeting however in accordance
with the emergency order I am confirming
that
one all members of the committee and
select legislative staff have the
ability to communicate contemporaneously
during this meeting through the zoom
electronic meeting platform and the
public has access to contemporaneously
listen and if necessary participate in
this meeting by the zoom platform or by
telephone
all necessary access information has
been made available in the house
calendar and through the electronic
calendar on the general court website
the notice for this meeting complies
with house rules and RSA 91a
anyone who has a problem accessing this
meeting should call 271
3600.
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and rescheduled
Christina Dyer our committee researcher
will be our staff
assisting us
please note that all votes during this
meeting will be done via roll call
[Music]
let's start the meeting by taking a roll
call attendance when each member states
their presence please also State whether
there is anybody in the room with you
during this meeting which is required
under the right to NOLA
John
yes I am present and I am alone in my in
yes I'm in my own home with my wife
walking around and uh
representative
here in the
LOB
representative
yeah I'm here in the lab there is
another technician today he'll be coming
here in the LLB
representative
a home in my office my wife is in the
house
here in the LLB
okay
here in Hillsboro in my home my husband
is in the house but not in the room with
me
I'm here in uh beautiful Dover New
Hampshire and the cat's napping in the
representative Gilman
you need to unmute yourself Julie yeah
we're having trouble okay we seem to be
having trouble with representative
is there a laptop
we see her we can't hear her I suggested
that she log off and log back in
um
representative McDonald maybe if you can
go back to her I'm not sure if you can
do that right representative McDonald
that I can visually see her uh so let's
count her as present you're very good
I am here in my home office in
Northampton alone my wife is in the
office uh Upstairs Downstairs sorry
representative Davis
I am at my home in Peterborough New
Hampshire my husband is working in the
adjacent room and there are dogs and
Carpenters but the Carpenters are not in
my part of the house but if you hear
thumps that's who they might be
thank you
yes I am here in my home in Nashua I can
hear the proceedings my husband and
Greyhounds are also here and my husband
will be doing a little work on the house
so you may hear
um a little bit of thumping every now
and again
representative Gallagher
I'm here in my apartment in Concord and
and uh representative Gilman do you have
if is Christine are you monitoring
yes I am here
um if representative Gilman I don't know
if she's Frozen oh there she is um maybe
shut off your video and the audio might
work
yeah so maybe uh you could continue to
troubleshoot that while uh where we move
on absolutely thank you I I I I think
she tried to log off and log back on
foreign
Mr chair I'm texting her right now to
see if we can work through it okay maybe
we can get get audio through her phone
while we have uh video through her
computer
we can blend the technologies that way
we're we're going to be very creative
today it looks like
all right if I could ask you to
the best you can if you could please
I pledge allegiance to the flag of the
United States of America and to the
Republic for which it stands one nation
under God indivisible with liberty and
all right just a little uh
Logistics
start the day uh
I'm I am headed for my second covid shot
at around 11 30 or shortly thereafter
which which will leave uh uh a vice
chair representative Piemonte to
complete the hearings
uh that will still be going on at that
time
and uh but I will be back
uh
in the afternoon
and I plan to be in the lob for the
executive sessions this afternoon so
I will bring Tylenol with me in case in
case I get a case of the man flu and uh
all right so and also today as as you
can probably see from the schedule
between nine and ten thirty we're going
to be considering three bills the way
they're scheduled is something different
we haven't seen that this year but I've
tried to schedule them all together
and uh this was uh Heather's
uh effort to try to uh display that but
what we're trying to do let me explain
it these these three bills are all very
similar
and so uh the intent here from the
sponsors is for us to hear all three
bills kind of simultaneously
and to consider them together because
the sponsors want to
combine them
into one bill
the mechanics of that will be uh 243
will for lack of a better term will be
the lead bill
and the other two 415 and 454 will be
Consolidated into 243 uh via amendment
that will happen in an executive session
uh and and I believe the amended is
available and has been shared uh already
with you
so when you think of these three these
three bills please think of them
together
uh because
of the sponsors uh is to
make sure please make sure you're on
mute if you're not uh not speaking the
intent of the sponsors is to be one of
these bills and itl the other two so
that going forward out of our committee
only one of the three Will Survive
uh to the to the Full House
uh that one that survives will have
content
of all three
that hopefully that makes sense to you
so as we go through the the hearing
process we're gonna hear uh about all
three of these bills and uh the sponsors
are going to tell us how they're going
to consolidate uh and try to include it
into one and like I said that will that
will happen technically through the
executive session process when we
consider an amendment to mechanically
combine the three bills
and
technically it means that one will
survive and two will die in an itl
it's if you so vote that way
uh
so is there a question to get started uh
representative 11 yes thank you Mr chair
um I wanted to let you know that my
personal bodyguard and chauffeur will be
at my house at exactly 4 pm
to drive me to get my first shot for a
vaccine so I hope we are finished by
then if not I won't be here okay well
thanks for the notice I hope I hope we
are finished by then too and good luck
okay the uh Mr chair yeah
yeah I'm having trouble hearing back
here John can you hear
yeah it's going in and out a little bit
could you just uh speak closer to the
microphone
sure thank you is it only me that you're
having trouble with
yes but let me see if I can adjust my
volume
are there any hints uh from Christina or
from uh representative maggiori of how I
might increase my
my volume to help people hear me
if Mr chair if you go to the um
if you go to your settings you should be
able to have the volume or the the
volume in Zoom to increase your your mic
volume
and if down on the bottom where it says
mute where you have your microphone if
you hit that little arrow it should
bring you to the to the area where you
and I think that is in the the settings
area which is the last
um little thingy
it's a technical term little thingy on
that when we're talking about audio
meanwhile I uh Mr chair I'm still
but Christina is also true she's
connecting now
[Music]
yeah
I've done what I think I can do is that
does that help any better did you hear
me any better
hmm
little
all right if if it continues to be a
problem with you hearing me
uh please please let me know because
that means the Public's going to have a
trouble hearing me as well if they're
listening in so uh
we'll need to make some additional
adjustments
yes Mr chair yes
um this is a machine over here I'm just
going to move that over and maybe that's
I'll jump in to say representative
I see I have an indication that she's
it's going to be hard to control my
all right well those who are listening
or who may be watching please excuse our
our technical difficulties we will
overcome them very shortly and and move
forward
he still appears to be on mute for some
some reason
just Just A Sign Language yes
perhaps uh Christina if you're
monitoring perhaps we can coach uh
representative Gilman to connect via
telephone so that she can contribute if
she wants to there you go yes I have
called she did connect via telephone I'm
she I'm gonna call her again
we can get that taken care of okay thank
you I I'm curious to know if uh if you
can tell representative maduri do we
have issues with the public trying to
connect to or is it just representative
Gilman uh at this point Mr chair we have
a number of people in here
um
um I'll I'll do a little test here the
person who logged in or has their hand
up Sheila can you hear me
Sheila
I can hear everybody and you can hear
everything that's going on exactly
except for the the rep that's trying to
get in okay thank you I'm gonna mute you
again and we'll continue thank you very
much you're welcome well that's good
news
okay uh as we get started representative
Matt jury and by the way for uh training
purposes ongoing training purposes we're
going to ask representative Maggiore to
be a technical person
uh primarily this morning and
secondarily this afternoon and then
we're going to Flip Flip that with
representative power she's going to be a
secondary Tech person this morning and
be our primary Tech person this
afternoon so we're gonna we're gonna try
that in an effort to to expand our
Technical Training to representative
power
and we uh we do have Christina Dyer our
our support in the background she's not
a member of the committee but she's on
staff and she'll she will continue to
Monitor and help us get in trouble
issues
um just uh notice about other people in
the room
um apartment is here to check the
sprinkler heads so they'll be in the
background
hey thank you for that notice
truly can't get up excuse me Mr chair
can you hear me now we got you we got
you now he's good okay thank you are you
communicating via telephone or the
regular Zone I am through telephone
doing it twice
[Laughter]
I have to inform you that your votes
will only count once so you can't get
uh
and representative Maggiore the first
person that we're gonna ask to speak
when we get going is Wayne gortel Uh for
all right as we uh as we move forward
I'm going to open the hearing
on uh HB uh 243
which is
relative to the form of Municipal
budgets
uh and uh
I'm gonna also ask
representative piamonte to give us a
brief overview of of his approach I
tried to explain it to you with the
three bills but he's going to give a
brief over overview and also perhaps he
could touch on the history
of uh of these measures that were
entertained in uh in last year's uh
session and the votes at the general uh
General legislature that that we took
and I think these bills
the intent here was uh went over to the
Senate and then it died at covert death
at that point so representative piamani
we'll start with you and then we'll go
to Wayne gortel
hey thank you Mr chair
um
yes
all right let's see sorry about that
how about now it's better okay
um this pal we had set this bill up uh
last year and it's uh it deals with the
municipal budgets for the district and
the uh towns
now all the budget committees and uh
we first actually we
uh killed it in the committee and uh
after talking with the chair and the
municipal Association uh we came to an
agreement and
we actually flipped it in the house from
ITA itl to ought to pass uh from there
it went to the Senate and it died on the
table
um so I I made a few additions to this
bill this year
um basically uh
it deals with uh 32-4 five and seven
and it's basically the same thing in and
it deals with a full line item detail
um I'm just going to introduce it as
that right now and yield my time to
Wayne goetel who uh is experienced in uh
the budgets that he does and uh he will
give you the uh go down on this bill
before we go to Mr gratel uh
representative Piermont did you recall
what the vote in the house was when this
came uh for a general legislation vote
to I do I do actually it's uh I'm sorry
I didn't mention that it's uh it was uh
298 I believe four and eight against
okay thank you and Mr cartel are you
ready I am thank you uh good morning Mr
chair and honorable committee members I
appreciate the opportunity to testify
today at Wayne gortel I served the town
of Hooksett as a member of its school
board and served previously on its
budget committee and also the budget and
finance chair of the school district
governance Association of New Hampshire
I did submit written testimony to the
committee uh last night via email so I
hope you have that
um testing testifying in support of HB
243 and also 415 and 454. this is
crucial legislation that would allow
taxpayers budget community members and
governing bodies the ability to truly
understand how their money is being
spent and to assess if it is being spent
well
as a budget Committee Member I was
mandated by New Hampshire state law RSA
32 to ensure the Prudence appropriation
of public funds this required becoming
familiar with operations and budgets and
carefully looking into budget details
not just rubber stamping the proposed
budgets that were provided to the
committee we reviewed spreadsheets of
accounting details and whatever backup
materials were provided to explain these
budgets then interviewed administrators
about the requests
the town of Hooksett has nearly 15 000
residents its largest budgets are 35
million dollars for schools and 21
million dollars for municipal operations
uh consider that the school budget alone
has over 1 000 accounting lines and is
28 printed Pages how can anybody
efficiently Analyze This budget quite
simple you need tools specifically you
must have the budget accounting details
as an electronic spreadsheet file one
which can be loaded into a spreadsheet
program like Microsoft Excel and with
the spreadsheet program you can apply a
fusible formulas such as identifying the
accounting lines that have significant
budget changes from the previous year or
you could forecast
expected spending by applying an
inflation adjustment to previous
spending or you could identify
accounting lines that have a significant
difference between the budget request
and actual past spending so during my
time on the hooks and budget committee
we did exactly this to identify budget
lines with unexpected changes or
differences compared to past spending
and sometimes there were good
explanations when there was a large
difference uh one year the police budget
salary and retirement lines were quite a
bit larger than cash spending but this
was explained because there were several
open positions so passed actual spending
was for a smaller than desired police
force and therefore the budget was
larger but sometimes budget lines aren't
Justified and they might need to get
adjusted
unfortunately many taxpayers and even
budget committee members or governing
body members they don't have the
capability to look at the budget this
way many towns and schools do not
publish their budgets online they just
give elected officials paper copies or
they're published online but not in a
format that can be loaded into a
spreadsheet program that's why the
language industry standard electronic
spreadsheet format is so critical with
the spell
in 2021 Electronics spreadsheet program
use is so common it's taught to high
school students and many spreadsheet
programs are available for free making
budget materials available to public in
electronic spreadsheet format is long
overdue
in my written testimony attached to some
exhibits uh just examples of how
electronic documents are made available
uh by the New Hampshire Department of
Education my Hooksett school district
and the Merrimack Valley School District
I encourage your support for this uh
soon to be amended 243 the mandates uh
critical tools for Budget committees
governing bodies and taxpayers so they
can have an honest and accurate
conversation that their governments are
budgeting responsibly I appreciate your
consideration and would be happy to
answer any questions are there questions
from the committee uh representative
treeleven
representative 11 you had your hand up
yes I did thank you Mr chair it takes a
minute to unmute with my silly Mouse
um thank you Mr gortel for testifying my
question is um who gets to do the data
input for these spreadsheets
the uh the data is produced by
um the accounting software that the
districts use a lot of them are using
Microsoft Excel to create the budget and
use that to prepare next budget based on
previous budget larger districts have
programs that
record all these accounting items and
put these things together and they all
support and Export to something like a
Microsoft Excel file so
um this is really how all districts are
managing their budgets whether they're
smaller
and uh representative Maggiore just for
your benefit uh please queue up uh
Victoria
Ayre and Donna green as our second and
third speakers uh other other questions
for
Mr chair I believe that representative
Gallagher had his hand up next okay go
ahead representative Gallagher
so
um asks
a tech person and
um
advocate of the free software movement
wondering
um you said like Microsoft Excel is does
it
um work
um just as well with alternate free and
open source Alternatives is it possible
to use these data formats without the
use of proprietary software or does one
have to rely on proprietary software
written by big corporations
to this data thank you representative
for your question
um what has happened is that because
Microsoft Excel is essentially the de
facto standard every program whether
it's a free program like Library office
or open office or a proprietary program
they can all import this Microsoft Excel
format it's because they were the first
big program that's kind of become the de
facto standard in my written testimony I
attached an example of the Department of
Education website they actually make the
data available in two formats so comma
separated values is just a file that you
can load into any one of these
spreadsheet programs or Microsoft Excel
for the purposes of a member of the
public or school board or or budget
committee these are the same so comma
separated value or Microsoft Excel file
any program can import these files
because they are standards and I think
doe did a good job making both available
uh Mr gertel uh this is uh
representative Dolan uh is it um
the correct Assumption of my part that
you're using
Excel as a generic term much the way I
might say to somebody go make me a Xerox
copy of a document and I'm not really
telling them to use a xerox machine I'm
just telling them to make a copy and
whatever copy machine brand that we have
thank you Mr chair it's very similar to
that
um I think the one difference that's
very critical here is most of the
documents you see published on the web
might be in what's called a portable
document format or PDF and that looks
pretty I can run that through my printer
and it looks lovely but I can't actually
do these spreadsheet calculations on PDF
documents so when we say a Microsoft
Excel file or a CSV file that
specifically defines a file that you can
load into a spreadsheet program so you
can do these kind of math functions I
described thank you representative
thank you Mr chair
um
thank you for taking my question if um
these documents are made available in
this format could a member of the public
then go in and change figures in the
documents
or is it um or are they
non-editable
uh thank you representative for your
question
um by requiring these documents to be
posted online
essentially you guard against that
protection so anyone can pull a copy
down
um in my written test 20 I I provided an
example of the Merrimack Valley School
District's
um spreadsheet so you can edit that and
look at it and you could do hypothetical
things but if anyone in the public wants
to see what the real copy is they just
go to their school district's website or
their their towns website and get that
copy so the ability to edit the files
allows the public or budget committee
members to do analysis or add formulas
or or things like that
um but the body that owns the document
essentially posts on their website and
everyone can go there for the real copy
I hope that answers your question I
would like a follow-up please follow up
so so it would be possible for me to
download it on my computer and and play
with the numbers if I wanted to and then
I could upload my copy into the onto the
internet on a Facebook page
would that could that happen that could
happen and if anyone uh just trusted
that upload they could go to the
um governing body site or whoever
published the document and obtain the
real copy how would they know
uh they would simply know that there's a
copy published I think it's kind of
similar to getting a copy of uh the
local newspaper and here's the copy
versus a edited picture that I posted on
Facebook you can always find the
okay uh next we have a question from
representative man chaputi
thank you Mr chair thank you Mr ortal
for taking my question isn't it true
that this uh software is tied into the
accounting software that the uh
City or School District or the
municipalities use so that there is a
seamless transfer of one and uh from one
to another
also isn't that the
protection
want that the security
of for the school budget or the town
budget committee to have that security
when they have paid
uh software that they're using
thank you representative for your
question
um
I think there's sort of three scenarios
here um for I think smaller towns uh
schools Etc they're probably using a
product like Microsoft Excel to put
their budget lines together and edit
them year to year to forecast their
their next proposed budget um larger
districts use
um more complicated software but because
CSV and Microsoft Excel are sort of the
two standards they can export that in in
my district for instance there's a large
program that's used and it's exported to
Excel and the business administrator
adds information to it to make the copy
that is given to the the school board so
um ultimately the the data is correct
and it's just transferred to a new form
that that can be used by the public or
same
I was muted and lost all audio
uh I'm sorry about that we have a next
question from Representatives Davis
thank you um Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
I I have a question about the term
industry standard
who who decides what is the industry
standard what if the industry standard
changes
a year from now I mean whoever knows
what it is uh I have a business in which
I do not use Microsoft Excel I use a
different kind of spreadsheet
which is fully shareable with my
partners
who can make changes and do analyzes on
it for me and for us that's the industry
standard so who who is the decider about
what the industry standard is in this
particular bill
thank you representative for your
question B
um I think that is a challenging aspect
of this kind of testimony as I mentioned
your previous question there's really
two types of files there is something
that you can print and looks pretty and
there's a type that can be used for a
spreadsheet program uh so you can
actually run calculations and do
analysis I would guarantee that whatever
program you're using even though it's
not Microsoft Excel allows you to import
data from a CSV file or a Microsoft
Excel file so
um again these are these have become
standard just because they're the most
popular programs the CSV format isn't
owned by anybody per se it is the public
format so that's the way it's really
just a list of numbers with commas
between them and any program that needs
to have data imported you can get that
format so
you could say CSV I think legislation
um industry standard I think gives more
flexibility and the uh exhibit from the
Department of Education I provided I
think really hits the the mark there
with making all three file formats
available
you muted Mr chair I was muted uh next
uh thank you uh Mr chair and um actually
I have a a question for you
um in reviewing uh Mr gortel's testimony
and listening to Tim speaking I I also
was looking at the um Amendment
um so
my um my comment is actually as much to
the amendment and I don't know if that
would be appropriate at this time or
should I be waiting yeah I I would uh I
would suggest that we wait until we get
to an executive session before we
consider the amendment the content of
the amendment just with the
understanding that the sponsors want to
use the amendment process to consolidate
okay that's fine then I just do have a
really um quick kind of question for uh
Mr gortel if that's okay
thank you uh Mr gortel
um I
I'm one of these people who um I'm a a
numbers person and I like having CSV
files myself so um I completely
understand that but I also
um want to follow up with a question
that um one of the previous uh speakers
had asked and that was about the ability
of being able to manipulate a document
and then put it up on social media and I
agree with what you say the the original
one will always remain there but Mike my
question to you is
aren't we also concerned that um the
original poster that may have changed
these documents to create some type of
tomfoolery or or someone like that
um that will become the live document in
the Public's mind
um and not necessarily that if we allow
um editable but I at the same time I'm
saying this I do agree with
um the the right of being able to do
much of what you had said but do you not
have concerns that this could happen as
well
thank you representative for your
question
um I'm personally not concerned and and
the reason for this is because you
always can find the original copy
um maybe a better analogy than the
newspaper one I offered before was if
you were to have a post on on social
media and then someone would just say
representative said this and and messed
that up someone could always go to your
social media page and see what you
actually said so
um I think with any kind of
communication you sort of have the game
a telephone where things could be taken
over context or misconstrued or
intentionally
um uh stated incorrectly but the ability
to post these and know who was the
source of record and go to that location
to find in this case the budget
spreadsheet you always have the accurate
copy and I think that quickly
um
stifles any sort of um misuse of a
document to make or whether it's a
social media post or whatever
um someone can simply say that's
incorrect the copy on the school's
website says this is the amount we spent
on teacher salaries last year you're
incorrect so I think these kind of
things um you know we see examples in
other areas in social media today but
you can always find the original quote
or the original posting and and see the
truth that way so I think it's it's not
really any different from other
situations we have today
okay
um Mr chair yes
uh this is representative Tripp may I
ask a question
uh
let me uh oh you're in the uh you're in
the
the lob so I can't I can't uh see you uh
yeah that's a problem no yes it is
um
so perhaps we're being discriminated
against I know so so perhaps I could ask
representative medjury if there is a
member in the lob that raises their hand
that I can't see because I only can see
electronic hands could you please uh let
make me aware that there is somebody in
the LLB that wishes to speak as well
I'll do that and as a follow-up Mr chair
I would just say that
um maybe if that representative could
physically wave their hands so I can see
them and I'll make a note as best I can
well that's right you're not you're not
in the lb either I was I thought you
were there uh representative Powell
you're in the are you in the lob yes yes
could you uh with you are you uh are you
a in a designed assistant right now for
the meeting yes I am all right so why
don't you
um as you look around the room and see
one of the members in the lob with their
hand up that wants to speak could you
please indicate to me because that's
that's a disadvantage from
representative Maggiore because he's
like me he's only can see the electronic
hands raised yes I will do that thank
you
so let let me go make I'm trying to do
this in the right order so I want to go
to representative Maggie or he was a
question
thank you Mr chair and and thank you Mr
gottel for taking my question
um my question is going to be about
enforcement and and the background or
penalties in the background for full
disclosure the town of Northampton has
for many years provided the budget
committee with the exact form and format
that you are suggesting
um and as as I'm sure everybody is aware
when after the select board has reviewed
the budget it transfers that budget the
approved select board budget to the
official budget committee that's what we
do and then it's theirs
um so I'm so my question is the budget
committee then will be suggesting
um to the governing body that the
updates to the budget be posted online
well actually there's two questions here
so what if we forget or don't do it
um during that that high that intense
period of of budget season uh we we just
that the town has forgotten to do it is
there an enforcement or a penalty issue
here and
um are you would you be suggesting that
there should be some notation here that
this is the budget committee
recommendation or School Board
recommendation and not the
recommendation or not the update from
the select board to eliminate some
appreciate the questions
um I think regarding who's budget it is
you're correct there's there's
definitely a transition of ownership the
administrative body uh sorry the
administration proposes a budget
typically it goes to the governing body
they amend the budget so that points the
governing body's budget and then if it's
an sb2 channel it's transferred to the
budget committee and it's their budget
and ultimately they have a public
hearing and
uh the deliberative session on that
budget so
um speaking from my experience in
hooksettes we have five governing bodies
um water precincts uh Wastewater School
in town
what effectively happens is the
administration is managing that budget
throughout the process so governing body
makes adjustments their Administration
obviously is is updating the budget at
some point it's given to the budget
committee the budget Community makes
updates so there's there's motions and
votes and and they're tweaking lines or
or the bottom line and what's happening
is essentially you've got two bodies
checking each other's work so the budget
committee has a running total your
Administration is running total
in Hooksett ultimately your
Administration is taking the amended
budget and putting it in the handbook
for uh the public hearing or for the
deliberative sessions so
you essentially have dual ownership at
that point you are corrected as budget
committee's budget presented to the
public uh I haven't seen a lot of
examples of the budget committee
publishing their spreadsheet uh we've
done that in hooks up in the past but
typically uh the folks who spend the
money are most interested in making sure
all those Publications occur
answered your question
um
you had two and I think I only answered
one yes thank you very much and the
second question was do you anticipate uh
any type of enforcement and or penalty
should for some reason this this
um this amendment says shall and for
some reason we do not by and let's
assume that that is just human error and
not intentional but it is not done and
then the public feels disenfranchised do
you anticipate or does anybody
anticipate any possible enforcement or
penalties
um
so RSA 32 doesn't really have a lot in
the um penalties section uh there's a
few few examples uh for
uh light I'll basically I'll call it
late negligence that mean gross
negligence and if memory service correct
I think that capsided perhaps say uh
there was litigation involved a one or
two thousand dollar penalty
um and again that's gross litigation
which I I'm not aware has actually ever
been
um brought about
um I I think Simply Having the
legislation goes a long way because
um it is the guideline you're supposed
to follow and what IT addresses at least
in my perspective is is there is such a
variability in in how these things are
produced today in the public in many
places doesn't have a chance to see the
budget so the fact that you've specified
this approach to making the data
available
um I think that we'll optimistically
bring everybody around to
um being very transparent or forthcoming
okay
um
our next speaker we're going to go to uh
representative Tripp and then
representative Gallagher with questions
but before we do that
um I representative Clee brought up an
issue about uh the amendment and uh it's
my understanding that the the other
bills of this Trifecta here uh
415 and four four
54 on May
answer those the questions that uh the
amendment might try to solve it I may
hopefully I have that correct so I'm
going to ask Mr gortel to
confirm whether I'm correct or not
Mr chair thank you yes um I I see this
as a package and those other two bills
um
the first one we talked about in my
testimonies primarily around the the
details that are published
um the other two bills specifically
address
it's getting published and being
available for the public in a useful
format and then a very small change to
the language that essentially makes
budget committees on par with governing
bodies and I can talk to that for those
bills but
um yeah I see them partnered up and
together providing a good solution
okay so I'm gonna next go to
representative Tripp and then we'll go
to representative Gallagher
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
same sorts of a lot of concern about
people
changing the uh these files and then
putting them on social media or
something like that uh
seems that uh
this is the only concern that people
have about uh
changing files and then completing them
Mr gottel are you familiar with PDF
editors
I am yes
do you think that uh people can download
files from
PDF files from a
School site change them and then repost
them
uh thank you for your question I think
there's really two situations here um so
a PDF can be signed and and that is
supposed to make it tamper-proof and so
for the budget being published in a in a
very pretty format you would perhaps
print out or scroll through online I
think that's a way to lock down the
official you know governing body
published budget or budget committee
budget so I think it makes sense to have
that publish in the website the CSV or
Microsoft Excel file format that that we
see many districts publish that's really
a tool to allow people to to apply
formulas and do some what-if questioning
and such
um I think your signed PDF as as the
budgeted record on a website really
addresses that problem because it's not
going to be manipulated so new delhi's
Point people to that document
I love people
uh representative tripty did I hear you
ask for a follow-up
I'm not so much concerned about uh
the the actual pretty uh budget theme
changed I think that uh
the problem is that people aren't aware
that this can happen you know they
they're very concerned about the CSV
files being changed and and being
reposted whereas uh it is possible
uh that uh the PDF files can be changed
so
I guess why is there extreme concern
thank you for your question I I think
the Cs V again is we're really using two
different programs the PDF allows anyone
to view it you can view it in a web
browser
um you can view it a PDF editor and and
that can be a signed document the the
other files you can actually sign an MS
Excel file but a CSV it's just a list of
numbers uh or a giant table of numbers
um and I think ultimately you've got the
same
your challenge is no different than uh
we could have this meeting this morning
and and representative pick a comment
and then I can post an incorrect summary
of that comment on social media and
someone says no that's you know go see
the original comment Mr vertel was
incorrect it's the same thing with the
budget data um I think that
yeah there is no way to I mean any any
data you get that's that's public you
can pull onto your computer and edit so
really we're just looking forward these
um additional bills that have to be
posted and I think the the governing
body or whoever posting these you always
have the gold copy there so I think the
questions about someone posting an
incorrect copy are are really addressed
by just go to this place and look for
the real copy
okay next speaker or a questioner will
be representative Gallagher and then
so
um
on the line of this whole uh discussion
about different versions of
budgets
um I was wondering if it would be
possible under this legislation
for towns to use a GitHub style
development model for their budgets
where the budget is stored in a Version
Control System
um and then each version of it is
identified by a unique commit hash and
then changes to it are required to be
done in the form of poll requests so
um that
um
people that different versions are
people's other versions are easily
identified as such and people can
see
who it's coming from and how it would
get merged in
uh representative thank you for your
question I'm actually a computer
software developer uh by trade and so I
know exactly what you're talking about I
think that would set a bar that would be
too high for for some
municipalities or governing bodies to to
follow just because there is a learning
curve it's not your standard web hosting
blog to give an example and I think uh
another uh representative had this
question about versioning so
um what hooksett's town government does
is they'll post the the MS Excel
spreadsheet on its website and there's a
date on it so the Excel file or the PDF
file has a date it's it's version two as
of January 7th 2021 if the budget
Community makes additional changes they
simply remove that version publish the
latest version with an updated date and
so
um although you could have a bunch of
different versions really all that
matters is the current version because
that's the sum of all the amendments to
date and then the version that um is
used to produce the budget going to
public hearing and Global Obsession so I
appreciate this very good question I
think that simply putting a comment and
even the file with a version and a date
addresses that question is probably from
my perspective the most efficient and
simple way for for
um governing bodies and such to comply
with this bill
representative
thank you Mr chair
um just going back to the different
versions and different uh software and
stuff what is the stamp for the cyber
security I mean these are accounting
these are Preparatory
documents of you know how safe are
municipalities in cities in the school
boards to have this kind of
cyber security not being tampered
uh thank you for your question
representative I I think it's very
similar to a school publishing
um and I don't want to oversimplify but
publishing like a lunch menu or
something
um the website
you know you specify a document can be
retrieved from your website and random
people can't change your lunch menu for
your school or they can't upload
documents because the website has been
set up so only people have permission
only certain people have permission to
post so the actual posting the documents
and I think that's that's more covered
by um one of the other related bills is
addressed simply by
any anyone that has a website page or a
Facebook page or something specifies who
has permission to do what the actual
document is is really no different
um I could go today to my town and issue
rights no request and get a paper copy
or get this file personally so
I think the the related bills that talk
about publishing this in a website
actually make the process safer because
anyone in the public can go to the
website and say Here's the budget
published by the budget committee if if
you're not publishing this and someone
gets a copy by write to no request and
posts it there's nowhere to look and
confirm if this has been been modified
or not so I think the related bill that
says it should be published
um really solves a problem because
there's one place to go for the for the
real official copy uh follow Mr chair
yes go ahead
um I understand uh I'm married to a
software engineer who has worked on the
cyber security and uh
you know software uh
of 40 plus years so what my question is
I understand this is where the 21st
century this is the way to go this is
the way to do it but on the same token
in the back end
that is also an investment that our
municipalities school boards and staff
which we have to do virtually and to
have that back-end safety
that also has to be not just one
software that's for publishing and
website and uh but also security we're
talking about budget
so tampering that there should be a
representative thank you I
um I think there's really sort of three
scales to to how these things are posted
and I think we're talking about the
related bills at this point but
um for instance I have a little website
gorgehog.com I have like 20 Pages there
as a school board member I've posted
some letters to the editors and things I
spend ten dollars a month for this to be
hosted and there's a administrative
access that says I can post and nobody
else can so obviously Manchester has a
very different uh town website but they
do a similar thing with with granting
access and there's of course
um
municipalities between the size of my
little website in Manchester so Food
flavors but they all have these
fundamental access controls as part of
publishing so
um you know I think perhaps there's a
larger question here about
ensuring municipalities are taking
appropriate cyber protections I I
personally think that's to be on the
scope of this bill this is really
getting at the budget
um which is being examined by governing
body budget committee and and such
should be available for the public and
if it's posted online you know the real
copy is online at a website if anyone
can go get it and that sort of
guarantees that everyone knows what the
real real budget is I hope it answered
your question
thank you our next question will come
from representative Gilman then a second
question from representative Matt giorg
thank you Mr chair I apologize for
having uh computer problems in the
beginning
um but for the record I am in my room
alone in Exeter
um my question is would the
uh
access
to a line item budget be adequate if the
administration scans it and publishes
publishes it as a PDF that way as
opposed to a a live PDF that can be
edited
thank you representative for your
question
um what I'm looking as a budget
Committee Member um very specifically I
think you need both both versions so the
scanned copy that's made available as a
PDF you can publish that and people can
see the budget but again consider
Hooksett a thousand lines for its school
budget you really can't look through 28
pages and say what are the lines that
changed a lot um you really need a tool
that's sort of like asking your auto
mechanic to to do repair without tools
um these these budgets are so large a
spreadsheet program is being used to
create them uh if you want to ask some
of these fundamental questions you do
need it in a format that that can be
loaded into a spreadsheet so
unfortunately the scan copy you can't
load into a spreadsheet program and you
can't ask them these questions and
unfortunately my experience on on budget
committee
um some years where we had this data we
could do some really good work um one
year which I I described in my written
testimony we were denied access to these
public documents and it made the job a
lot harder
and can I have a follow-up Mr chair yes
you can
um
what was my follow-up sorry I've
forgotten what I was going to ask on uh
well just uh think about it we'll go to
representative Maggiore thank you
thank you Mr chair and thank you Mr
goetel for taking a second question uh
I'm I'm thinking about uh fist being I'm
thinking about economies in different
communities as they may have been
affected or or they just are as as they
exist so please don't take this question
as being snarky it's not intended to be
but can you please define the the limits
thank you for your question so uh one of
the related bills uh published online
and and I think that's
um
on on a municipalities website for
instance uh in the in the written
testimony provides some examples you can
go to a page of documents on hooksettes
School Board site and and see the
spreadsheet uh Merrimack Valley just
drops the entire spreadsheet in a page
and you could actually look scroll
through it there without with any
difficulty uh the Department of
Education just has these data pages and
whichever version you want a PDF file a
CSV or or Ms Excel you can just download
your computer and pop open
um so I think publishing is is somewhat
big but online is it's 2021 I think
online is where people go to to get
these documents
thank you
okay next uh I want to bring in uh Miss
Victoria Ayer who wants to you can
support
good morning can you hear me yes go
right ahead
thank you Mr chair thank you members of
the committee I think Mr gartel summed
it up quite nicely and it'll make my
testimony quite a bit shorter I did want
to touch upon one comment though I can
already produce any spreadsheet I could
produce a spreadsheet of a budget detail
for either one of you and post it online
just because
I can do that doesn't mean I'm going to
do that so I just wanted to make that
comment that it's something that can
already be done allowing this bill to
pass does not mean that this is a new
option for people that want to adjust
numbers and and skew the facts
and I'd just like to add that um you
know I don't have the education or the
training that that you all have and I
certainly don't have the experience that
Mr gortel has and just a resident here
in Gilson we have 826 residents and as
it's budget time we have our annual
reports spread out on the floor we flip
through the ms-737s the 535s the 434s
and we have to flip back and forth if we
had a budget line item detail in
spreadsheet format we could sit at our
system and look at it and then that
would allow us to make a more educated
vote when it comes to budget
time right now we have difficulty
finding out what our lines actually
contain because they're not expanded
even during a public by the budget
committee meeting
so with that difficulty I ask that you
please pass this bill I asked this last
year when it was presented as House Bill
1460 and I again Ask it this year I
think it's a benefit to communities and
we need to be able to access this
information thank you
and representative Billman you remember
I was wondering
um and thank you Mr uh girl for taking
my question
um all of the budget meetings have to
occur as a public meeting where any
products are published any follow-up and
so I'm going along the lines of the
scanned PDF going up online and if
people follow a line uh I don't know
about all communities whether they
record their meetings or not
but they uh as the meeting progresses
people can follow along with the line
items if they even have it on their
screen not printed out how does this not
how does I don't know if I explained it
well enough but how does it not satisfy
your concerns
representative thank you for your
question I think there's really two
questions here
um the first case and I mentioned this
in a written testimony my first year on
the on the Hudson budget committee
I I did this work I described I I took
electronic spreadsheet files I added
some columns to identify the lines that
changed a lot I identified lines that
were budgeted a lot different than past
actual spending and this was used as a
guide for the committee to to go through
and we didn't change every line that
that this is essentially to look at
candidates and again we're looking at a
thousand line spreadsheet and and the
tool helps you identify things you
should ask questions about this doesn't
seem quite right why is that so we had
several three four hour long budget
committees meetings um our school board
rep was was texting our business
administrator and so I'm gonna say we
probably had 20 20 hours of analysis
doing these lines and so the first thing
the the spreadsheet is required to find
the interesting lines so it's a tool for
for doing that analysis and seeing which
ones need more attention uh secondly
that year we modified 83 lines of the
budget so if you went through meeting
minutes they were long long documents
um someone motions to to amend this line
with this account number from this
amount to this amount it's second in
there's discussion there's a roll call
vote and we move on and so imagine you
know five or or six uh meetings worth of
this
um I need few lines you see simply
couldn't track it so grabbing um the
latest version up website is is the way
for the public to really understand what
the current budget looks like and in
this case the one example I discussed it
looked very different when we were done
with it due to that a detailed analysis
okay thank you
uh representative Maggiore you had an
additional question
yes I do have an additional question but
it's going to go way back to to
representative piamonte and the the vote
on the floor last year it would that be
appropriate now Mr chair or shall I wait
uh well since it was brought up I think
if you wanna comment on that you you're
welcome to thank you it'll be very quick
the the floor the division vote on the
floor was 281-8 an overwhelming majority
and and that was good but the amendment
that passed by that
so the vote on the floor was May do you
but but this bill changes back to shall
um I'll I'll defer to representative
piamonte on that one
thank you and I'm sorry I didn't ask uh
Mr representative piamonti directly I
apologize
um unfortunately I can participate in
the hearing I did introduce the bill
uh represent I mean uh Mr gortel can you
answer that question
uh I I did testify thank you Mr chair I
did testify for HP uh 1460 um I don't
recall if it was mayor shell I I do feel
shell is is the right word here because
uh without it it'll just be ignored and
uh as I expressed them we wouldn't
testimony
um there needs to be some guidance I I
had a
surprisingly difficult year doing the
job I was required to do my state law
without some of these documents and so I
think it's responsible uh to publish
them and I think uh ultimately you
develop trust with your community by
making this information public
thank you the next person to testify is
Christina Barrett who is in opposition
to uh HB 454
thank you uh chairman Dolan one quick
correction um it's Barrett Christina
Barrett is the first name Christina is
the last name
that uh chairman Owens it's a common
mistake um by all means it happens all
the time uh thank you committee members
um my name is Barrett Christina I'm the
executive director of the New Hampshire
school boards Association and chairman
Dolan if I could just ask one quick uh
process question are we discussing all
three bills right now or are we just
going to talk to to uh 243 right now I
just I asked so I can uh provide my
comments accordingly yes and a rather
unusual uh technique today we are
blending the the testimony on all three
bills normally we don't do that but
because there's no similar we we thought
it would be appropriate for the
committee to hear all three together
absolutely so thank you for that
clarification sir and I'll try to talk
to all three bills if that's all right
um again for the record uh my name is
Barrett Christine I'm the executive
director of the New Hampshire school
boards Association we're sort of the
sister organization to the New Hampshire
Municipal Association we represented
about 160 school boards across the state
and provide multiple trainings on on
School District budgets and and related
matters to these three bills
um specifically to House Bill 2 243 I
think some of the concerns that nhsba
has with the bill have already
um been been asked by some of the
committee members so we had questions
about what a full line item detail means
and and certainly what industry
um uh standard electronic spreadsheets
um mean
our bigger concern with this bill is
you're asking you know close to 400
public bodies to to alter and amend and
perhaps purchase new software in order
to comply with 243.
um yeah I I think it may be more prudent
and more efficient not just for this
committee but for 160 school boards
across the state and I believe there are
240 or so uh talented municipalities
across New Hampshire
um if if the desire of this committee is
to pass a bill that provides um greater
access and transparency to to taxpayers
and voters to be able to review uh their
local budgets I think that the dra might
be
um it might be more prudent for the dra
to perhaps create some sort of standard
forms for towns and school districts to
use for their budget preparation we know
that the dra certainly has forms for
sort of post-budget aspects if you will
the pertinence school district forms are
the ms-26 the ms-27 for school districts
that have uh Municipal budget committees
and then there's a default budget form
as well too and and in looking through
these they list all the line items that
the Department of Revenue Administration
um indicates in their in their
department and their department rules
the 1100 lines the 1200 lines the 1300
lines expenditures for the prior year
expenditures current year is approved by
the dra Appropriations for the ensuing
uh fiscal year Appropriations for the
recommended Appropriations for the
ensuing fiscal year uh record not
Appropriations not recommended for the
ensuing fiscal year so I understand that
these forms are filled out after your
annual meeting
um so it really doesn't necessarily help
on sort of the front end if members of
the public or budget committees want to
see where the public body is either
increasing or decreasing a line item
um but but the available the information
is certainly available through existing
Department Department of Revenue
um forms and it seems that that may be a
more prudent course of action rather
than uh rather than having you know 400
local political bodies have to to change
what they're doing have to purchase
software and things of that nature so
that's our primary concern with um with
House Bill 243
if I could speak to House Bill 5 uh I'm
sorry 454 right now
um and I understand there there's an
amendment coming but I'm just looking at
the bill now this is on line eight
um that the the public body
um shell provide to the budget committee
at such times and in such detail as the
budget committee shall fix
I I can speak to this pretty clearly
every year usually in the fall when when
school districts and school boards and
budget committees are working on their
budgets the New Hampshire school boards
Association receives numerous phone
calls every year from either a school
board chairperson or a superintendent or
perhaps a school district business
administrator saying
you know so and so from the budget
committee emailed me or called me and he
said he wants these documents and these
formats and he wants he needs them by 5
pm today because they're having a
meeting tonight
um and that creates uh confusion for the
school district
um it doesn't help the budget committee
as well too but you know we and so the
business administrator may try to comply
with that request but the next day he
gets another request from another budget
Committee Member for something else
that's either done differently or in a
different format or need to buy a
different time
so when when we have these concerns with
um sort of relations between budget
committees and school boards nhsba
advises the school board to have a
conversation with the budget committee
and see if they can establish some sort
of ground rules where there will will
there be a point of contact from the
budget committee to the school board or
to the school district to request these
sorts of these sorts of documents and
this sort of information
um but if we're going to be putting it
in law that in in such details the
budget committee shall fix now from a
sort of a governance standpoint I I
would read that as presuming that the
budget committee would have to take a
vote to determine what information they
wanted in the format that they wanted in
the manner that they wanted it and then
a liaison or representative from their
budget committee would have to uh
contact the school district to make that
request in reality that's not how it
always happens though
um you know as elected officials budget
committee members often will call as I
mentioned we'll call the superintendent
or or were called a business
administrator and sometimes they request
information in certain formats sometimes
they demand certain information in in
certain formats so
um this is more I think a communication
issue that doesn't necessarily need to
be put into State Statute
um you know I think if if the budget
committee whether it's not the
chairperson or the liaison or the direct
um point of contact for the school board
if they can have these conversations you
know at the get-go you know before Labor
Day or right after Labor Day when
everybody's starting to dig into a work
that can alleviate a lot of the
challenges or frustrations that I think
budget committees may have and perhaps
the school boards may have as well too
so From nhsba's perspective um I think
that's again that's a sort of a local
communication issue that should be
ironed out between between the two
public bodies to find the best and most
efficient method in which the school
board or the school district can provide
the budget committee the information
that they necessarily need
um and last uh speaking to uh House Bill
um as it reads as the bills uh currently
reads um that the it says but the the
governing body
um shall uh uh excuse me uh shall
prepare statements and estimated
expenditures of revenues for the ensuing
fiscal year and shall submit such
statements to the respective governing
bodies so on and so forth but no fewer
than 30 days prior to the public budget
hearing for the budget
um that is concerning um simply because
it's going to limit the amount of time
in which school boards have to get their
budget done now most budget hearings are
usually held under RSA 32 are usually
held in the middle the middle of uh uh
December for talented school districts
um by requiring that that information be
done 30 days prior is going to
significantly limit I think
um I think the the the
I think it's going to going to inhibit
or limit the
the best matter in which that budget can
be prepared
um you know school boards are often
working through this right up until the
day that the budget needs to be
published prior to the prior to the the
budget hearing and by moving that back
30 days you're disallowing
um you know our municipalities and our
select boards just that extra 30 days
um to to really get down and present a
prudent um and a clear budget uh to the
voters the other aspect to that is often
Collective I know collective bargaining
Agreements are done on a via separate
warrant article or not necessarily
included within your your general
operating budget
um but if the if if members of the
public want the full picture of what the
the overall budget will be for a school
district collective bargaining is not
often done or completed by the middle of
December
um you know there are some it can it's I
mean ideally it's done by by the new
year
um but you know there may be times where
school boards and and teachers unions
need that extra week or two to hammer
out the final provisions of eclectic
bargaining agreement and some of the
cost items that are going to be
presented to the public so we have
concerns that by pushing that back or
pushing that up 30 days
um you're going to get you're not going
to get um as good a budget as you might
possibly have if school boards and other
towns have additional time to to fight
to finalize their budgets before posting
for the budget hearing
um the other aspect relative to House
Bill
415 where it says the governing body
shall publish the draft budget and
revised versions one I'm not sure what
the draft budget means does that mean
the the initially proposed budget that
is being presented at the um at the
budget hearing
um and and and version revised versions
um this is sort of one of those areas
where there's a difference between
statute and practice
um you know there may be there may be
dozens of revised budgets
um you know business administrators and
superintendents are working on on
budgets all year long
um as soon as uh March 20 21 annual
meetings are done if hopefully hopefully
we can get through them I say March some
of those we know maybe maybe in April or
May this year
um but by the end of the school year
we're already working on budgets for the
following year we're looking at
projected revenues we're looking at
student enrollments and I know over
um usually over the summer is when
superintendents and business
administrators will sit down with their
other administrative staff they're
building level staff their special
education directors school principals
and over the Summers when they start
developing the next year's budget so to
require
um that um a draft budgets and revised
versions
um
after making any updates to the budget
have to be posted or noticed within five
days it that belies the reality I mean
you may have two or three draft budgets
in a single day the business
administrator and the superintendent
May sit down at eight o'clock in the
morning work on the budget for a couple
hours and then go off and do other work
and they may come back at four o'clock
in the afternoon and do another couple
hours on the budget so I'm not sure what
a draft budget or what a final or a an
amended budget
um or a revised version excuse me a
draft budget or a revised version would
necessarily mean so without any further
clarifying language in that
um it it just doesn't make sense from
sort of a practical standpoint in the
way that that school district budgets
are are actually developed
um so those are nhsba's comments um on
the on the three bills um you know we
certainly are happy to promote anything
that can increase transparency and
increase
um uh uh voters being more prepared or
more or more aware of of their budgets
before they actually have to vote on
them but we think that the language in
these three bills is is vague as
confusing May impose significant
um additional uh requirements on public
bodies
um and and just does not fit for the way
that these actually work and we think
that some of these things certainly have
Merit but we think that maybe the
Department of Revenue Administration
um might be um the better place to
direct some of these some of these
proposals and with that I'm happy to
answer any questions Mr Christine I have
a couple of questions from the committee
thank you Mr C uh chair thank you Mr
Christina for taking my question so
um thank you for a very detailed uh
testimony in terms of
um
how these three builds are going to
impact uh my question is by just simply
putting it is this helping
or at the local budget school boards
counties in cities make a really
transparent budget process or it's going
to hinder with not enough tools is it an
enabling or
uh more controlling yeah sure thank you
for the question representative
um you know we think that there are ways
to certainly enhance
um The public's awareness of these of
these matters we just think nhsba just
thinks that that the three bills at
least as presented I understand there
may be an amendment coming I don't under
I don't know if that amendment is going
to be just these things in a single bill
or if they're going to be language
changes as well too but we think that
that these three bills are going to
um sort of hinder the necessary work
that's being done within the central
office between the school board and the
superintendent and the administrator
um and we would certainly hope that this
would increase transparency if these
bills were to go through but
um I'm not certain that's going to be
the case for the reasons that I that I
stated
thank you uh representative Trill Evan
uh thank you Mr chair I have a question
for you and I don't mean to throw a
wrench into the works but I was candidly
surprised when you asked Mr Mr Christina
asked if we were hearing all three bills
at once and my understanding was that
yes during the exact session we were
going to consider them all together but
we weren't going to hear them
all at once from each speaker so can you
clarify this for me yeah that sure the
uh the way it was we have it posted in
the calendar we all three of them are
simultaneously being heard uh so that's
the way we posted it and and the reason
we did that there were a couple of
techniques we could have sent this to a
subcommittee to have the subcommittee
work things out uh but it was it's in my
judgment that we're uh we're up against
the calendar and uh we wouldn't have
time for that to happen unless we
retained uh the balance of these bills
so thank you for the clarification I see
it now and I understand thank you Mr
chair okay and representatively
uh thank you uh Mr chair
um Mr uh Christina
um now that we have brought up all three
of these bills
um I I have a question to ask you
um
especially this year with um the covid
um pandemic and money's coming in from
um different locations and unexpected
um expenses and so on I know places like
Nashua
have kind of delayed their public
hearing so that they can honestly work
right up to the the last minute of the
public hearing I'm sure it wouldn't be
that day they put pen to paper I'm sure
that there would be some heads up so
that the public would have it ahead of
time you did mention the 30 days do you
feel that
um this would create a um a less than um
I don't want to say perfect but less
than good even
um draft or proposed budget
for for the municipalities yeah thank
you for the question representative it
just seems that if a school board had or
or a select board has an extra 30 days
to work through their budget that they
have an extra 30 days to provide more
scrutiny um and and more attention to
the overall budget so again I think you
believe you're speaking to um
is it 4 15 I believe uh representative
so yeah yeah I mean if a school board
has an extra 30 days to to to to to to
to work through that budget and to make
the necessary changes we think that's
going to result in a better product at
the end representative Mr chair may I
ask a follow-up oh yes you can go ahead
thank you so much
um I I guess then my my next question
would be um because we do want
transparency and we do want to give the
public some time to do as um some of the
other speakers had mentioned
um in in your opinion what would be um a
fair time frame would you look at a week
five days
um because they don't believe that I
mean I know up to the last minute school
boards can be doing it but um what do
you think would be fair and uh
representative of of both parties yeah
thank you for the question that that's a
wonderful question representative
um you know we there's a balance too
between Just Between the calendar the
reality is you know the budget hearings
are are the middle of uh the municipal
budget hearings under RSA 32 or I'm just
going to say the middle of middle of
January January
um you know and and that week between
obviously Christmas and New Year's is is
challenging as well too for public
bodies so I mean I the seven days notice
perhaps I just I mean and I'm I'm sort
of spitballing there I'm not making a
specific recommendation but I mean I
think a week's notice to present a a
budget before the budget hearing would
give the give the you know the public
reasonable time to to to to to to to
give provided such scrutiny as they as
they as they desire
one additional question from
representative Porter before we go on to
additional folks to testify yes
Representatives thanks Mr chair uh thank
you Mr chair thank you thank you Miss
Dina
um
familiar with the budget committee
because my communities do not have one
but our school district is an sb2
school um school district and I know our
deliberative session this year happened
early in February if this 30 days were
to occur
in in a town or a school district that's
sb2
um how early would they have to have
their budget completed
in order
to meet that deadline for the
deliberative session sure thank you very
much for the question representative
even if you were an sb2 telling your
deliberative session for schools is
usually the first Saturday in February
my understanding I believe all the other
I'd have to go back and give RSA 40
another look in RSA 32 I believe the
timelines for posting your budget
hearings and and posting the initial
proposed budget are the same
um for sb2 as they are for for
traditional Town meetings I know the
Department of Revenue Administration
publishes a timeline every year for for
dates of when things need to be proposed
and when petitioned warrant articles
need to be need to be acted on and
things of that nature when they need to
be submitted you know for for
consideration
um but I believe the the budget hearings
um that are are listed in I believe
house bill 415. I believe that's the
thank you uh for those who have signed
up to uh indicate support or opposition
uh as a point of information on on 243
we had 21 in support
six opposed and one that's neutral
on 4 15 we had 16 in support 19 in
opposition and in on 454 we had 17 in
support and 19 in opposition
our next individual position excuse me
the chair to representative power in the
LOB
yes
um I had my hand raised um
for the past two speakers and I have two
brief questions if you will right ahead
I apologize for not not seeing you
so um for Ms Ayer well thank you for
allowing me to and ask these questions
so for Ms Fair
um
I missed the point as I was taking notes
she had described that um in her
experience there was a body that was
putting actual printouts of budgets on
the floor
um she um clarify which what body that
was
sure thank you so
we have a small town and when budget
season comes up we ask for the full
budget detail
we are typically not given it it's not
bombed out so we see each of the line
items so we rely on
the printed budget detail that we're
allowed to see
the annual reports with previous years
so we can then make comparisons and it
is very difficult to decide what we
should be voting on and what we should
be cutting back because
um
if for instance salt we were paying
twenty thousand dollars a year we have
15 miles of Road and because of that
when we can't calculate the years out in
advance and see the trends we didn't
realize that we only need a budget half
that for our salt so for the past five
or so years we've been budgeting double
the amount necessary that money in a
small community is very important and
that could have gone towards something
else and that's just one example of not
being able to see and that's why we
um many residents here in town support
this we actually took initiative last
year after I testified in February on on
1460 we put in a Citizens petition to
have the Border Selectmen include the
full budget detail in the annual report
at least thinking it was a step towards
transparency
um that passed overwhelmingly at Town
vote unfortunately the board of
selectman felt that that was not a vote
that needed to be honored so we still
are in the same boat and we're again
looking towards this bill and and hope
that it passes we do have QuickBooks we
have spreadsheets in town this is not
going to increase our expenditure from
what I can tell I don't know about large
towns or cities but as far as our town
our full budget detail would only be six
pages Max
so it for the most of the towns in New
Hampshire that are small
I feel that this this is probably more
economical because now they're not
printing out these papers or finding the
time to visit your town hall that's only
open six hours a week it's very limiting
representative power you had a follow-up
the second question I have is for
attorney Christina
and I'm seeking clarification on a point
um if governing bodies are already
perhaps generating budgets
electronically
um I'm seeking clarification as to what
specific software that
um you're referring to when you had
indicated in your testimony that um
upwards of you know 400 bodies in our
state being
um be required to purchase additional
software I'm trying to understand
um what that software may be thank you
thank you for the question
representative the the language that's
used in at least one of the bills is
industry standard software I readily
admit I don't know what the common
software is it's being used in school
districts I don't know if it's just
Excel I don't know if there's another
sort of accounting software that maybe
use I I simply don't know
um but we certainly did hear testimony
from one of the other Representatives I
forget specifically who but said that
she uses a different software for her
her private business or her private
company and that's industry standard for
for her or for at least for her for her
company
um at least standard for her company so
I mean I I I I I presume that Excel is
used extensively um across the state but
I can't speak to that specifically
thank you
okay uh next speaker we have
Miss Donna green who's would like to
thank you
thank you can you hear me yes you sound
fine go right ahead all right thank you
um I have timed my remarks to be uh
three and a half minutes but I would
also like to respond to attorney
Christina's objections uh with the
Indulgence of uh you Mr chairman thank
you
um honorable chairman and committee
members I'm Donna green president of the
school district governance Association
of New Hampshire we are a non-profit
privately funded organization
our members are mostly current or former
elected School District officials
many in our membership have experienced
ongoing problems obtaining timely and
useful budget information from their
school administrative units it is
completely unreasonable that elected
officials have to fight to receive
budgets in live spreadsheet form but
fight they must in many cases
we thank representative pamonti for
sponsoring this legislation
while I was a member of the Timberlane
Regional School Board I myself had to go
to the New Hampshire Supreme Court to
obtain my school district's budget in
full line item detail in spreadsheet
form
my SAU spent fifty thousand dollars in
legal fees to prevent me
or anyone else from having a useful
version of the 68 million dollar budget
thankfully I prevailed in the end
it sounds incredible doesn't it that an
SAU would see fit to spend its taxpayers
money this way but this is an indication
of how reluctant some public bodies are
to allow their elected overseers robust
financial information
while few elected officials have
resorted to the courts typically they
must be satisfied with much less
information than they would desire I
know of one situation two years ago
where a school budget committee chairman
asked the SAU business administrator for
the budget in spreadsheet form the next
meeting no spreadsheet so the board
voted as a whole to request a
spreadsheet the next meeting no
spreadsheet
so the board voted to demand a
spreadsheet four weeks went by before
they were given a spreadsheet and by
then the committee had just a few
meetings left so this deliberate delay
by the administration worked against the
elected officials prudent and proper
oversight of the budget and the public
interest
although we would like to think that
saus exist to ex to assist the elected
officials the reality is that
superintendents and saus have their own
powerful institutional interests that
are very often
in direct conflict with the interests of
the people the elected officials
represent the history of modern
education has been an astronomical
increase in administration and cost for
a very depressing decrease in
competencies
administrators always want more money
taxpayers want value for money these
changes to the law are needed to help
budget committees and school boards do
the job the public expects them to do
there are very few penalties for public
bodies who fail to follow Municipal
budget law at the very least elected
officials need the transparency tools to
properly supervise
and oversee the sizable tax dollars
entrusted to public bodies
sadly many sau's need to be compelled to
provide these tools and in a timely
fashion anyway anyone who testifies
differently is doing so in the interests
of sau's and paid administrators no
matter the name of their organization
I have submitted written testimony of a
somewhat difficult a different nature
um and to uh address attorney
Christina's objections the dra forms are
nowhere near the detail of what is
required or what is being asked for in
these bills no they are extremely high
level uh forms and I
I do not believe the dra would have any
interest in the voluminous my districts
um uh
my District's budget when it was printed
out was um just about six inches thick
I do not think the dra would like to see
that level of detail
although the budget committee certainly
would
no new software is required because
everyone is using electronic budgeting
software and all of that software
exports to spreadsheets
um as to
business administrators having to
respond to different formats and
different requests
that is a very simple uh issue of the
board as a whole taking a vote to decide
what kind of level of detail and in what
format they request and as you can see
it's a constant fight with the
administrators failing to provide it and
trying to run out the clock
as for 30 days notice I would just say
that Republic bodies are going to have
to schedule their deliberations so that
the public has and a better opportunity
to scrutinize the budget if you think 30
days is too long then perhaps it should
only be two weeks but there has to be
some uh some set
um
opportunity for uh for better
transparency and the fact that
collective bargaining might be going on
is completely independent of the
budgeting and um the budget you know
um the collective bargaining agreement
is voted on separately from the budget
so
um although I do believe that those two
should be
um occurring simultaneously
and point of fact they don't
um so
um
you know I
I appreciate your time today and I do
hope you'll support these bills and I
would be very happy to entertain some
questions thank you so much
I don't see any questions uh right now
so I'm gonna go on to our next speaker
uh Cordell Johnson from ahma who like to
speak in opposition of all three bills
and I and may I say that uh that I would
ask those who are speaking to uh to try
to be succinct as we are overdue in our
time slot for uh for this bill by about
15 minutes already so uh sorry sorry
that you're at the end of the of the
list Mr Johnson but uh that's where we
are
that's okay thank you Mr chairman
Cordell Johnston representing the New
Hampshire Municipal Association in
opposition to this bill
uh I want to point out there have been
several references to the bill that was
passed last year this is nothing like
House Bill 1460 as as the house passed
it last year uh House Bill 1460
uh merely said that the budget committee
may require a governing body to provide
its budget recommendations in full line
item detail in active spreadsheet format
so that was if the if the town or School
District's budget committee requests
that then the governing body shall
provide it but this was not a state
mandate as these bills are I'm gonna I'm
gonna Focus my testimony on the
amendment to House Bill 243 because it
seems to be the intent that everything
to be incorporated into that
um
and I I mostly agree with uh with what
Barrett Christina said and so I won't
repeat that
um although I think actually there's a
misreading of this 30-day requirement at
least as it's put into the bill
this is not a requirement that the
budget be done 30 days before the
hearing uh as it's written it's a
requirement that the department heads
get their revenue and expenditure to the
governing body at least 30 days before
the public hearing uh now that's usually
more like several months before the
public hearing so I don't know whether
that language was inserted in the wrong
place but
um
as it is that 30-day issue I don't think
is a problem but if if the intent is
that the budget be done 30 days before
the public hearing then that would be a
problem
our major concern is that this bill is
essentially trying to micromanage how
municipalities do their budgeting
um and based on the idea that what what
has worked for some towns uh should be
forced on every other town
um and you know we have municipalities
uh from uh all the way from Manchester
with a hundred and ten thousand
population to Hearts location with about
44.
what works for one doesn't necessarily
work for all of the others
um there in in the various bills and
again I'm focusing on the amendment to
House Bill 243 uh it talks about
publishing the draft budget Publishers
not defined there has been some
discussion on the committee about what
that means
I think the assumption is that it will
be published on the town's website
not every town has a website that may uh
come as a surprise but I know there are
at least half a dozen towns that still
do not have a website
uh this also would apply to Village
districts
uh and a lot of very tiny village
districts and I'm guessing that some of
them don't have websites either
um the requirements that uh budgets be
published in full line item Detail full
line item detail is not defined and so
people can have I've asked uh probably
10 different people who work with
budgets what is the definition of full
line item detail and they say well I
kind of know what it means but there is
there is no standard definition so
people are going to have different ideas
about that
um
note that this this bill applies to uh
towns school districts and Village
districts it does not apply to the state
or the counties so we're not requiring
current this this would not require that
the state publish its budget in this
manner and the state doesn't
uh if you ask the house finance
committee for a copy of the state budget
you're not going to get full line item
detail
um and I don't know about County budgets
but I I suspect the same is true there
um I actually agree with much of what uh
Ms Green said about uh being up being
about a school board being unable to get
the full line item detailed budget from
the superintendent
um there's no reason that the school
board shouldn't be able to get the the
full line item detailed budget if it
exists from the superintendent but
that's an issue between the the school
board and the administration
this this bill doesn't deal with that
this bill says the school the school
board or the Select Management the town
um what what Ms Green and some of the
other Witnesses have talked about I
think is really a frustration with being
able to get information
um it should be understood that whatever
form of budget the governing body has
you already have a right to get that
from the governing body you can walk
into town hall or you can call or email
and say I want to see the budget that
the that the Selectmen are working on or
that the school board is is working on
and under RSA 91a they have to give that
to you and they have to give it to you
in in paper form if you want it or if
you wanted an electronic form and they
have it in electronic form and they can
give it to you that way they have to
um if if you wanna
amend the law to to make it clear that
that whatever the governing body has
must be made available to the citizens
that's fine except I think that's
already clear
in RSA 91a
um and if there are people who are
unable to get that then it may be
because someone's violating RSI RSA 91a
but that's that's a different issue
um and
um that's already the law and that's
just a matter of someone voting
um I don't think it requires a change to
the law so I'll end there but I mean
just basically Our concern is
micromanaging uh Municipal budgeting and
saying you know the state doesn't have
to do this but every city in town in the
state does have to do it
I'd be happy to try to answer any
questions representative magic Pootie
thank you Mr chair thank you Mr Johnson
for taking my question from your
testimony and having served on school
board and other uh boards here it seems
like this is
putting the responsibility on the local
government
unfunded mandates
and expecting our professionally hired
people
needing to
do I mean hamstringing their ability to
do their job is that am I correct
well I I think to some extent I and I'm
not going to overstate it I'm I'm sure
there are many municipalities where uh
they have people who can do this already
and they have the software and and they
probably can do it without any
additional expense
but I suspect there are somewhere that's
not the case and if if it does require
any additional expense and I'm not
saying it will but if it does that would
okay uh right now I see no additional
questions
um
hoping to testify
uh chair I think we have one other
speaker if I have it right reconciling
the three testimony list and that might
be Eric power
or they would be Eric power if I re if
I've reconciled all the lists correctly
okay Mr power would you like to uh
hello this is uh Eric power can you hear
me yes you sound fine go right ahead
thank you I'm a resident of Brookline
and I always also uh the chair of a
study committee to look at a budget
Committee in Brookline it was chartered
last year during our town meeting
so as the chair of that I looked at all
things budget committee over the past
year and we're actually having a warn
article to adopt the budget committee at
this town meeting
but in the process of that I've talked
to many budget communities in advisory
budget committees across the state and
it is something that I've come across in
talking to them
learning about budget committees is that
this is a problem that budget committees
cannot get the budget information that
they need in a timely manner and that's
one of the disadvantages I've seen of
having a budget committee because they
have a fiduciary responsibility to do
the budget but then they're prevented
from getting the information in the form
that's needed that's why I think that
this bill is very very important most
almost all municipalities are using
software this is not really putting any
burden on anybody
to provide that to the budget committee
and it actually makes it easier for them
to do their job so I would recommend for
this uh for this bill and thank you for
hearing my testimony
any are there any further questions
from the committee for those who have
testified
seeing none uh we're going to end the uh
the hearings on two four three four one
five and four five four
I'm going to move on to our next bill
552 is a a bill about uh
a suspending uh revaluations of uh of
property
uh do we have a a member that wishes to
testify that may be a sponsor of this
bill it's not indicated to me on my list
of those who wish to testify but is that
uh
well Mr chair I do see the prime I
believe I see the prime sponsor uh
representative Jackie Callie Pitts and
I've allowed her to uh to speak
perhaps we have an immune issue with
Miss Pitts
I I do not
see Mr chair
representative Abram Center
representative fellows if you would like
I can introduce the bill while we're
trying to work on getting representative
Kelly Pitts in go right ahead
thank you Mr chair members of Municipal
County government for the record I am
representative Jim majori representing
the town of Northampton Rockingham
District 22 and I'm here to introduce
House Bill 552 relative to property tax
valuations
and I would be happy to take any
questions as long as they are only what
you want for lunch
okay uh why don't we why don't we look
Mr
uh Bernice
who opposes the bill
we have him on the line
uh sorry hold on
uh we have
Mr Bernice and I uh you should be good
to go I've unmuted um can you hear me
yes go right here yes uh good morning uh
Mr chairman members of the committee my
name is Norm Bernice I am the director
of assessing for the town of Hanover
um I uh luckily or unluckily uh assume
this job a week before covet hit last
year and then we were under a board
order uh New Hampshire Board of tax land
appeals ordered revaluation to be
completed in 2021
we are well on our way to doing that
um I I think
um that uh other communities using
cobiza as an excuse to not do the job of
uh making sure that taxes are fair is
probably
um not a good thing in fact we've had
great success with covid believe it or
not because everyone is home so we've
communicated uh actually well well above
what we would normally communicate with
with our citizenry
we've reached out to them in many ways
we do uh we're actually doing some uh
internal inspections uh being social
distance we're also um
uh doing uh FaceTime and zoom meetings
and having them walk through the house
and and and having a quite an
interaction with the with our uh our
community so we're looking at it as a as
a success at this point and I think
to suspend what what appears to me to be
picking up all building permits
just stop stopping the assessing
function of valuing property I think
creates an inequity in and of itself
um and and I opposed that and I think
Hanover is doing the right thing and uh
I'm sure there are a lot of other
contractors out there that um have
contracts and and uh it just would uh
probably hurt their ability to do their
job if the towns were to uh uh try to
spend the contract because of covid
um I don't know what the impetus of the
bill was was it just a safety issue or
was it um Rising values of residential
property as opposed to commercial
property and then having a tax shift so
I I don't know what the what the impetus
of the bill is and we haven't heard of
obviously we're gonna hear from the
sponsor at some point but
time to Hanover and myself were were
opposed to this bill and I'll take any
questions uh Miss Pitts has uh been able
to navigate through through our uh our
Zoom meeting so if you could take
yourself off mute I would certainly uh
representative Maggiore is any way to
get her up or mute from your desktop I'm
certainly trying oh there you go
we might need representative Pitts a
calling from her phone I'll be looking
to Christine for some help too because
it looks like everything on this end she
should be okay but clearly not miss
Pitts uh can you give us a thumbs up if
I don't think she can hear us either so
uh
we'll we'll see if we can get her on the
telephone uh like we did with uh
representative Gilman earlier
uh oh it looks like I'm getting a
message from representative Gallagher he
does anybody else having trouble with
so representative Gallagher um what I
may suggest you do as a first effort to
troubleshoot is to log off the zoom and
re
and re-engage the zoom to see if that
helps uh your connection try that as a
first uh a first effort to troubleshoot
I don't know if you can hear me
yes okay yes is that Miss Pitts no this
is uh representative treeleven oh yes go
ahead
I just needed to check my audio Mr chair
but now we can hear you thank you now be
quiet
and I've sent an email to representative
uh Callie Pitts to see if maybe she can
call in from her phone
down there
okay we can see her
yeah
okay well in the meantime let's go maybe
because of the wind and the power
outages and stuff over the last couple
of days people having difficulty with
their phone lines
do we have uh uh Jim misho on the line
Sorry I will go back
yes and
um I will say that he is all set to
speak but let's see if that actually
happens
can you hear me now yeah yeah right
ahead thank you very much for the
opportunity to testify in House Bill 552
for the record my name is Jimmy show I'm
the chief assessor for the town of
Hudson New Hampshire I'm also chair of
the legislative committee for the New
Hampshire Association of assessing
officials I am speaking on my own behalf
I'm just giving you a little bit of
background
um I I'm not sure if this bill was
intended to be amended prior to this
hearing I had heard some rumors about
that but all I can go is based upon the
writing of the bill as proposed
um it is frankly way way too late in the
process to suspend appraisal assessment
and valuation updating for the 2021
property tax year
New Hampshire Municipal assessing
officials have already done literally
thousands of changes to property values
across the state as associated with
items like building permits new
construction property that has had fires
and been damaged properties that were
partially complete prayers of April 1st
2020 that are now complete subdivisions
site plans zoning changes zoning
variances I could go on I don't want to
take up all my time discussing that
it would be literally impossible to
efficiently and accurately unspill the
milk undo all that work
never mind how impeccable it would be to
the state's taxpayers it would be a
catastrophe for the goals of fair and
equal assessments throughout the state
further who's going to pay for the state
mandating the undoing of all this work
where is the fiscal note where's the
budgetary appropriation from the state
to pay Municipal assessing officials
budgets both contractor and employee I
don't see that proposed
in the budget process from the fall of
2020 in anticipation of the 21 property
tax year
New Hampshire municipalities typically
anticipate how much tax-based growth
change is going to occur and in part
based budgetary appropriation decisions
on that now if values are not allowed to
be updated that is going to potentially
I I think I might have found there we go
representative Pitts if you could Callie
Pitts if you can hear me I have you on
mute it seems that with your call-in
it's causing that
um and and so I'm just going to ask if
if you unmute can you hear us and can we
foreign
can I testify
or somebody else I can't
hello
yes we can hear you representative Pitts
I'm just curious if Mr misho is is I
don't know either
I I will I will finish up
can you hear me now yes okay so so I
will finish up um if the point is to
delay any potential tax increase tax
increase based on Market escalation and
sales prices delaying for one year will
only likely exacerbate the assessment
difference and resulting tax differences
for the following year
this simply isn't a good public policy
bill and I would ask for the committee
to itl it
that are all my comments I'll answer any
questions and I'll stay on the line
chairman Dolan
you have two questions here in the LLB
thank you uh yes uh who who has a
question
representative lasalles representative
Styles go ahead please
yes a question for Mr Michelle uh we
haven't heard yet what the purpose
or goal of this uh bill is but if it is
to discontinue assessments because of
difficulties with the covid crisis uh I
would like for you to reflect uh if you
have seen those types of difficulties
and how easy was it for you to get
around it
so uh certainly commensurate with with
most Industries uh the pandemic has had
a a fairly uh good impact upon not good
but for a fairly difficult impact on on
doing our job
um in in Hudson
um you know we've established continuity
operations plans we've gone half remote
half in person
um for a good part of last year we were
not going inside properties we were
accepting people's videos
um we were accepting information from
obviously from the building department
inspectional Services
um you know just doing our best to do a
work around and obtain the most accurate
data that we can
um we didn't just stop doing our job
because it was difficult we just did our
best to work around it we followed
Department of Revenue Administration uh
technical information releases on this
we communicated with other communities
uh what are you doing in your community
that seems to be working
but you know in in Hudson because of a
you know a higher uh positivity rate for
much of last year uh certainly in the
fall
um you know we we really didn't do a lot
of interior review but we did our best
to work around it
What would
how would you
assess the quality of your Assessment
program
uh during the crisis what what kind of a
grade would you give it
you know
um I'm not prepared to answer that
question because it's like we're still
in the middle of it towards the end of
it maybe
um you know
that that that kind of uh after the fact
action report I just I haven't done that
for my own board of selectment at this
point so I'm not so sure I'm prepared to
testify in that this morning
do you have a degree of confidence in
your assessments
yes I I do have a degree of confidence
in the assessment
um you know even before pandemic you
know certainly there's properties that
we never got into and
um you use your best education and
experience and knowledge to do your best
estimate of what is on the inside of
that property uh many times you have
some historical data
um you might be able to obtain some
other data from the building permit
process obviously and certainly being on
the property site whether it's on the
site or from the street
um you can you can glean a fair
indication
um you would think about the interior of
the property if it's if it looks okay on
the outside it's probably okay on the
inside though that's not always the case
um I I I'd give a fair degree of
confidence in what we've done in terms
of assessing property
thank you Mr mishogi thank you sir
Miss Pitts are you uh are you still with
us
I'm not a Miss I'm representative uh I
am
oh please and I'm I I'm a little bit is
this chairman Dolan I don't know who am
I speaking to because I got out of the
meeting yes it is um I'm a little bit
upset that I wasn't allowed to give a
little bit of the history and the
motivation first so I'm gonna go very
fast
with this what this was was a was a
Portsmouth Bill basically the selectman
asked me the city council asked me to
put this bill in and I will advise you
that the same exact verbiage that is in
your hand now or that is in the bill now
is in Senate Bill 102 which is an
Omnibus Bill
and so and and I'm sponsor on part of
that Omnibus as well what the motivation
behind this was as many people as we
were going around
said you know with property values going
up so high
in in this particular area and lots of
other areas I know Conway's experience
the same thing other towns are
experiencing the same thing because we
are having an influx of people people
are being paid
more
than they're asking for their property
so that's good for the people
but the people who are moving in with
the taxes sometimes that's not good and
it might not be good for The Neighbor
Next Door whose property value will go
up
when this was put in that was meant to
stem the mandatory five-year assessment
some towns don't assess every year
because they don't have permanent
assessors like we do and so this year
after this bill was filed I was informed
that yeah don't worry about it
Portsmouth isn't going to reassess this
year
so it doesn't have to be done in our
town
thinking about it a little bit more
I thought the rest of the state there
are places that are having a problem and
all it was meant to do was put off that
mandatory five years assessment for one
year
that could cause as as someone stated
um
tax shock
in the second year
it wouldn't stop taxes it would use the
um through April 1st of 2020 so it's not
going to stop taxes it's not going to
change the education portion of what
goes to the state
but it's going to keep the line for some
people again as an extraordinary measure
only because it is for the covid-19 for
the purpose of covet 19. we're coming
out of covid-19 now I I think I believe
the governor has done an excellent job
and we are starting to move forward
and in my own opinion I did not want to
take
additional property taxes as a step
backward that's all there was no no
putting assessors out of their jobs no
no use the 2020 and and try to hold the
line for one year I think most places
are doing that not only holding the line
but a lot of towns including my city
including my own
uh cutting budgets and
that also is going to come because
sooner or later you have to pay the
piper but I think right now in this
particular time
too many people especially Property
Owners uh are hurting and so our
landlords I mean it goes across the
board and it's got to be equal it's it's
got to be just an equal so we mentioned
the other sras that's all it is it
wasn't a mean-spirited bill it wasn't a
bill to
do any harm it was supposed to do good
my recommendation on this bill
would be that it be held and I know the
the sponsor who a couple of the sponsors
I said go ahead pull your name off the
bill that's fine with me because they
were it's not going to affect the
property the education tax no it won't
but it may affect other things so I just
would my recommendation and it's only my
recommendation would be that it be
retained
and take a look at what's happening in
the Senate bill
I'm not so sure Omnibus bills really go
anywhere
and then this can always be itl later
I don't I I believe there is a need out
there to do something
and this was just an attempt I believe
you got a letter from Maya Beckstead
uh we may have I I don't have my hands
on it right now
okay I believe that there was a letter
from uh the mayor of Portsmouth saying
that this is not really a Portsmouth
bill it is a state Bill and that's the
end of it I mean that that's where it is
so I I am done and I
I know that there are all good
intentions and if the bill fails it
fails but I certainly hope
that somebody can come up with something
to offer relief
to the property owners around the state
especially those who have been in the
state and have owned their homes for a
long time and who are struggling
thank you that's all
thank you representative Maggiore do we
have anyone else that uh
has indicated they want to offer
testimony
we have them well I'm sorry
yeah she's representative power I I was
multitasking earlier and I know that
representative Tripp had his hand raised
previously did was his question
addressed I don't believe it was the
representative Tripp do you have a
question
well my question thank you for taking my
question my question was the same as uh
uh representative lasalles you know what
is the purpose of this bill
now apparently it's just a delay uh
the the purpose of the bill was there's
a mandatory mandatory five-year
assessment so that if if towns and
whatever every five years you at least
have to reassess
and so that that mandatory assessment
for towns who assess every year or every
other year not going to bother them but
for that mandatory five-year assessment
uh at this particular time would be
waived for one year for the covid-19
only
follow up please
yes I I
go ahead I'm having a very hard time
understanding go ahead
well
we're in the same situation I have a
hard time understanding too so
apparently there are some towns that uh
assess weight
the entire five years before doing any
assessment so there's going to be a
a tack shock if they have to try this
year well uh
it would it would also appear that uh
since
people haven't had their taxes increased
for five years that they they benefited
from a lower tax payment you know uh
how does uh
they're pushing this off another year to
I think it benefits the town because
people who are struggling are going to
be struggling are struggling in other
ways
and I think that
people and and again I haven't gone from
town to town because I like everybody
else I've been
in my four walls but I do believe that
once this once people are struggling if
they come to the point where they're
having problems with their
pain especially their home tax that
threatens the basic need for shelter and
I think once you threaten that basic
need for shelter then you come upon
other problems you come upon social
problems you come upon uh police
problems you come up you come upon all
kinds of problems the idea is to like
release the valve on the pressure cooker
thank you uh do we do we have uh
represent Gallagher the I'm not sure do
um no I
representative power do you have you
have a yes um representative McDonald's
would like to ask a question okay
um
so if we patch this
yo
you're gonna have to deal with it four
more years to be compliant with the
no you would have to do it the next year
we are suspending for one year
is that what it says that five-year
mandate that that the legislature quite
frankly put in
put in so we are suspending that for one
year
um
that's all not paying your taxes but you
would pay the rate from 20
20.
okay uh
and you will follow up Mr chairman yeah
go ahead and have a follow-up
[Music]
that was one of those would you believe
questions uh representative Kelly Pitts
I believe anything that Municipal and
county says because I think you uh
people are more knowledgeable on this
subject than than I am
but I do think that there is some need
to provide for the individual taxpayer
not only businesses but the individual
taxpayer
um
some relief and this was one way to do
it it may not be the best and I'm going
to admit that
but
all it does is say that we can suspend
that one year
of
assessment that's mandated in the law
that's all representative and if there's
a better way to do that I respect you
for that representative Kelly Pitts this
is uh chairman Dolan I just as a kind of
a follow-up question
you representative McDonald's question
so if one third of their Town based on
their re-evaluation taxes were going to
go down
by suspending this that would not allow
their taxes to go down how what what
would you say that we would have to say
to those people that were anticipating a
tax reduction based on new valuation
based on the value on the valuation for
um that I would say is going to be an
equitable
decision for those people whose taxes
won't go now
okay any one-third and based on
one-third now what if you have the full
thing you are suspending for one year
that five-year valuation so you don't do
the evaluation every
every five years I'm assuming
so that you certainly can adjust the tax
rate that way
I would look at this as enabling but we
couldn't do that because we had to say
that this is universal because part of
the Constitution it has to be
Equitable across the board okay I'd like
to kind of wrap here uh representative I
would too I have you have a final
question
no I I would just like to say that I
hold on a second I came with since we
question from Representatives Davis I'm
a half hour late for another meeting go
ahead
thank you representative Kelly Pitts for
taking my question just very sure are
you aware of any other states
that are trying to implement similar
efforts
no I am not thank you
all right well thank you for staying
over representative I appreciate your
testimony and good luck with your with
your next meeting that's on aggregated
community power please
I I would just say this
if this one goes down you know I don't
get heartburn over it but it is going to
be contained in that Senate bill which
may or may not come across so the idea
uh foreign it's not something that's
out of the question
I didn't go soliciting sponsors because
a lot of people were hesitant but if you
look at Senate Bill 10102 you will see
that there's quite a few sponsors and
and I don't know if that's going to be I
don't know what's going to happen to it
hasn't been scheduled yet so I would ask
you to please look at that as well and
see if there's some Equitable solution
somewhere
for the people who are hurting that's
all and thank you very much for your
time and allowing me to speak to you
thank you for your testimony at this
point I'm going to close the hearing Mr
chair thank you before you close the
chair we do have
we we do have two other people who
signed up for this bill
uh who are on the line uh Paul Smith and
Mike torello
I I see that they're both from out of
state is uh can we can we uh
quickly get a uh
understanding of of their interest of
why their interest in this New Hampshire
bill
Mr Smith are you on the line
he's on the line and unmuted or asked to
unmute
go ahead Mr Smith thank you Mr chairman
committee members can you guys hear me
we can but I'd first like you to address
that that indicate you were from Dover
Massachusetts and and what is your your
interest in this particular Bill sure
yeah I'm the Chief Executive Officer of
Vision Government Solutions we provide
uh revaluation services and camera
software which is the assessing software
to 57 New Hampshire assessing offices
and we are currently the leading
projects with Manchester Seabrook Nashua
Salem Amherst and Hanover
so we're also the largest revaluation
vendor in New England so we we feel like
we have some important insight into how
this change may impact New Hampshire
taxpayers cities and towns and and
everyone involved
okay and and uh could you also bring up
uh
uh Mike torello uh representative
Maggiore he's from Hudson Mass and uh
he's from Vision Government Solutions uh
also from out of state and I'd like to
understand what his interest in this
bill is too awesome all set to go thank
you I've asked Mike I've asked Mike to
join me Mike works with me at vision and
he's been in he's been leading projects
for over 30 years and it works with many
of the towns in New Hampshire and I just
thought he'd provide a good expert voice
for additional questions but I'll speak
for for our company to my understanding
you you have a financial interest uh in
completing your obligations that you may
have been contracted with by various New
Hampshire towns is is there something
beyond that that you'd like to convey to
us that uh because we are beyond our our
uh our time schedule here I'd like to
conclude this hearing but if you have
something new that hasn't been testified
on already and if you just want to
indicate that that you you have a
relationship with several towns that
you'd like to complete is there anything
beyond that
I think there's a couple of points that
haven't been made that would be worth
having been heard
um that have not anything to do with
visions Financial interests but I
certainly freely acknowledge that we
have a financial interest in in
assessing in New Hampshire for sure
I understand the time constraints so let
me ask you to see if you can wrap it in
a couple of minutes
yeah of course yep so let me just first
make a couple of points to answer some
questions that were asked by other folks
uh Massachusetts Rhode Island
Connecticut are not doing this
um I believe uh one of the
representatives asked that question so I
can confirm that that is not happening
um
and um in terms of the key points number
one I just wanted to highlight that as I
read the bill I did not take away
um
what it was designed to do I think it
will do things that are unintended
um additionally
um one of the key points I want to make
is when when our customers do updates to
their values they do it so that they can
stay closer to the 90 to 110
Equalization rate that's required as
part of their reassessment and for many
of those communities that we're working
with right now
um they're already in the 70s which
means that their Equalization rate is in
the 70s So currently if they do their
update taxpayers will face a 30 to 40
percent increase in property taxes
already if they push it off another year
and they drop into the 60s we could be
talking about a 50 increase in property
taxes and so that has a very serious
negative impact obviously on taxpayers
it will increase appeals and it will
create an economic shock to taxpayers
so I just wanted to highlight the fact
that doing this actually will reduce the
the public impact and allow people to
better plan and manage their finances
second I thought it was important to
mention that we're referring to equity
here uh where what we have to do is make
sure we maintain equity which assessors
have worked for decades to create if we
pass this bill and we're not allowed to
include things like new constructions
addition to homes new hotels new
factories none of those values will be
incorporated and so if we're trying to
take care of folks who can't afford to
pay their taxes
um we're not necessarily helping them
we're just giving a free ride to people
who just made investments in their
properties
and that's not maintaining equity and
then the third thing is I think it's
going to create a cost for cities and I
think uh uh Jim Rashad made this point
earlier but if you've done half of an
update and you've paid for half that
update and then you stop
and you need to redo it next year you're
going to have to repay for that half of
an update plus what you didn't do so
you're going to be paying 2x for the
same project and you're going to
constrain the industry because you're
going to create this entire this glut of
projects that have to be done at one
time
and that's going to raise costs on the
towns to do those projects so I think
those are all really important
considerations and they have nothing to
do with visions financial interest they
simply will impact the community and I
do want to say I understand that the
sponsors of this bill have the best
intentions and I understand why you know
it would seem like a good idea I just
think there's unintended consequences
for something like this that extend far
beyond the reach of the bill and sort of
as it's laid out
well thank you can I just add one thing
this is Mike torello yes go ahead okay
just to clarify if the equalization's at
75 and then it goes back up to the 95 it
doesn't mean that that percentage
because it goes up 30 or 35 that the tax
they're gonna go just for clarity it
just means that right now there's
inequities some maybe at 75 some
properties maybe at 85 some may be at
65. it's the median is at 75. by
bringing the percentage back up to like
say 9 5 100 it brings all the other
things that might be at 65 or 85 back up
to a hundred that's where you get that
one-third go up one third go down and so
forth so the percentage isn't that taxes
are going to go up 35 or 40 percent is
that the percentage of Assessments going
to go to an accurate number close to 100
for all properties
this is vital for consistency and fair
taxation for the people and I just want
to make that clear thank you for that
testimony at this point I'm I'm going to
close the hearing on on this bill and
we're going to move uh I'm gonna pass
the virtual gavel to uh
representative piamonte would you like
to take a five minute recess uh
representative piamonte before you start
okay we'll take a five minute recess and
we'll we'll start back up with house
bill 573.
[Music]
thank you
I I think there's a problem I have to
I did uh mute the room so if folks in
the lob could turn on the audio before
um
representative CLE can you hear me I can
hear you fine yes yeah I think the
problem is actually with representative
majori's audio
um he sounds like he's a robot yes he
does that's what I was getting so yeah
it's uh unfortunately it's you
representative maturity I thought you
were a robot I thought you were the king
you can't be you want a robot
foreign
representative power does it sound wacky
there if we're speaking no
good yeah we still can't hear the room
because the room is still muted you'll
have to go to the computer near the TV
and while they're doing that we will try
representative Klee again
can you hear me
that's all better oh good thank you oh
representative Maggiore can you hear me
yes sir okay
um there was a request made that uh if
someone's here if you make a note that
someone here wants to speak to they uh
you introduce who they are because they
sometimes can't see or tell who's
speaking in the lob and Diane's going to
do the same thing Fair Point thank you
noted
okay is everybody ready
[Music]
yeah okay we're going to introduce uh uh
house house bills 573 which is relative
to the use of certain large retail
properties
um
uh representative majority do we have uh
representative
on the line
we do and should be all set to go Mr
chair
okay
um go ahead you have testimony are you
introduced to Bill go ahead
yes thank you Mr chairman
um for the record my name is
representative John ginigian I represent
Rockingham District 8 which is Salem
um I want to introduce uh House Bill 573
and the main impetus of this uh a couple
some of my constituents in Salem who own
businesses have come to me and basically
um as we know commercial commercials
really struggling right now and
especially brick and mortar commercial
and um so this bill
um helped is looking to help the process
be a little bit easier for the for these
landlords and small businesses that go
through tremendous cost uh on a change
of views
um now we're trying to limit uh how much
obviously towns want to be in control of
this so we want to limit what we're
really doing here but uh large for those
who may not know large retail does not
mean a huge store it means they're
they're selling large items like
Furniture cars uh boats you know things
that are obviously large items and so
we're also not talking about large box
stores like Walmart and things like that
because we're this bill as you may
notice on on item Roman numeral one
limits this to fifteen thousand square
foot
um establishments and the other thing we
do is if something is already zoned
um if it's grandfathered commercial we
we don't allow that to just have a
change of use to another commercial
because the fact that it's grandfathered
is probably in a different Zone and the
town probably needs to look at that
um and basically the the key here is
that only and and as you look at the
bill you can see exactly what is allowed
but um basically the key here is trying
to make sure parking doesn't become a
problem whatever the new use is must fit
within that zone number one and number
two parking must not overflow onto
adjacent Lots
you know and or it must
um be in keeping with existing town or
city ordinances
so um with that um I'll take any
questions
okay representative the jury
um we have uh any questions to this uh
I see that Mr chair uh there is one hand
raised Mr chair but I do believe it's
Sheila Johansen who is here to speak
about another bill
um and and she has put her hand down so
okay that's confirmed thank you I do see
now that representative stavis's hand is
representative for taking my question
does this bill anticipate any
residential or mixed use
changes for the large retail operations
that you're addressing
no I think we're we're basically trying
to focus on Commercial only
um
because mixed use you're right is going
to is going to bring residential into it
and that the intention would not to do
that now if that committee feels that's
important we can look at it or or that
this bill is not sufficiently
needs more clarification I'm open to
that as well follow up Mr chair
if it's in a commercial area
really shouldn't be
it shouldn't be an issue
I'm just trying I'm on the planning
board in Lebanon I'm trying to Envision
this situation here
and if there was a a store that wanted
to change its use to another store
I don't believe the planning board here
would get involved
there may be some towns that that might
yeah that might not be the case
um there are many towns where it has to
go through planning or zoning and in
that case can cause a very expensive
transition uh for the new tenant they
may have to do traffic studies they may
have to do all sorts of things that
effectively
were most likely done by the previous
um
situation and because the the parking is
already allocated for that previous one
this bill tries to say let's let's help
these small businesses and not have them
jump through a whole bunch of Hoops if a
town already doesn't require that that's
that's fine I think this would be
targeting towns who are requiring the
extra steps
chair
representative question here and that
will be sorry representative Tripp you
have a question
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question uh
when I was reviewing this uh
Bill last night the uh the thing that
struck me right off was uh there's no
mention of uh
what the what the new use would be and
certain zones have uh uh certain
permanent uses
uh eliminating the check
introduce a use
that's not permitted in this particular
Zone
so
the intention would be if a use is not
permitted in that zone then
it's still not permitted this is only
trying to uses that are already
permitted in that zone it's trying to
make sure that this this change to you
know and you'll see paragraph three
change of category of uses from large
retail and again large is is large items
not because nothing because nothing
larger than 15 000 square feet of space
is allowed here so change of use from
large retail to retail
um and so if it's not a lot if if it's
not allowed then this wouldn't
um you know it wouldn't take so if if
and I'm open to fine-tuning this if
there's something in there where people
feel that it is opening the door to
allowing anything that's not allowed in
that zone or we could add a sentence I'm
open to that because that's not the
intent the intent is to only allow
what's what's allowed and to make sure
that new businesses are not undergoing
big expenses by asking for new traffic
studies and things like this when that
item would already or that you should
okay uh there are any more questions for
I see no questions at this time and I
will end the hearing on 573
Mr chair well I'm sorry I didn't mean to
stutter there
um there were no more questions but on
573 there were two other people listed
um Adam Abbas and Cordell Johnson from
the nhma and I and I do see that they
are on the line so I I don't know if by
law we need to reopen the hearing or
what you need to do or of course it's
your discretion I I if that was a
mistake I apologize for that and I will
and I have uh welcome Mr Abbas and uh
and Mr Johnson also into the meeting
okay thank you can you guys hear me
established does not have any questions
it's representative too my fault I my
bad on that one my apologies
thank you
okay
hello
yes
I can never can everybody hear me this
is Adam Abbas okay
that's confusion thank you so much and
thank you for the opportunity to briefly
discuss um what um the bill uh from my
understanding is and why I support this
is um for for
um
stores that are fifteen thousand square
feet or less
that are selling retail large retail
items and what's great about it is it
it's if you want to do a restaurant or
these other uses for this specific bill
you still have to go through the same
um Prestige or locally depending on the
town uh all this is doing is saying I'll
give a great example um if if there's a
furniture store and they want to sell
in some towns for instance Our Town
Salem New Hampshire
there's a there's a ordinance where
you've got to go for a change of use if
that furniture store wants to now if it
goes out of business and they want to
sell uh small items now so it's just the
selling of goods or services they would
have to go in and get a change of use
for what is we refer to in the industry
as regular retail so it's actually the
size of the item that uh that with this
specific Bill pertains to it doesn't
allow these 15 000 square feet and under
uh businesses to go in and open up a
daycare or a movie theater or things
like that it's it's just from large
retail items to regular retail items and
um it gives it gives us a little
flexibility in the industry I've been a
property manager for 17 years seen a lot
of things going in note
um the uh
property owners and managers have a
vested interest to not least
spaces to uses that are going to cause a
problem uh if it if it did they wouldn't
get their rents they would be sued by
their neighbors if they cause problems
so and uh to be honest you the market
usually corrects it where a tenant will
they have very strict requirements so
for instance if you had a fifteen
thousand square foot large furniture
store large retail and uh like let's say
a supermarket wanted to come in and
there was only 30 spaces in a town like
ours they just simply wouldn't lease so
the market would basically dictate a lot
of this this is just giving a little bit
more flexibility and not to question you
know what I have a furniture store but
now I want to I want to add uh lamps or
small little uh wet wipes at the door a
little rack of wet wipes the Mind
violation of a uh of an ordinance so
that's kind of what it is it's it's um
it's definitely
um retails evolved we got a lot of
competition with uh with Amazon and all
these guys and you know a lot of uh
spaces don't they they don't really um
to avoid the uh the red tape left and
right they still have to go in for their
building permits which is that none of
that changes they have to go in they
have to meet fire code
they need a certificate of occupancy
this is just for you know what I it
saves me a step to uh to to just do
retail large retail to regular retail
and I've actually done it myself and
it's it it was um believe it or not the
sound flooring planning board's great
um but you know I I and I'm sure many
others are too but this just kind of
makes it Statewide to a little push in
that direction to give landlords that
that flexibility so that the costs
aren't uh passed on to small businesses
as well sometimes they pay for it
sometimes landlords it's based on what
they agree upon I just want to thank
everyone again for their time and uh
much appreciated
okay thank you very much uh represent uh
representative majority I see three
hands up including your own would you
like to go ahead I'll defer to
representative uh Davis and
representative Porter because I don't
know what the order was
very well uh representative Porter had
who establishes the ordinances that
prevent
or allow only large retail in a space is
that the town or city or is that the
state
I guess right right now it's the um it
would be the the town itself would be
depending on what um they could put it
on ballot and the voters can vote for it
but this is kind of a little bit of net
to over to kind of do a non something
non-enabling to the town uh because some
towns may have different boards and and
um we you know it's uh I think that that
is the best I can answer it
I have a follow-up Mr chair yes yeah go
it would require all communities to
allow this change
correct to just enable them to allow
this change yeah it would it would
require them to to just uh to allow the
change of use without going for a change
of use from large retail if that they
even sometimes may not even have large
retail in their ordinance it could just
be retail across the board I'm not too
sure I never really looked into that but
I'm I'm more familiar with locally here
in Salem which isn't necessarily a city
and it's not really a small rural town
it's a nice medium there and I do know
that it's required and you know me and
basically almost every commercial
landlord would agree
um there should be no reason why uh why
I don't see any of those anyone in that
industry would disagree but um you know
and and by the way the parking there's
language in this bill that says that you
can't overflow and I I assume that they
would they would be in a little world of
trouble if if you if you went and
violated that that that as that's part
of the ordinance being proposed or
rather the bill
but that but that wasn't my question my
question is
who sets up this ordinance and if why
why would the state have to get involved
if this is a local ordinance issue I
guess that's my question I guess because
it's a measure to support small business
across the board in the state of New
Hampshire and um I the reason that a lot
of we felt is very conservative and uh
in nature is that it doesn't cost the
state of dime so you know there's a lot
of things being done for small
businesses which are great by the way
with the state with with the governor
and everything
um but you know no loans here no no I
mean sometimes uh businesses are
rejected good wholesome businesses a lot
of people ask why this business is in
town or this one isn't in town sometimes
because it's a change of use and no one
wants to absorb the cost and sometimes
that change of use isn't even a high
impact this this really doesn't big box
guys are still going to have to go in
and and do their change of use there's
no big box operator that's 15 000 square
feet or less we're talking home Depot is
120 000 square feet this is like 10 of
the floor not even 10 of the floor space
so you know so that's kind of it's it's
more this is more of a very specific
change of use change of uses are still
going to have to happen in a hundred
other circumstances this is just for
large retail Goods to regular retail
Goods
um and for this specific uh proposed
bill but yes the the towns do decide and
this was this is something that would be
a a more friendly and create a slightly
more uh friendly environment for the
state as a whole May attract some some
uh some other businesses or or uh give a
little help to the commercial real
okay Representatives Davis you have a
question
[Music]
board hat and I'm thinking about
unintended consequences of Statewide
legislation to cities and municipalities
that it may not apply to and may cause
tremendous confusion because it doesn't
apply would you consider you and the
other sponsors consider making this
enabling legislation so that it's not
one size fits all because New Hampshire
foreign
if it's enabling it really is it would
be the same as it is now so right now we
would it would it would basically kind
of not help out in any way personally I
do
um understand the and respect the you
know that you're airing on uh and thank
you by the way for serving on the
planning board as well that's that's
quite that's quite the um uh service
there um but I think that what you know
we're really trying to get help
um the you know in making it enabling uh
not enabling just kind of opens a little
a little more room I'm not too sure too
many problems would would happen with
this because of the it's retail to
retail it's it's large retail but small
retail yeah it could be a little busier
um sure but once again I had talked
about the market that would would
correct that I mean I I know these
tenants they're getting more strict on
what their requirements are and are and
I think the covid uh situation I don't
know if it's gonna be permanent I don't
know the future but I know that it
actually made it so less people go in
these places as well uh just for social
distancing reasons and all that so you
know I don't see the big the big uh
heavy push so landlord's not going to
lease a space that doesn't have not
adequate parking because he has the
vested interest and nor will a tenant
lease that space they they need to at
least a space that works for them
um and I and I you know I know that the
planning boards do a great job but this
gives up does put a little more trust in
landlords to do the right thing and if
they don't you know there's language
that says hey you're in trouble here you
can't go in that neighboring lot unless
there's an agreement with you and that
neighbor and and so forth so I I
appreciate the question thank you
representative Gilman do you have a
question for Mr Avis uh representative
Genie
the first
oh thank you Mr chair for Mr Abbas
unless representative janitian would
like to land uh my question is if there
if this is a Statewide mandate and
um
a business and there's no distinct
distinction in a town between large and
small retail material
what what would happen if a applicant uh
does not like the uh decision made by
the board for whatever reason
um where would the appeal go to since
this does this is a state mandate would
it go to the local zoning board or would
foreign
would you like to answer that question
well I mean if if uh planning but even
if the planning board doesn't um
uh acknowledge this this
um
bill I mean if it was passed they they
you know this would be I'm sure they
would be aware of it if there's no
ordinance
um in the town then it's already just
one retail it would just be they
wouldn't even need this but if uh if
there there was a town that had that
specific language such as Salem which is
they have both they have large retail
uses and regular retail uses I can't
imagine Salem planting boy if this was a
they're very I mean they're they're
probably very renowned here I think it I
think it would be um
um you know that would be between the
applicant and what they want to do uh
where it goes legally I I guess they
they can take it where they they want
they can take it to the U.S Supreme
Court if they want it if it goes up that
far but I I that's more of a legal
question but I I think um I've answered
that to the best of my ability
okay thank you thank you
clarification Mr Abbas Adam Abbas who is
on the telephone
is he a state representative
representative or not that seems to be a
little confusing no I'm actually just a
um Mr uh representative majority we have
uh representative Melvin would like to
ask a question
thank you
thank you for taking my question how
would this work out in a strip wall
where everything is sectioned off
because the strip mall could be you know
80 000 square feet and it's sectioned
down to you know ten thousand square
feet yeah so it's only for the the space
it's only for the in the actual space so
each unit you know you you can't if it
was a supermarket with a hundred
thousand square feet and then you had a
fifteen thousand square footer attached
yeah the the 15 000 square feet it's the
size of the space it doesn't really
matter what's around it
it's the Interior Space
not has nothing has not nothing to do
with who the co-tenants are if it's a
square foot structure and we have uh six
different businesses in that structure
so any one of them would have to if they
change from let's say a furniture store
to a clothing store they wouldn't have
to uh
only if it was under fifteen thousand
square feet
so if if it was a hundred thousand
square feet nothing changes at all the
bill is only for specific to 15 000
square feet and less so that would be
I'm trying to think of an example
um
you know like like a small grocer like
it wouldn't it would be like uh a
regional you know maybe a regional
grocery store or something or
a sporting goods store maybe a smaller
one which the the too many don't exist
anymore
all right one more follow-up
so this would be a building that would
technically only be 15 times 15
000 square feet
not the building the space
so it would be the space itself
because you gotta you gotta go for and
whenever there's a change of use you got
to go just for the space you don't go
for the whole you go for the whole
property but you really you get focused
in on that space and what that because
the other spaces don't change around it
so you don't you only go for a change
you use four spaces for individual units
thank you representative majority
thank you Mr chair and thank you Mr
Abbas for taking my question
um hopefully this is a simple one I I
would would the with the new business
need to still comport with say a sign
ordinance
absolutely okay thank you
and uh one more question representative
Staples
thank you Mr chair this is what you get
when you have a planning board member on
the committee
so I'd love to follow up on
representative Melvin's very good
question about strip malls
in many cases in fact most cases the
property on which the spaces
abide in a strip mall is owned by a
single owner it's not owned by the
stores themselves
um they lease the space from the owner
and frequently that owner is not in New
Hampshire
so how do you envision this bill
applying to
owners of retail property that com is
comprised of many many different stores
um how do you how do you see it working
and and you made a comment I think
before about not a legal matter well but
a bill is a legal matter
so you know there's a lot in here that
would seem to
just kind of invite
lawsuits
so I and I'm sorry I'm mixing the
question up here I'm mostly asking you
how you see it
applying to large strip mall owners who
lease out to multiple spaces
well is that I think um that's a great
question I think that
you know at the time of Discovery the
the landlord will have to do their due
diligence and if they they're aware of
this
I'm sure the planning the planning board
will be aware of it in the in the states
uh in the towns
for my you know the planning board in
Salem they're aware of everything so if
they if a CL uh someone comes in to
for to lease a space and there's a
question about they will say well this
is what's allowed and they will
reference this law
so so they would you know this would
only pertain to a lawsuit if the
planning board was not aware of this uh
in a certain community and not aware of
this uh legislation and they they still
uh made a decision it would have to go
through several
channels I guess to get there uh through
error uh are are not not understanding
the the law but I think uh if they go in
and they do the change of use and they
get it done uh you know they well they
won't have to get to that level with
this so if if it's a fifteen thousand
square foot or or under they'll they'll
be aware and if they're not aware they
should be made aware through due
diligence
uh thank you um I see Mr Avis I want to
thank you for your testimony
um it's my pleasure
and I apologize for not recognizing you
earlier representative majority is your
hand still up because I have
representative I mean Mr Cordell Johnson
coming up next I believe I apologize for
not lowering my hand and Cordell Johnson
is uh all set to speak okay Mr Johnson
Johnson thank you Mr chairman uh Cordell
Johnson representing the New Hampshire
Municipal Association in opposition to
the bill
um this is
um the language of this bill is
something that would be perfectly
perfectly appropriate to include in a
zoning ordinance
uh but that's that's really where it
goes this is a local issue
um the the the state statute on uh
zoning and planning is extremely General
and it it um it authorizes the
municipalities to adopt zoning
ordinances and describes in very general
terms what the zoning ordinances may
require and then and then it authorizes
municipalities to have a planning board
that performs site plan review when
there is a new use or or a change of use
discussing what kinds of uses can be
changed to what other kinds of uses and
based on 15 000 square feet or less
that's the level of detail that simply
doesn't belong in State Statute that
belongs in the local zoning ordinance
if if you go down the road of
uh of defining
um what
what kinds of uses can be changed to
other kinds of uses under what
circumstances
um you're going to end up with a zoning
statute that is hundreds of pages long
and every time there's an issue in one
municipality uh they're going to come to
the legislature and say can you please
take care of this this is this is
absolutely a local issue
um and and one of the problems with
doing this at the state level is
this bill talks about commercial uses it
talks about retail uses it talks about
large retail users all of those things
are things that are probably defined in
the local zoning ordinance
and the definitions in Salem's ordinance
I can assure you are not going to be the
same as the definitions in lebanon's
ordinance or uh or exeters or dovers or
anywhere else
so you're now you're using definitions
here that are going to mean different
things in different towns
um another problem with the build is I
think the bill doesn't actually even do
what the what the supporters want it to
do because they're talking about as I
understand that changing from one
permitted use
in a in a zoning District to another
um
when you when you change from one use to
another that typically requires site
plan review by the planning board
it it but what this bill says is that
that change shall not require a variance
or a conditional use permit ordinarily
it wouldn't it wouldn't require a
variance or a conditional use permit it
would require a site plan review
um
so I don't think this even does what the
what the supporters want it to do
um
what what really ought to happen here is
their uh municipalities already have
authority under its RSA 674 43 paragraph
four
and says that the municipality can
establish thresholds based on the size
of a project below which site plan
review shall not be required
and many municipalities do that so the
town of Salem or wherever it is can
adopt um as part of their ordinance
provision saying that these kinds of
projects will not require site plan
review but that is it is absolutely
a decision that needs to be made at the
local level because as I say if a state
starts making these decisions you're
going to be up to your eyeballs in um
requests for for Statewide
changes to zoning ordinances
I went there but I'd be happy to answer
are there any questions to Mr Johnson I
see one from representative 311. thank
you Mr Excuse me thank you
representative piamonti it's not a
question
um I it's two things I wanted to let you
know that my New England lunching
bodyguard has returned home so he's here
with me in my open concept house and my
second is just a refresh from Mr
Johnston regarding what RSA he just
mentioned a moment ago in regards to
changing ordinances in a town
yes it was RSA 674 colon 43
paragraph four Roman numeral four
okay um are there any more questions uh
I see no further questions
and I am going to close hearing on five
so chair I I do believe that the prime
sponsor representative genegian is still
yes
thank you Mr chairman I'll
um again for the record I'm
representative John janigian
representing Rockingham District 8 which
is Salem
um House Bill 574
um
very similar except this one deals with
spaces that are 3 500 square feet or
less and specifically
um small retail and again the word small
here it means small item small item
retail to small uh item retail and also
some service establishments as
identified in the bill again I know
we're getting tight on time you're
running over so I'm not going to go into
a lot of detail but uh similar similar
concept trying to keep costs down
helping business helping small business
and and in New Hampshire
[Music]
foreign
I don't think we have any questions here
we have the same people
um Mr Abbas and Mr Johnston uh who were
okay
it looks like the whole room is muted
Mr chair it looks like we lost the room
someone could go up to the computer and
turn it on the same way you did after
lunch
wait a minute after lunch I didn't think
we had excuse me I apologize
um after the break excuse me
representative maggiori do you want to
invite Mr Abbas to speak while they're
it it looks it's fine with me if
um representative pimonte is it okay if
Mr Abbas speaks while you are working on
the muting issue absolutely oh you're
back
okay representative Davis would you like
to speak on 574.
yeah
uh oh yeah this is uh uh Adam abness I'm
not representative mom for the record
um uh thank you very much uh once again
I I think that this is another great
Bill to I won't reiterate a lot of the
reasons why but this is something that
really really helps the small guy the
smaller space is 3 500 square feet or
less I manage a property with some that
are under that some that are over I have
some that are you know up almost 6 000
square feet
um so I I I know that the 3 500 Footers
and under there's there's only so much
impact you're gonna have going from
retail to the following changes of use
now what's interesting about this is in
section three of the bill uh B C and F
are already allowed in Salem it's just
this is just kind of stating the what
the what the um
um meaning
allowed it means that the use that it's
going to actually is less of an impact
uh parking wise now in place of assembly
in restaurants
you know it would require more parking
demand uh and you know we feel that the
you know the the change of use the space
is only so big you can only fit so many
seats in a 3 500 square foot and that
even that's getting less for instance I
we have one 60-foot uh restaurant UH 60
seat and now they only have 20 because
of the pandemic and they're mostly pick
up so you know this this just gives a
little bit more freedom now I'll I can
point out where the existing way of
things the market is allowing something
interesting to happen in our town now we
have up to up to somewhere between 10
and 15 vape stores in town which no
disrespect to the industry I I have no
problem with it but with with that the
reason that there's a lot of vape stores
in Salem a lot is for two reasons one
because the mass you know Massachusetts
put some legislation that restricted
certain kinds and the other is because a
landlord or property manager such as
myself right now can lose a retail
tenant and put in a vape store because
it's also retail so when they when they
weigh that against a restaurant
let's say a restaurant called us for
lease and they only have five seats
I I have to go for a change of use
just you know it's not going to really
be a big deal people are going to pick
up some items from a deli you know it's
not the the existing zoning
does not allow a little more freedom for
these smaller spaces to get in we're not
talking the Home Depots of the world and
the Walmarts of the world we're talking
the little the little tiny hair salon
uh you know the um the retailer that you
know the dry goods that wants to put in
um a fitness Boutique uh 35 you can't
put in Planet Fitness on this one that's
uh that's about what fifteen thousand
twenty thousand square feet
so this is this is very conservative I
feel like the change of uses you're
gonna see a a the public will love it I
think too because you're going to see a
lot more interesting and creative uses
uh things that would be better for the
community I I love it I think that this
is it gives it gives a little trust once
again to the landlord it throws a net
over New Hampshire and says look we
don't you know we respect your
ordinances but this is one specific
ordinance for this size space to have a
little more freedom and um you know I'm
I'm like I'm not getting a lot of calls
I'm getting a lot of uh calls to lease a
lot of vape stores a lot of uh uses some
of them come through here and there and
I said you know what this is going to
cost a lot of money and uh you know for
these smaller tenants Mom and Pops
they're not going to pay put the bill
maybe and if we do then we have to raise
the rent on them and then they they
could actually the hopes of them
even leasing the speech which I've
actually seen and lived through many
times
um throughout the past 17 years
um but anyway uh that's kind of where I
stand on it like I say really respect
and uh thankful for the opportunity to
uh to speak today
a representative of a jury uh
representative lasalles has a question
yes
for anyone who wants to answer it uh
in uh
parentheses f
Dimensions salons including but not
limited to beauty hair cosmetic Health
waxing and nail salons would that
um so that's a great question uh tattoo
Powers is already allowed because it's
retail so if something is already zoned
to retail Believe It or Not f is already
all that is retail at least in Salem so
right now if a sporting goods store
that's thirty three thousand square feet
went out of business 3 500 and under and
then a salon hair salon wanted to come
in they don't have to do a change use
but there could be other communities
that have an ordinance where you know it
throws a net so it's almost moot in some
areas to some which is no problem and
then when it gets to another zone so
tattoo is I can like let's say uh I for
instance I have a 2000 footer available
right now it was a full Mark cell phone
uh retail I could lease to a tattoo
place right now without any of this
um Oculus to a vape store right now
without going through zoning right now
but I can't go in least to a restaurant
so you know I can't go at least to
a fitness Boutique that has like a
certain class size meaning if they're
going to have like 25 people in the
class or something you know it's going
to be it just it gives a little bit free
more freedom to go and and not you know
by the way deals fall apart fast uh
sometimes the planning board meeting
from A to Z could take two to three
months multiple meetings sometimes
someone's looking for a space and they
just want to get in and they want to get
in easy or a little easier
I'll be honest with you in a world of
restrictions for business at this time
and small business doesn't need any more
restrictions we need we need a little
help
especially online is just it's coming in
big and you're going to see the the
online percentage get higher and higher
as the years go on so brick and mortar
needs it we need more traffic we need a
little bit more traffic definitely
across the board in the whole state and
and uh the New Hampshire is a great
state that's why everyone comes over
over the line I love the state here I
love it here but um once again thank you
thank you for the opportunity
uh Mr Abbas thank you very much for
testifying I want to recognize
thank you Mr chairman
Heimer I am representative Daryl Abbas
and I represent Rockingham County
District 8. I'm speaking support of
House Bill 574
I'm sure this committee is aware that a
landlord is is running a business and
the pandemic has been very difficult on
all businesses uh retail businesses
small businesses as well as the
landlords
as small businesses go out of business
the landlord has now lost their customer
and to get a change of use in an example
would be an electronic shop
if if you want to average want to
convert that to let's say a coffee shop
in order to get the change of use some
some towns it's very expensive to just
get the change you use uh some some
planning boards that uh have the
discretion to desire for their
consideration a traffic plan uh an
updated site plan
some to get changes abuse can cost
upwards of ten fifteen thousand dollars
even more
so for a startup business trying to open
a new business
they start across are high as is I feel
that the change of use for a small uh
retail business that's under 3500 square
feet to convert from a small electronic
store let's say to a small coffee shop
would have to go through Great Lengths
in order to do to get that established
but also adding the cost simply to get
the change of use
when the impact is going to be minimal I
believe would really help
boost our economy on all ends it would
help the landlords out it would help
keep those businesses going it would
help small businesses and a lot of
tenants in those buildings
especially strip malls they benefit from
having other tenants open in the same
Shopping Center
so if you have a strip mall where
sometimes uh people who shop at one
store they'll go to multiple stores
while they're there so it's really in
the interest of all of the businesses
that not ever have a vacancy and they're
strip mall so that's
it's it's really it's a win-win-win I
would say it's winning for the existing
businesses that manage to survive during
the pandemic it's a win for the landlord
but it's also win for the startup costs
and I believe the impact
would be rather minimal so I would uh to
speak in support of HB uh 574 I want to
thank the committee and thank you Mr
foreign
I have lost my computer here so I cannot
see and tell me if there are any other
people who like to testify
sure Mr chair I do not see anyone else
with their hand up and double checking
against the list the only other person
is uh to speak is Cordell Johnson who
just put his hand up very good uh
Cordell Johnson
um thank you Mr chairman again Cordell
Johnston from the New Hampshire
Municipal Association and uh we oppose
this bill for the same reason we did
House Bill 573 again this would be
absolutely appropriate and and probably
even a good idea to put into a local
zoning ordinance and uh if the if the
people of Salem want to or any town want
to put that into their local zoning
ordinance uh that's fine and I think
they should be encouraged to do so
but again
um
putting this kind of detail about what
is and is not permitted and how it how
it should be done in a state statute is
going to cause a lot of problems for
municipalities again it uses Define uses
terms such as retail
there's one one term in here it's it's
quote retail stores store groups shops
or service establishments close quote
um that may be something that's defined
in one zoning ordinance but certainly
you're not going to have the same
definition in another zoning ordinance
so it really really should be left to
the municipality
and again uh site RSA 674 43
paragraph four that allows the town to
um to exempt
uh
developments or changes of use based on
based on size and this would seem to
fall perfectly into that to adopt uh to
adopt an exemption for these kinds of
changes involving spaces of 3 500 square
feet that's that's where the the
legislating should be done at the local
level not uh not at the state level
um thank you Miss Johnson uh are there
any more uh people that would like to
testify Mr George
Mr chair I do not see anybody else uh
left if there are no people signed up
Lester left to testify but I do see the
representatives Davis has her hand
raised
very good Representatives Davis what
could be your question thank you Mr
chair very briefly
uh representative Abbas
um
have
excuse me representative uh
representative left oh okay so who who
um Mr Abbas
uh representative genevian is still here
thank you representative genejian could
you tell me if any of the sponsors of
this bill have approached the town of
Salem zoning board or planning board and
asked that they consider
uh not that I know of Representative
um we were basically not looking to just
benefit Salem but to benefit the whole
state the the Avalanche of online
um sales
Amazon's you know and all that is is
hurting a lot of the brick and mortar
stores so we're looking this is more of
a pro-business pro small business build
for the whole state
it would benefit Salem as well but we're
not looking to if we're looking just for
sale and we I agree with um Cordell
Johnson that we should change the
ordinance but we we want to build up
business
um and encourage small business in the
back
um
representative commanduri are there
anyone else with their hands up
no Mr chair I see no one else with their
hands up okay I see no more questions at
this time I'm going to end the hearing
on House Bill uh 574 and open up the
hearing on House built
six one six
I've pardon me I just lost the
connection here and I'm
trying to get back on the uh
the board here representative birdie is
one moment Mr chair I'll double check I
was just
getting organized but I don't think I
see
hold on a second let me double check
just to see if possibly through our
panelists but no I don't see either
through panelists or attendees and as we
have done before I'd be more than happy
with your permission Mr chair
to introduce the bill
if you would like very good why don't
you do that
thank you Mr chair and thank you members
of the House Municipal and County
government committee my name for the
record is representative Jim Maggiore
representing the town of Northampton
Rockingham District 22 and I'm here to
introduce House Bill
616fn and act relative to review of
planning board
decisions with that said Mr chair I do
notice that there are two people who
have called in
um I don't see on the list to testify
remotely anyone other than Cordell
Johnson so I I don't know if you'd like
me to allow both of those people who are
calling in to see if one of them might
happen to be representative baruti
uh yes and why do we do that and I have
have that each one identified themselves
recently okay so the first one I've
clicked on is the number ending in six
six eight nine
and um I've asked that person to unmute
and of course uh for those who might
they don't like me okay
how could the next one then which is uh
area code 978 and ending in four three
zero zero and again
oh yep should be good and I'm just
curious if this happens to be
representative burruti
hi no it's not um I'm Jackie Walker
signed up to speak for the next bill
okay well that uh apparently Cordell
thank you Mr chairman uh Cordell Johnson
representing the New Hampshire Municipal
Association
um and I hate to seem like a difficult
person but again in uh opposing this
bill
um largely because it is very well I
guess there are a couple reasons one is
it's very confusing the other is that it
it seems pretty unfair I guess I'll talk
about the unfairness part first
um this would require as I as I read it
if someone if someone appeals uh
typically a planning board's approval of
a site plan
um or either residential or commercial
um it's property the person filing the
appeal would have to
pay a filing fee of Seventeen hundred
dollars which is uh really quite High
compared to ordinary Court filing for
the city would have to
file a bond equal to the assessed value
of the property
um and if the appealing party loses
would have to pay the other party's
attorney fees that is that's pretty
um heavily skewed against someone who's
just exercising his or her uh legal
rights to appeal a decision of a
um or or a decision of a zoning Board of
adjustment as the case may be and I
guess
for the most part the the unfairness
doesn't really affect
local governments which is who we
represent so
so
it doesn't necessarily affect us except
that there are cases not a lot but there
are cases in which a municipality could
be appealing a decision of its own
Zoning Board of adjustment
um and so it would under this
have a significant cost impact on the on
the municipality filing that appeal
so that's the unfairness part of it the
confused the confusion part of it
is it talks about the cost to file an
appeal pursuant to this section
uh however an appeal
wouldn't be this doesn't create a new
right of appeal
and uh so an appeal would be filed under
existing law which for a or a appeal of
a zba decision would be it would be
Cloud under RSA 677-4
an appeal or the planning board decision
would be filed under 677.15
so
there are existing sections that provide
the right of appeal and this is sort of
coming in from the side and seeming to
create a different basis for appeal
and that's going to lead to a lot of
confusion for parties to these to these
land use cases
um
and then it uh in paragraph five it says
standing for appeals of projects
pursuant to paragraph one shall be
limited to direct Butters only
again under the existing law there's a
right to appeal it's not limited to
direct to Butters it's it it applies to
any aggrieved party and a grieved party
is something that has been defined by
Court decisions and it includes more
than just director Butters it includes
anyone who who whose rights or interest
uh are directly affected by the decision
so when someone wants to wear Pete wants
to appeal a decision if this bill passes
there's going to be a lot of confusion
about exactly what law applies what is
the filing fee uh what are the results
do I have to file a bond and who has
standing to appeal
um so uh for those reasons we oppose the
bill and I'd be happy to try to answer
any questions
okay uh representative majority other
questions for
used myself there I see one hand up from
all right uh Mr Abbott do you have a
question
sure it actually isn't a question I
would like to testify if that's okay
chairman
um I signed up late and you're not able
through the system to uh I would say
that first of all I'm Gary Abbott I'm
the Executive Vice President of the
associated general contractors
our legislative committee reviewed this
bill as an association we represent
large commercial contractors I was
hoping to hear the sponsor's reason for
the bill in which we didn't really hear
the sponsors reasons for the bill I had
two construction attorneys look at this
and we're in kind of an agreement with
Cordell Johnson who just spoke we think
it's confusing
the bond equal to the assessed value on
a commercial project could be awful High
it just seems to put in a higher level
now at the same time you can have a
construction appeals as well so this was
confusing
as it seems to carve out
um also noting the fiscal note from the
municipal Association
we're in agreement that um
not really sure how this how you would
make online 10 of the bill uh kind of
guessing what the proposed attorney fees
would be and then how that would all
work out so having two attorneys that
represent construction and contractors
tell us that I think we'd rather see the
the existing laws stay the same as this
would add costs and it would confuse the
current system because you can have
cases where different parties appeal not
just as described in this bill so I just
wanted to put that on the record with
the committee that it may appear at
first read that this helps
an applicant who represents a commercial
site but we're not so sure it does and
it might add more confusion so we do not
support this legislation that's
currently drafted
and be happy to answer any questions
Mr chair I do not see any other hands
raised from either the committee or from
the folks who are in the public
hey uh representative majority did you
have a question on this oh no I'm sorry
if I had my hand up but I will tell you
Mr chair I have looked in every way that
I can
think of to try to find representative
baruti under his first name his last
name under rep and I I apologize I just
cannot find him here and I don't see
anything
uh with an odd uh with an odd title to
make me even think that he might be
there under that so I I've looked every
way that I can
okay thank you I want to thank all the
testified for this today and I'm going
to close the hearing on House Bill
616-ft and and introduce
the next bill which is I'm sorry 588
Mr Testament would you like to testify
on that
was a representative Testament
Mr chair while uh if I may just a
question of the chair
this is representative majority
um and I I just want to ask you as I am
a co-sponsor here
um and I've signed up to speak if
necessary but I'm also handling the the
technical side here is there any problem
that you foresee or or should I just
continue to handle the technical stuff
no uh Diane could take over for you if
you you want to take a break on that
that's fine
representative power are you okay with
that so that there's no uh no potential
conflict or of question
I'm willing to do that I do not have the
um
the Sheep of those who will testify
I'll email it I will email it over to
you right now can you receive email yes
okay I'll send it over here this morning
so it should already be in your email
representative power thank you
okay
okay Mr representative assessment
whatever you're right
uh good afternoon I'm representative
testerman I represent mayor Matt uh
Second District that includes Franklin
and Hill uh I'm here this morning or
this afternoon to introduce Bill 588 uh
it's a bill that would the first time
allow tiny houses into New Hampshire uh
it there is an amendment uh that
representative majority uh put together
with me which actually
essentially takes the bill and takes the
wheels off the
the tiny home because we ran into a
series of difficulties and questions so
we also have I believe a
Joe Mendola who is the real lightning
bolt behind this thing is he online that
representative majority
you didn't finish your testimonial
representative and we'll locate for you
okay I was going to have him sort of sit
so
there's any questions I'll try to answer
do we have represent uh okay this uh
representative of Testament
um I'm going to ask for
Mr chair I had my hand I got him yes
this is Joe Mendola can you hear me yes
representative testerman would you like
me to open the remarks I I've I've
introduced the bill uh I'll let you
speak to the specifics and the reason
behind it great first of all I want to
thank the committee for uh hearing this
bill it's really important uh bill for
uh the continued economic growth here in
our state I am a real estate broker uh
with Nai Norwood group and I have been
researching uh the the tiny home uh
process to make it a permitted use in
the state for for about two and a half
years now and as I tried to to develop
it
um at least the zoning uh I ran into a
brick wall that basically has the state
has no Zoning for it so um what what the
deal is here is we'd like to pattern
this after existing legislation already
on the books which is the manufactured
housing Park zoning except that that
manufactured House Park zoning the does
not relate in terms of building
requirements and specifications that a
tiny home would so this bill was
originally introduced as HB 312 about a
year and a half ago and Governor sununu
thought that it deserved more more
attention more information and he was
kind enough uh to put together a study
committee which I believe
Representatives majority uh testerman
and representative stavis were on there
along with uh Senator Martha Fuller
Clark and so we studied this over the
summer months and
actually got introduced in the Senate
with sponsorship by Senator Clark but
covet hit and and that became the end of
that so
um so now it's it's coming back in with
our original sponsor Dave testerman and
uh bringing on uh representative
maggiori who was on the study committee
so um that that's kind of the background
there what I've provided for you with or
my notes and a PowerPoint for the last
two and a half years I've been attending
uh breakfast from the virtual community
group up in Hanover the Bia uh Saint
anselms uh ethics webinars and we've all
had the same people coming on lamenting
uh that we don't have a sufficient
amount of affordable Workforce housing
stock in the state and the the problem
has been all along is that the zoning
um doesn't really uh provide for it and
that's the purpose of the bill so what I
what I want to do is just talk about
this is that New Hampshire needs to
solve the problem of lack of affordable
and Workforce housing for our young
people to stay and be attracted to New
Hampshire
if we do not provide this housing we
will not have enough people to fill the
jobs in our base Industries and in the
hospitality industry if you cannot keep
and attract the millennial population in
our state our businesses will follow
them out of state
um where the in the South where the
housing is less expensive and we will
lose uh my fear is the vital business
profits tax that really contributes to
the social uh needs of our state our
young people are managing significant
student debt and they uh not only kind
of not afford the average house in in
New Hampshire which is over three
hundred thousand dollars today uh but
they want to live minimally they want to
live large with less and that's what the
tiny home
um does for them uh they need housing
that's less than a hundred thousand
dollars uh in costs you could buy a
modest uh tiny home for around fifty
thousand dollars and you can buy a
luxurious one for around 85 000 and in
the PowerPoint you see the the picture
of of a luxurious this one that I've
provided for you
and the other thing is our Millennial
population doesn't trust the housing
cycle because they're going to be
changing their jobs 10 to 15 times in
their career uh I'm one of those old
baby boomers and my college professor
told me I'd change jobs three times in
my career and I did but those days are
gone so they need that flexibility to
move on
so I I understand that the tiny houses
on on Wheels have been taken out we can
talk about that another time but the the
have the tiny house on a foundation uh
will actually move the needle and create
really needed uh Workforce housing stock
in the State uh that is not here right
now
um and so that's one of the reasons why
uh I'd like to make this happen again as
a as a commercial real estate broker I
what I do in my day job is is I find
needs in the marketplace uh to keep our
our businesses vital in and growing and
this this came up as that need
over the time we've had two groups uh
neighbors neighbors of mine
um uh one being the the municipal and uh
town uh uh Association of which my
friend Mr Cordell Johnson is I guess
speaking to that today and uh the point
that I need to drive home with those
folks is that every form of Workforce
housing in the state is mandatory it's
not enabling legislation and we are so
far behind in providing this housing
stock that uh it is imperative that that
this bill
ought to be passed uh and hopefully that
it will be passed as as mandatory
legislation uh just as uh every other
form of Workforce housing is the other
issue of one of my other neighbors of
the building uh uh New Hampshire
building officials Association
um I've talked with them over the last
couple of years and they are in favor
um as I talked with with their president
about a year ago of of working with the
the requirements for uh Chinese homes on
a foundation now what you folks
um need to have in your in your
understanding there is that the uh
International residential uh code of
which New Hampshire I believe is is
using the 2009 version in the 2015
version they finally
um agreed and and uh gave uh uh interest
to uh tiny homes and they've created
appendix Q which uh provides for uh uh
construction specifications that they
think are are safe and warranted for a
tiny home on the foundation so I say to
my neighbors and and the building Owners
Association
um that I hope that they would would
join in accepting uh appendix Q uh even
even though New Hampshire's Edition is
is somewhat behind the times and so
um just in closing it's it's uh again
it's pretty simple because the
manufactured housing Park zoning is
already on the books and if we could
tailor our own Zoning for uh the tiny
homes on a foundation uh we will go a
long way to uh uh providing the badly
needed housing stock under a hundred
thousand dollars that are Millennial
population needs and wants thank you
very much
thank you uh Mr Mendola
um are there any questions from Ms
Mendel Mr chairman yes
um before we proceed I'd like to inform
you that we have nine people signed up
to testify on this bill and the time
that they have requested totals
approximately 40 minutes so moving
forward could you maybe give some
guidance on yes
um moving forward I'd like to uh make
your your testimony as efficient as
possible
um if something has already been talked
about please don't uh repeat it
um and uh I will now uh since I see no
questions
excuse me we have um representative man
japoodi who has her hand raised okay uh
representative major booty we'll take a
question
thank you Mr chair thank you for uh
Mr Mendel uh for taking my question I I
have a quick question in terms of uh I
understand the need for it and is there
a limit on how many can go into one lot
or one location how many tiny homes
is there a level yeah that's an
excellent question and again pattern is
after the manufactured housing Park the
only that's already in the books it's
it's basically uh basically four units
uh to an acre and that's what MHP allows
and it's about ten thousand square foot
lot and then the uh there's a lot of
common area that uh that the community
the community needs and wants so it'd be
okay are there any more questions from
Mr Mendola
representative Tripp
thank you Mr chair thank you Mr Nova for
taking my questions
I haven't read the amendment that I
didn't receive Bill last night
though last night allowed uh
either Municipal Water and switch
I'm not understanding the question could
feel about either Foundation tiny houses
it also allow either
um
that's true you can either use Talent
provided or otherwise it does allow and
this is something that uh business
the the senator asked for specifically
if you have a self-contained
uh
Wastewater system you cannot
have any that exits you know onto the
ground and stuff like that so it has to
okay uh I'd like to uh are there any
more uh questions
I'd like to rep uh I'd like to recognize
representative majority please
thank you Mr chair and thank you members
of the committee for uh taking what will
be extremely brief testimony I
um I I feel everything that we've heard
here I will hope you will find out to
pass and regret that we had to take off
the wheels of this of this bill but
um there were as as representative
testerman has said and as represent
Representatives Davis will agree we
heard considerable
considerable concerns about the on
Wheels uh putting a tiny home on a
foundation does add one of those tools
to the big toolbox that we need for
affordable housing for people who are
economically and and environmentally
concerned
um and and and and would appreciate the
fact of living or appreciate living in
such an interesting home uh with that I
will be happy to speak to the amendment
are there any questions for
representative and Jory
representative power thank you Mr chair
thank you Mr representative Maggiore for
taking my questions with regard to the
foundations is it the Ford Foundation or
is it the cinder block Foundation could
you describe a foundation for a tiny
home
thank you representative power for your
question and I believe that we have on
our list Steve Paquin who represents the
new New Hampshire building officials
Association
who can speak specifically to that maybe
go into more detail I don't want to punt
the question but I think he can get into
into more of that detail for for you and
everybody else on the committee if
that's okay with you thank you thank you
okay uh if there's no more questions uh
representative the jury
I'll take the next person on the list so
I'd like to recognize Mr Stephen Aquin
electronically so I can see you on the
list
thank you
all right thank you can everybody hear
me
yes yes
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
committee for allowing me to testify on
House Bill 588 for the record my name is
Steve Paquin I am the vice president of
the New Hampshire building officials
Association
um the New Hampshire building officials
are in favor of the amendment removing
the tiny Wheels out of of the bill
um
we felt that that was a vital part to
moving forward as
um Mr Mendoza testified earlier I want
to correct him a little bit New
Hampshire is currently on the 2015
Residential Building Code oh good and it
was 2018 where the ICC the the producers
of the building codes for the first time
moved forward and gave a definition of
what a tiny home is and that was indeed
appendix Q
um and there's a a small appendix queue
was moved forward by the New Hampshire
building code review board
um and I'm not sure if representative
majority was going to talk about this in
a little bit but um there may need to be
another Amendment added to this bill to
get appendix Q into legislation because
somehow it was missed
in the house bill I believe 17 and
Senate Bill 57 which was going to ratify
other amendments to the building code so
that needs to be added in somewhere
I agree
representative if you're to answer your
question regarding a foundation the
building code says that any residence
needs to be attached to a permanent
foundation
depending on the size of the home that
is typically a frost protected
Foundation which goes down anywhere from
36 inches to 48 inches maybe more in
some parts of the state
that can be
concrete
concrete block or believe it or not it
can even be wood and it can be a slab on
grade based on the building code so
there's multiple ways that you can
and I'd be happy to answer any more
questions
uh representative lasalles has a
question
yes
um thank you for taking my question
how does this
proposal
differ from current
uh ordinances concerning mobile home
parks
I two totally different creatures
um manufactured homes are regulated by
hype which is a governmental
organization that does third-party
inspections on how they're constructed
and what standards they're built to
a tiny home will be built to the
international building code which is
done by local Town building inspectors
it's it's done through the international
residential code two totally different
creatures as far as building lies zoning
wise I'm really not the person that can
testify to zoning I think individual
towns create their own zoning amendments
and they need to fit it in as best they
thank you okay are there any other
questions for this Witness
Mr chair I see representative air has
his hand raised
I'm sorry representative here we have a
question yes thank you chairman for
taking my question
so if you have a one acre house lot
you want to divide that into four
so if your zoning says it's a one acre
lot you're gonna spot Zone that lot into
four Lots
is that correct
again I'm not really the person to
testify to the zoning portion of of this
amendment I'm just here for the building
code portion of it
representative power may I speak to that
yes you've made yeah
um uh thanks for the question
representative air uh technically you
you could be right because in the
manufactured housing Park zoning
Manufacturing Housing parks are allowed
anywhere uh where a single family uh
residential dwelling or multi-family
residential dwellings are allowed and so
in that particular area
um it's governed by the the size of the
lot for that community so
um a one acre lot may not be large
enough to do that but uh the purpose of
the of the of the ten thousand square
foot lot is what we're trying to do is
get Parks going so that we can provide
enough housing and so we're looking at a
larger piece of ground 10 15 20 acres so
my understanding in doing the research
is that if you want to put it in a Zone
where say there's you know two acre
zoning whatever it is
um you might need a variance from the
the uh from the zoning board of appeals
for that
yes uh excuse me uh Mr Mandola next time
you want to answer a question address it
here please okay thank you
next person to signed up to testify
would be
um Ms Jacqueline Walker yes is Miss
Jacqueline Walker on the line
representative status has a question I
think oh sorry
um
Mr chair I can wait until
um after the testimony is delivered I'm
um this walker is
lined up could she raise could you
s uh Jacqueline Walker are you on the
line
the chair I did not see Miss Walker
right now I will go to the let's talk
she just she is here um she raised her
hand so she moved let me pull it right
uh if you have a testimony you would
hello uh yes
can you hear me yes you have testimony
you'd like to add yes
um
good afternoon my name is Jackie Walker
and I would like to testify in support
of House Bill 588
um I Echo many of the points that Mr
Mendola said so I will try to keep this
brief and only add new information I
been a resident of New Hampshire for
four years now all those in Dover for
three years we lived an apartment
building constructed in
in 1880 we were able to find a place for
what is considered a bargain in Dover
and infestations amongst appliances
difficult and dangerous neighbors the
heating was inefficient inefficient the
wiring was faulty
um and we dealt with a lot that was
beyond our control
um for this past year I've been living
in a tiny home that was built by a
professional contractor insulated with
Energy Efficiency in mind and the wiring
was installed and inspected by a
licensed professional less than two
years ago while we do have wheels on our
home the taxes is lifted by concrete
blocks and we are anchored to the ground
using higher requirements than those
that currently exist for mobile homes in
our area designed to withstand High
category hurricane force winds when
looking for a place to park and live in
our tiny house we heard from five
interested homeowners in Dover alone as
well as from others around the state so
the interest is there for both those who
want to live in tiny homes and for
traditional homeowners interested in
hosting tiny homes
the state has an affordable housing
crisis and also an aging population A
diversity of housing options such as
tiny houses can make a big impact in
alleviating these two issues I want to
know also that New Hampshire is being
given a huge opportunity to become the
first state to accept tiny homes
Statewide even California and Texas only
have a few cities and more rural areas
where tiny homes are explicitly allowed
there are already dozens of people like
me living full-time in tiny homes around
New Hampshire and many of us want to be
contributing members of our communities
we want to be recognized and to be
asked on the property that we occupy so
that we can help fund schools emergency
services and Road repairs in this place
that I hope to stay in for a long long
time I urge you to vote in favor of
House Bill 588 so that I my fellow tiny
house
swellers and future tiny house swellers
can become active civil servants for the
great Granite State thank you for your
time
thank you very much
any are there any questions for this
Witness
Mr chair I do not see any
um anybody with the hand raised okay I'd
like to recognize representative status
with a question
thank you Mr chair
um this is a question for uh
representative testerman and
representative majori
um and this was something that came up
in our study group a year ago where I
raised the issue of homeowners
associations and the laws or the lack
thereof in New Hampshire that govern
them and my concern is in
tiny house communities and how how do
towns and cities are indeed the state
um
keep track of or support these
communities as they attempt to govern
themselves it's tough enough to do it in
existing homeowners associations where
there is absolutely no State legislation
that supports uh any of the bylaws or
uh
representative Testament is not here but
uh representative majority would you
um sure thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative stavis for asking me the
tough questions and putting me on the
um and I I do remember that from our
from our study committee and it's an
excellent question uh one that that one
that I regret that I cannot come up with
a specific answer for you uh I don't
want to liken it I don't want to liken
what will happen to any other industry
we cannot say this would be like what
would happen in a manufactured home park
or like what would happen in a
Condominium Association or like what
would happen in a campground because a
tiny home is none of those things a tiny
home and if there would be a tiny home
park or different or or different
animals unto themselves I would hope
that any type of any type of Association
or rules that would be governed there
would be a part of a cooperative and a
part of a comprehensive agreement that
could be done cooperatively with at the
local level but I regret representative
Davis that I can't give you an answer a
specific answer to your question nor do
I think that in my rambling I've even
given you any direction so Mr chair
could I have a follow-up yes one
follow-up so I wonder if you um I guess
representative Chesterman is no longer
here I wonder if you might think this of
this as an opportunity
not so much as a challenge but an
opportunity
to use the um
you know the presence of tiny house
communities to strengthen New Hampshire
legislation governing homeowners
associations
if I I can certainly thank you again for
the question and I'd be more than happy
to speak with representative testerman
and work with you also to see if there's
okay are there any more questions uh
Mr chair representative Tripp has a
Mr representative Maggiore
one of the things that uh when I was
reviewing this last night is uh I saw
where this is basically enabling
legislation and that the municipalities
have to develop Sony
ordinances pursuant to this uh
would that be where uh such items as uh
dimensional
requirements would be included
disowning ordinance thank you
representative Tripp for the question
and the dimensional requirements for a
tiny home are specifically outlined in
appendix Q
um appendix Q if if you don't have I can
certainly send to you make sure that you
have but within appendix q a tiny home
is listed as a as a dwelling 400 square
feet or less I don't know if that
answers your question specifically but
again I can send you appendix Q to see
if it might address that question and
any others
I have a second question
go ahead
the reason I asked the question is it
seemed to be a hole in in the
would uh
will dependent 2 be referenced in say
the zoning ordinance
and thank you representative for the
question and Mr Paquin from the building
officials Association uh brought us
right down to that path and I am looking
at how this bill may have to be amended
to ensure that the references in
appendix Q as adopted by uh the The
Building Association or Builders
Association building us now I'm messing
that all up but to make sure that those
are all Incorporated within the bill
um because it because as this may be
tangential again a tiny home is a
specific creature it's not a small house
you can have a small house I think the
smallest you can have is 70 square feet
a tiny home is very very specific so
um I think we are working on and I will
work with Mr Paquin on an amendment to
make sure that we we plug that hole that
you that you are referring to
thank you for answering my question
thank you representative majority I will
uh uh move this uh to exec on Monday if
that'll give you some extra time to do
that
I appreciate that Mr chair I'm uh I I
will apologize but I was working on it
while we were talking to see if I could
actually get it done before the end of
the day but I will have it to you by
Monday for sure thank you very much
thank you I'd like to rep uh recognize
Cordell Johnston right now and I know uh
for now you can be long-winded if you
would like to keep it together so we we
are about quite a bit behind right now I
uh yes Cordell Johnston uh the the
long-winded Cordell Johnston
representing New Hampshire Municipal
Association and I promises will be the
last bill I oppose today at least in
this committee
um this once again is something that we
believe should be addressed on the local
level
um if if people want to build or develop
tiny homes uh zoning ordinance can be
zoning ordinances can be Fashions to
allow that uh basically what the bill
says is that you can't it essentially
eliminates any minimum size requirements
for homes in any municipality and
um
again that's something that ought to be
done at the local level the
um
uh state law already requires uh
municipalities to allow Workforce
housing to allow manufactured housing to
allow avus
um the idea that now allowing them
requiring them to allow uh tiny homes is
going to solve the affordable housing
crisis I think is
um extremely optimistic
I'll note that the governor had a task
force on affordable housing which made a
number of recommendations one of which
was House Bill 586 which was in this
Committee in which we did not oppose
um
but it its recommendations as far as I
know said nothing about tiny homes
um you I don't think you're going to
hear New Hampshire Housing Finance
Authority speak in support of this bill
if they thought it would make a
significant dent in the housing
affordability problem I assure you they
would be here in support of it as a
realistic matter it's it's not going to
um and to require every every city and
town in the state to amend its zoning
ordinance to allow something that very
few people are really interested in
doing uh I think is just going overboard
I live in a town that has no minimum
size requirement for homes I actually
live in something that is almost within
the definition of a tiny home it's mine
is 540 square feet I am pretty sure I I
live in the smallest house in town
um if if this were a real solution to uh
the housing shortage
um tiny homes would be springing up all
over the place in Henniker and that has
not happened
um so I strongly suggest that
um these matters be left to
municipalities and if people want their
town to allow tiny homes they can get
get them to amend the zoning ordinance
if necessary in many cases it may not
even be necessary
I went there and be happy to answer
questions
well thank you very much and I said that
with kindness uh Mr Johnson all right I
know that I I I know you are a very kind
man
are there any questions
Mr chair I did not see any committee
members with the hands raised currently
uh thank you for your testimony and
you know Bob Potter
it was the top
are you online
uh I am here can everybody hear me yes
I'm sorry I thought go right ahead okay
thank you uh good afternoon Mr chair and
members of the committee uh and thank
you for the opportunity to comment on
House Bill 588 my name is Rob tardiff I
am the administrator of the subsurface
systems Bureau within the Department of
Environmental Services
I'm here to speak specifically relative
to
uh the provisions in the bill to allow
self-contained Water and Wastewater
uh currently the department does not
allow for self-contained Wastewater in
in primary housing units
uh they would be considered a holding
tank
uh and the reason we don't allow for
holding tanks is quite frankly the cost
of Wastewater disposal
becomes very
problematic very quickly
and we've we find that Wastewater is
disposed of in illegal ways to try to
get away from those those high costs of
of
substance disposal here I'd also like to
preface this with we're only referring
to those tiny houses that would not be
on public water and sewer
uh obviously if a house is connected to
Public Water and Sewer then those those
individual disposal costs may not be
incurred by the property owners
we also have concerns regarding
lot loading which in layman's terms is
the ability of a particular piece of
property to support a sewage load
uh so if you already have a
for example a four bedroom home on a
property and you bring in a tiny home
that's additional Wastewater loading
that that lot has to support
and depending on the size of the lot and
the lot characteristics you know soil
types Etc uh that lot may not be able to
support that additional sewage load and
that again would be in
I'm going to try to be brief on the
times here the other part of the bill is
relative to tiny home parks and I
believe and I I'm sorry but I didn't see
an amendment to the bill but in our
letter of testimony we recommend some
language regarding to tiny home parks
and it would basically bring the parks
into the same type of regulations as we
have for existing mobile home parks uh
and again the bill may have been amended
to
to accommodate for those those
regulations
if I could just
uh you know all other forms of housing
require again if they're not on public
water or sewer uh require some sort of
compliant septic system uh and as Mr
Mandola referred to he was asking that
tiny homes be
considered as similarly as every other
form of Housing and I guess when I heard
that I thought of the same thing you
know the Department's looking to have
Wastewater disposal uh
requirements the same as every other
form of housing in the state of New
Hampshire and not to
allow for
this type of home to be
different or somehow differentiated from
that of a a two-bedroom mobile home or
quite frankly a six bedroom stick built
home
the Wastewater is Wastewater the
concerns of the of the department are
the same regardless of the size or the
number of bedrooms in a home
and
again to try to be brief I'll leave it
at that and I'd be happy to answer some
questions if anybody has any questions
for me thank you Mr tariff are there any
questions yes Mr chair
um representative true Levin has your
hand raised uh representative truleta
I'd like to ask a question thank you Mr
your chair I mean yes thank you Mr chair
and representative power
um and thank you Mr tarda for being here
I know of a few homeowners associations
in the
southern part of New Hampshire here that
have a community water and Community
septic system is that something that you
see as viable or even possible for a
tiny Home Project that's not uh in a
in approximity to a Municipal Water and
Sewer
development
absolutely I mean there are there are
many community
on-site Wastewater systems you know
again it's it's not even for smaller
homes you could have uh an association
of
four bedroom homes that have a community
system associated with the Wastewater
disposal it's it's really a matter of
again I threw out the term earlier lot
loading and and we look at a particular
piece of property in the characteristics
of that property to be able to support
I was just going to finish with those
types of systems typically uh the all of
the Lots combined
or well depending on depending on the
scenario the lot that you that the
septic system or the leech field is
located
needs to be able to support the load for
that entire Wastewater you know and we
do it on typically we do it on number of
bedrooms for residential applications so
if you have 20 bedrooms combined
the the property that the the system
itself is located must be able to
support that
and we do without getting into too many
details we get into easements and things
like that as well to accommodate for
those flows
got it and may I have a follow-up Mr
chair uh one brief follow-up we are
running way behind and I want to give
everybody lunch here
thank you sorry semester chart if this
may or may not be your uh expertise but
I'm wondering because I know from my
practice of selling real estate that if
a community has a community well that
well needs to be tested every six months
am I correct
I'll be you are correct and that's not
my area of expertise Wells need to be
tested the frequency I I would I can't
really speak to him I'm sorry oh
perfectly fine I'll figure figured out
thank you Mr chair thank you Mr Charter
thank you
um representative who's next on the list
and I'd like to have you limit your
testimony to three minutes okay and I'm
sorry for doing that but we are running
way behind Mr chair the next person I
have on my list is Ms Michelle Sanborn
could you raise your hand Michelle
thanks
identifier
thank you can everyone hear me yes thank
you thank you Mr chairman and committee
members my name is Michelle Sanborn I'm
a resident of Alexandria New Hampshire
and I've been a resident of New
Hampshire for well over 30 years I am
currently living in a tiny home on
wheels
um this is not just uh an affordable
housing issue for Millennials I am in my
50s I am a new divorcee and considering
uh the affordable housing issue with uh
the number of out-of-state people moving
into the state
I can definitely not afford to buy a
home not even a small home
um so a tiny home on Wheels is something
that that I can't afford it puts a roof
over my head uh the problem I'm running
into
and I have no issues with uh with the
waste water any of that um Alexandria is
pretty rural everybody's on a septic
everybody has a private well that makes
complete and total sense my tiny home is
not self-contained so of course it's
going to make sense to to use a um
septic system and viable you know water
source
um but this issue of uh being forced to
to remove
um to have this on a permanent
foundation
is is okay
um so long as the tiny home can be
simply like put up on blocks
um but what I keep running into is I
cannot even buy property Alexandria does
not have zoning so you would think it
would be tiny home friendly but I'm
running into subdivision restrictions on
mobile homes since there is no tiny home
definition they use their discretion and
say oh no that's a mobile home you can't
have that here if I go to there's a
warranty deed restriction that I keep
running up against
um for mobile homes and again they're
using their discretion and saying that a
tiny home is a mobile home and therefore
they don't want it so having I'm usually
one who is very anti-state preemption
because it generally
um does not allow local communities to
set more protective measures but in this
case I would see a state preemptive
mandatory allowing tiny homes Statewide
as a minimum
acceptance level to allow for affordable
housing
um sometimes it's a town zoning that is
an issue but like I said even in my own
town
um I'm running into issues of not even
being able to buy properties so I'm
actually considering moving to Vermont
uh because they are more tiny home
friendly all around whether it's just
buying and owning a piece of property
outright whether it's a tiny home
Community I looked into trying to find a
tiny home community in New Hampshire
they don't exist
um so I can't go there I can't buy
property it's very frustrating and I'm
actually being disenfranchised and I
feel like I'm being evicted out of my
own State and it really is an affordable
housing issue
um I think those are the main things
this this aspect of removing the tiny
home on Wheels I feel is a little bit
problematic because I don't understand
that meaning does this mean that tiny
home on wheels are not going to be
covered under this you know protective
definition measure and if that's the
case then I'm just completely doomed I
will literally become homeless and be on
the streets which is not something any
state wants that's not helping the
financial uh viability of of myself as a
contributing Citizen and it's also not
helping the state
so I do have a question around that what
does that mean that this section of tiny
home on Wheels is being removed does it
just mean that when I if if and when I
can find property that I just have to
take my wheels off if that's the case
I'm fine with that
um but if it means that I cannot bring
in a tiny home on Wheels that's going to
be a problem because it grossly
increases the cost of getting this up on
a flatbed or whatever and paying a
commercial you know Transport company
um I'm happy to respond to to any
questions
um
but that's my my brief testimony so I'm
not sure that I'm fully in favor of this
bill I am definitely in favor of
defining tiny homes so Statewide
preemption
um that allows for tiny homes anywhere
single residential home is and I totally
agree with tiny home communities falling
under similar guidelines to mobile home
parks
um are there any questions for this
witness Mr chair presently I do not see
any committee numbers with their hands
raised
okay thank you very much and the next
person to testify will be Alex Kish
you can hear me I I don't know I'm in
the barn I'm in the dark here yeah
okay good I have prepared statement but
I just want to go and respond to some of
the things that have come up on the Fly
here number one it's not just the
affordable Workforce housing we're
talking about for Millennials I'm I'm an
old guy and you know it applies to me
and we just heard from the divorced
woman so it's a broad spectrum of people
that this apply to and I think it's very
important to adopt
uh I've been a resident of New Hampshire
since 1996.
um
and unfortunately is that true that
local zoning has not stepped up
accommodated
um the tiny homes
and I own property in three different
towns so I'm pretty sure that that's a
fairly accurate statement Statewide so I
unlike
um one of the other
um people who've testified I think that
the state needs to push this so that the
you know they'll have to do something to
adopt and dress it outright and
furthermore zoning should not regulate
the form of housing to second-class
status
as only an Adu or accessory dwelling
unit or to be confined to small and
cramped Parts they deserve there and to
be accommodated outright and I think
this bill does that so I think it's
important enough to just on that alone
um
now
I wasn't made aware that the on Wheels
was removed from this I didn't see the
amendment but I see no relation between
relevant relation between a foundation
and the overall structure this is more
about
got lost
you want to be back yeah
yeah it was
I'm living out in the Boondocks
apparently you uh disconnected me I just
caught a couple more points if I'm still
here
um I believe in people's agency and
their ability to decipher themselves how
much space they require to meet their
needs
uh so
again the tiny homes often are not
accommodated under zoning and because
they are a lot less than 400 square feet
finally I want to respond to Rob tired
of my colleague over there at some
service I'm a licensed septic designer
and installer and additional real estate
agent
um I don't disagree with anything he
said I would just add that I think the
existing rules and regulations around
septic systems already are adequate if
anything I think um
you know regulations regarding one
bedroom septic designs
uh being relaxed may be warranted
uh but I think the rules as they stand
already addressed
um housing that tiny homes would fall
under so
there's that
um and I think
oh just one last thing real quick
building standards exists I'm not sure
and we've talked about the appendix Q
being amended not familiar with that but
I do know that other states Florida
Washington Oregon they've adopted these
things and they work fine so I think at
the very least New Hampshire could look
to them
uh for guidance if needed be anyway
thank you for your time Mr chairman
all right thank you testimony are there
any questions for Mr Kish
Mr chair I do not see any committee
members with their hands rates okay I
see nuns I would like to recognize
Gerald Miller if he's on the line
[Music]
been asking him on mute
it's not a response
ah here we go
I'm I'm not familiar with uh Zoom to the
point where I'm real comfortable but I
assume
uh if you if you would like to give your
testimony I would appreciate it and
limit it for three minutes okay yes in
fact uh I'm going to just have you
referred to the uh written testimony
that I have sent in and I can limit it
to uh just say that I'm in favor of the
original bill and I understand the
reasoning behind the amendment because
uh I did attend most of the study
committee uh meetings and participated
along with
um representative Maggiore and the
others and I I know that that was a Hot
Topic and I can also say that I feel
sorry for the people who this will not
benefit
um but I also feel that we need this
bill and legislation just to get tiny
houses on the record in New Hampshire so
that it is recognized as a
um
a type of dwelling that is uh
going to be
I think in the future uh more widespread
because it's this type of living that
young middle-aged and old people are
really taken to heart for
all the reasons that everybody has said
so far so I will leave it at that and
let you go forward and give me
thank you very much Mr Miller does
anybody have any questions from Mr
Miller Mr chair I'd like to inform you
that there are two attendees who have
their hands raised one has already
provided testimony in one I do not see
on this list and I'm unclear as to
whether that person could provide the
testimony previously when I was not
rocks
recommendations
I am here and good afternoon Mr chairman
thank you for recognizing me I
appreciate it I had not intended to
speak but um
I I feel compelled for two reasons uh
the first is yeah we're way behind and
these guys are hungry uh I understand
I'll be very brief thank you I uh the
reasons I I feel compelled to speak uh
and again Ben Frost from New Hampshire
Housing Finance Authority
um the two reasons I want to speak are
one uh the amendment I think is an
improvement of amendment proffered by
representative Maggiore he was kind
enough to send it to me that as
Amendment uh zero five one zero H
um and this the second reason is because
New Hampshire housing was invoked uh by
name by uh my friend Cordell Johnston so
I do want to uh say that I think that
um although he is correct that this
legislation if enacted uh is amended or
as introduced would not solve the
state's affordable housing crisis
it would certainly help and I think that
anything that the legislature does that
can improve the housing Supply in New
Hampshire especially of lower cost units
would be of benefit to us as a state
I do have my last comment is I do have a
minor concern with regard to the
language this is on the bill is
introduced page one lines 26 through 31
and in the amendment uh page one lines
20 through 25 with regard to detached
accessory dwelling units but I
understand you're under time constraints
and I'd be happy to work with the prime
sponsor and representative majori to
work on an amendment in the Senate if it
gets there have to take any questions if
that's acceptable to representative the
jury that that would be great are there
any questions for Mr Frost
Mr chair I did not see any committee
raised on the attendee list and I don't
see those names
having been previously signed in
first one
um so there's a Ms Michelle Sanborn with
her hand raised
okay Michelle sanboy are you testified
before you have a question from Mr Frost
I would appreciate it if you make it
brief
uh my apologies I did not realize that
my hand was raised okay thank you and
additionally there's a an individual by
the name of Stephanie and she has her
hands raised uh Stephanie
um online there you have your hand
raised yes can you hear me uh yes what's
your last name for the record my name is
Stephanie Burroughs and where you come
calling from uh thank you Mr chairman
and members of the committee
um
I am online
um today with you I am the founder and
organizer of tiny homes of New England
Meetup Group
uh currently with 485 members uh thank
you for this public hearing today it's
um a very very important issue and I'm
also um wanting you to know that I am in
support of HB 588 however for the record
I'd like everybody to know that there's
a tool that we use
onlinelegiscan.com and the um I come to
this meeting today
um unaware of the amendment the um house
bill that was introduced is there there
are no amendments listed there as well
so I was unaware that the tiny houses on
wheels was pulled from this original as
introduced bill
um but I just want to say uh I am in
support of tiny homes
um here in New Hampshire
um it does absolutely provide the
pathway to affordable housing and yes
like others have said it's not just the
Millennials it's the students Workforce
housing retirees wanting to downsize
people like myself preparing to retire
seniors and families that want to be
closer you know in an Adu or a tiny home
on Wheel situation on the same property
as their personal needs change over time
so again I want to thank you for this
bill
588 and um
I do support it and I look forward to
the future amendment to this bill I'm
not really clear if it will be to this
bill or if a new bill needs to be
developed and introduced specifically to
the tiny houses on wheels there are
associations that have very successfully
across the country worked with other
states and municipalities and counties
in legalizing tiny houses on wheels I'm
certainly available for any questions
and resources to get further assistance
in getting the tiny houses on wheels
also included in in legislation here in
New Hampshire
oh thank you are there any questions to
the service yes Mr chair I see
representative Gallagher has his hand
raised uh representative Gallagher yeah
uh just quick clerical
um question
um could you uh spell your last name for
me
um I wasn't sure if it was with a W or a
u g h
um and
um remind me what organization you're
with again my last name is Burrows
b-u-r-r-o-w-s
I founded the tiny homes of New England
Meetup Group in the year 2014 and also
manage a Facebook page
I've been very involved since the
beginning of tiny house development in
this country even
um predating the appendix Q I worked
very closely with the authors of that
appendix and have been involved in this
um for many years
I'm also a professional kitchen and bath
designer and project manager for over 20
years
so I've worked in construction and very
many different aspects of um
residential
housing
well thank you are there any other
questions for this Witness
Mr chair I see um
final hand just popped up on the
attendee list it's a Mr Gerald Miller
I'm Mr Gerald Miller uh are you out
there
I'd like you to be brief we are going to
lunch after this but uh what your
testimony is and if it's a substantial
fine uh and you already have any uh
letters that you may want to introduce
hold on so
um I already previously testimony uh
testified and indicated that uh just uh
go to the uh written testimony and other
supplements that I've already sent in to
you very good thank you very much
at this time I'm going to close the
hearing on House Bill 588
and I do apologize to the members today
for taking so long with this
um I hope you have a good lunch
thank you very much
uh actually look back at 20 past two
I will be muting the room um
representative pimonte just thank you
very much
appreciate it
Christina can you still hear me
I sure can
so thank you so we're going to lunch and
then if I understood it from the
beginning from from chair Dolan
representative power is going to
continue
um doing the being the tech person for
the exact session okay
so uh so I think that's what I
understood but the exact section should
be a little bit easier than the hearing
all right perfect thanks for letting me
know thank you for all your help thanks
foreign
anything good it's the other room
I put my coffee underneath there and
then found out that this was it they
foreign
[Music]
pulled out when I was seven
yeah
it's the only opportunity
I'm returned from my second uh shot and
I'm feeling great no side effects but I
I urge you not to text my wife because I
fully plan to exploit that into the main
clue breakfast in bed and ice cream and
all kinds of things
you take my advice on my cure for that
did you representative you guys uh you
ladies know uh
know all about that I'm sure know how to
manage the man to
you but chairman Dolan my um my husband
had absolutely other than the sore arm
he didn't have any effects from his
second he got the moderna so I don't
know which one you got but uh I had to
look during that as well yeah he had he
you know representative Dolan Mr chair
because my wife had the flu shots I mean
the uh the same shot as I did and I'm
sure she'll have no side effects and I I
fully admit that women are much tougher
than guys are with pain
what you are asked to go through I don't
I can't even begin to think about it so
you have my admiration just you just you
remember that representative
and we have those built just remember
okay so those of you who are thinking
about what we're going to be doing next
thank you uh we're going to uh expect
that Trifecta free budget to 243 415 and
454.
and then we're going to go to 512
um
gotta go to
you're gonna hold
and then you're going to accept
131 67 and 284.
what was the last one Mr chair here 284.
we are
Mr chairman yes
could I make a request
yes who is that oh yes representative
van yes uh I have an amendment for 284
that's the involuntary lot line merge
bill I have a work work meeting that I
have to be at at four o'clock I would
love it if we could put 284 further up
the list so that I could introduce the
amendment what if we did that first
oh you're going to do that one first
I did that how would that be that would
be great okay I I you know we may get
done in time I just would hate to not be
here since I'm the one holding the
amendment very valid request that all of
us from time to time a bit of us
competing a competing uh needs for our
resources in other places so
uh using representative fans example if
anyone needs to speak up and say can you
do me next or do the this bill earlier
or last or whatever because of my
schedule if we can I'm certainly happy
to uh go combination
[Music]
15.
all right and I want to give you another
reminder we're going to start up Monday
morning at 8 30. I just want to keep
reminding you that when you show up at
nine o'clock and we're halfway done with
the first ability and I say what
happened
so I'm giving you another of mine at 8
okay
um I just was
got a debriefing on what happened after
I left and I want to I want to uh
make an adjustment to like one of the
bills we were discussing or that you
were discussing in my absence and I want
to fix something uh
House Bill 588 that's the tiny house
bill uh that was recessed
uh or I I don't think it was recess I
think it was there was just a general
agreement to stop and and do it on
Monday instead and we haven't noticed
that from Monday in the calendar
so the proper way to do that
would be to recess the bill
and not just move it so I'm going to
reopen the public hearing
for
588 and then I'm going to recess until
Monday just to make sure that we don't
run a foul of the of the notice
requirements for the public that that we
have normally normally what we would do
is we would republish it in the calendar
uh and uh and re-notice it
so we have a technique called resets and
we can recess it and and continue
discussing it in our next meeting which
what I like to do so I'm going to reopen
the hearing
or 588
which is the building codes for tiny
houses and unless I hear an objection
I'm going to recess further discussion
on that hearing
uh until Monday
in our meeting on the 8th yeah Mr chair
you can take that up right at the
beginning at 8 30. yes uh representative
majority would it be inappropriate to
ask you to move that now unanimously
ought to pass would that be
inappropriate
you got me on that one I know
uh now shut up
so that one uh is now recessed
and we'll take that up at 8 30 when we
to continue the public hearing any
comments
need to be added
okay
that was 580.
52.
yeah so the next bill uh we're going to
accept
is House Bill 284
and I understand there is an amendment
that's pending and I could ask a
representative fan to talk to us uh
through the amendment
am out but I can't put my hand on it so
one sec I have it right here
um
I certainly I mailed it to you people I
know I did let me help you the amendment
reads thank you
repeal RSA 674 colon
39-a Roman numeral two parentheses J
relative to the deadline to submit
requests to restore involuntary Lots
merge Lots is repealed basically
it says is that we are we're removing
the sunset Clause so it never sunsets
you can apply at any time to have an
involuntarily merged lot unmerged
so in the van I looked for you to make a
motion on the amendment
sure I move that we adopt the amendment
for HB 284 as just read by the chairman
uh chairman Dolan yes and let me add for
2021-05698 it's in hotel
pass on the bill first and then amend it
I think that's the process
but I'm
am I wrong
the way we had done it last year so
yeah I I I I I don't think it matters I
think that the only time that we get in
trouble is if we're gonna I if we intend
itl something and try to push an
amendment through that that kind of is
oil and and water okay fine I think it
works either way okay
is there a second
and
uh is there any discussion on the
amendment
seeing Nana asked the clerk to take the
role on the amendment
Mr chair yes I just noticed that
representative
yes
representative Fair
uh representative power yes
yes
representative Gilbert yes
representative
representative you're on mute I think
I'm so sorry yes
representative yes
representative fan
yes
representative Gallagher yes
are you sure I don't think are we
missing anyone or not no okay 19-0 the
amendment passes and so now I look for a
motion
to OTP
man
that we uh vote ought to pass on HB 284
as amended
and is there a second I will second yes
representative Davis has her hand up for
a second
Mr uh clerk please call the roll
oh wait a minute is there any discussion
on the
the most uh
pass as amended Mr chair yes I do not
see any Committee Member
thank you uh okay uh Mr Clark would you
ER
while he's uh
getting his paperwork
I'm a little premature but I would ask a
representative fan if you would write
the committee report
yes
the recovery yes
representative
yes
representative George yes
Davis yes
yes
so uh without objection I'll put that on
consent
uh representative Anderson to the
majority report
okay our next
order of business is House Bill 243. Mr
chair I like to approve the amendment
2021-0546h
okay is uh emotions been made to to
accept the amendment
it's uh is there a second second Mr
chairman
Congressman I'd rather representative
McBride II
the amendment number uh representative
was
two one
yes it's actually two zero two one
zero two one zero five four six
seeing none uh except the emotion
I'm sorry we didn't vote on the
amendment I'm sorry uh getting ahead of
myself so the motion's been made on the
amendment
uh zero five four six eight
uh
yes
right
representative AR we didn't hear you're
coming yes
thank you uh representative yes
yes
representative majority we didn't catch
you here
your vote my apologies yes
uh representative yes
representative
yes
representative yes
representative Gallagher
I'll make that motion and is there a
second
a second Mr chairman I'm sorry
representative McBride makes the second
discussion on the uh on the bill
uh otcs and then
see none Mr Cliff would you take a roll
call vote please
foreign
wasn't this the one that was going to be
combined with the other two and an
amendment would be offered yes this this
we're recording on now we just voted on
the amendment and when I were voting on
the bill as amended
and I suspect there will be two
subsequent motions to itl the other two
bills that's what I suspect is going to
happen okay thank you
so this is this is 243 as amended
excuse me Mr chair I I see that
representative Colleen has her hand
right now
okay now typically what we do is we'll
take a boat and then we'll I'll ask for
for discussion but we've already asked
the discussion so I'll I will deviate
from that representative plea you had a
quick comment
s
so this is unusual
well I I apologize I I know we we
already voted on the amendment and we're
voting on OTP
as amended yeah I I did have a question
is is
um I mentioned at the public hearing on
this bill but if it's too late I
completely understand
well if you had something that you
thought would be clarifying I'll I will
suspend that rule for for you
I I I truly appreciate that Mr chair
um my my comments are or my question I
guess for clarification is on the um
the the 30 days I and I know that I
probably should have mentioned that
during the amendment but I I just
figured that it would become part of the
the entire bill and it's its entirety so
again
truly my apologies and if you feel it's
not appropriate
um my concern about the 30 days
um for prior to the public hearing and
so on
um I believe Mr Johnson brought up the
the fact that um this was not
necessarily that this had to be
available to the public within 30 days
before but to the the voting members of
the of the budget committee or the
school board or the selectment ETC I
just wanted to clarify that particular
thing and
um the the changes in making all
versions available within five days of
any change also uh a confusing aspect
um for me
um so so I I apologize I really should
have brought it up before this amendment
but
um
again if it's inappropriate now I
completely understand I just could
concerned about all these versions do we
understand what we're voting on so I you
know I'm I'm a little more flexible in
that regard uh and let me ask uh
representative giamonte who was very
close to the originating uh this let me
ask if he could give some clarification
yeah on on the 30 days this is basically
what happens is is a lot of these uh
budget committees in the school
especially uh they drag their feet
and they the time limit is is extremely
short that they give to to pass this
budget and uh it goes right to you
saying okay here it is and let's rub a
stamp this and pass it along
I think they should be held accountable
and and get this uh get this accordingly
um and
get it out earlier I mean there's no no
legitimate reason for it other than
stalling the budget I believe okay
representative Porter you had also a
question
to representative Piemonte
um uh again uh thank you and and I my my
concern is um that while this is perhaps
aimed at school budgets and so on what
about the municipal budget I know Town
budgets work a little different than
Municipal so for instance here in um
Nashville we've
um delayed
putting out the budget because of covid
and and so on um and usually it's
released a lot earlier our budget as a
whole will won't be out until probably
like May and if we have to wait 30 days
before we can have the public hearing it
just becomes more delayed
um Etc and where we work with a budget
committee every department has their own
budget it gets heard kind of gets
amended would we have to put all of
those versions up within five days and
it's going to get really confusing on
our website as to what is the current
and and so on so I guess that's where
I'm looking for clarification I'm sorry
for so much specificity
okay uh well let's see uh representative
Porter do you have something you might
want to add
no I was just going to make a comment
um about
feet dragging
um
I just wanted to remind the committee
that
perhaps they're not aware that
department heads in schools are teaching
full-time during the day
um and so doing the budget is another
aspect over and above there
duties to teach the children
so what might seem like dragging feet
might actually be not just not having
enough time in the day to do what has
been asked of them I and I would just
like on the record so that that to that
be on the record that there may be very
legitimate reasons why it's difficult
for Budget writers in the schools to get
their budgets out the way people in the
public might desire thank you
representative could you make me a
co-host
okay so so we are in the voting mode uh
what we just did was unusual and
probably atypical but I felt it was
important especially since uh
this is a rather complex
scenario that we have with we're doing a
trifecta here all at once uh so I I
wanted to make sure that we weren't
doing something that we didn't
completely all understand
uh so I want to pick up what we left off
representative Piemonte was was called
on and he voted yes so Mr clerk if you
would continue with the vote
good folks uh yes
sure yes
traffic
sorry about that yes thank you
representative McBride you're also on
okay let's uh let's go past the
representative McBride and uh
representative
yes
absolutely
representative Porter I need you to come
representative
oh and again I'm protesting
representative McBride not being here
for our whole executive session if I
left the room when we were in the middle
of voting mode I would not be able to
vote and representative McBride put his
holding pattern up was out of the room
said no
no
rapidly maturity
Representative no
um no
in advance
no
representative
representative Gallagher no
Champion Dover yes and I would ask you
that he would
query uh Representative no again Mr
chair I protest I I
representative McBride was not in the
room I hear you then his vote does not
count just as if I was right there with
you in the lob and I left the room in
the middle of the voting mode and I came
please please uh
uh
representative McBride you've been asked
he did not vote he was not there when
his name was called he did not voice
evoke
we're going back we're circling back
yes
representative power I prefer if you not
representative McBride we can't hear you
I don't know if you're on mute or not
come on I just said yes
all right so here's what the rule is the
rule is that when we're in the voting
mode what before unless a first unless I
can see a person when they vote that
their vote won't count
uh and uh in the last time this happened
uh representative McBride uh wanted to
uh Express his vote but I couldn't see
him when he uh was trying to vote and
therefore I disallowed his vote in this
particular case uh he his video was
turned off during the discussion but
when it was time to vote just as we just
recently uh went back to him at the end
of the list I did see his face the
purpose of that rule is to make sure
that the people who vote are people who
are on our activity and and there isn't
some type of a proxy voting that's going
on
I have been expelled from
Representatives hall for not being
present for the vote and I was not able
to vote
I know those are those are different
rules when we're in representative Hall
this is these are rules for this these
chair I just got a message from the
clerk my message to him was he was not
on the screen when the vote was called
can he vote and the answer is not
supposed to not present when the
question was put
on Paul that's right he was not there's
a question have them call me is what uh
clerk Smith has just said so I'm just
passing that along to you if you're not
in the room when the vote is called you
cannot vote
right just as if I was in the lob with
you which I wish I was as a matter of
fact and I had to run out for an
emergency for a phone call for anything
you were in the I was in the voting mode
when I left the room I couldn't vote
when I came back period final the end
all right here's here's a ruling right
now I'm going to allow the vote I'll
make a commitment to you that I will
check with the with the house Clerk and
uh and if that if he comes back and uh
says that I did it the wrong way that uh
I'll come back and tell you that
and here is that isn't that a rule that
we have to clarify if that uh yes can
clarify because this is a voting mode
question that we have so to go back and
fix it and we are actually in the mode
and we are asking for a clarification
shouldn't that our clarification be uh
provided when we are actually dealing
representative power you have a comment
thank you Mr chair I have a point of
clarification yeah it is my
understanding that in this committee a
Committee Member shall not speak unless
and until they are properly acknowledged
by the chair
so
to be clear I have been asked to be the
technology monitor for soon and so after
Representatives have been recognized and
have spoken
it was my understanding that in order to
maintain order in this committee meeting
that I shall
be able as the moderator to be able to
mute people and if they have their hands
raised digitally
I shall alert the chair of that and you
will properly
allow them to speak
Representatives speaking out of term is
is
um confusing right you're right uh and
I've made a commitment to the committee
what I will do is I will check with the
house Clerk and make sure that the rule
As I understood it and expressed it is
appropriate if not
you have my word that I'll come back and
change it you saw the first time this
happened it was in my judgment that the
vote shouldn't count and uh that's what
we did the other thing we could do is we
could reconsider this bill and then
bonus another time which I I have a
feeling is going to result in the same
outcome but uh I will I think it's worth
clarifying was represent with uh Clark
Smith just to make sure we all know what
the rule is
so representative 40 had one last
comment I do want to I do want to move
forward and then come back to this Mr
chair I fully understand the issue that
um representative McBride and I
sympathize with him but when we are
having an executive session we have to
be present for the executive session and
if he if he is has to be at his place of
work I understand that then he needs to
step back from the executive session so
he can do his job but if he's going to
be with us for an executive session then
he needs to step back from his job to
perform his legislative duties I really
hope that when you speak with Mr with
the clerk that we can get some kind of a
ruling that's clear on this that we
understand the situation
we just feel like if the rule is you
have to be on screen to vote then you
have to be there and that's the rule
that we all had I mean we have we have
house members who do not have access to
a computer who call in and they have
been house members for generations and
they can't vote in their committee
because they can't be seen on screen
right
and I I have uh I told you what I'm
going to do and I will be fair uh and I
will represent represent to you exactly
when I'm told uh and you know
the clerk he will not uh issue any type
of advice without uh with any type of
party affiliation he will be
straightforward and give us uh what the
thank you Mr chair and I apologize
representative power if I offended you
in any way I was feeling very emotional
at the time
um I have been in sessions where we've
all been in that LLB room together and
it's been great and we've had to rain
ourselves in to get our comments going
and I will endeavor to do that in the
future thank you for listening to me as
well and it looks like uh the clerk uh
Mr Smith has joined our Zoom meeting so
let me uh are you there Paul
yes Mr chairman I'm here sir yeah so
here's the question we have a member who
uh stopped his video uh during
discussion uh uh in the executive
session and when the first when we came
around to vote he was not on screen
so uh we came back to him at the end of
the vote
to catch up with him see what his vote
was at that time he was on screen on
video and so the question is should his
vote count or not
well Mr Mr chairman I I would only state
to you that the prior uh determination
by the speaker of the house was that in
order to participate uh during a roll
call vote uh you do have to be on screen
um to cast your vote
um that being said I I would also note
that if a member is not present when the
question is put that they should not be
voting on the matter just as if they
were not at their seat in the committee
room at the time that you called the
question uh they should not be uh
casting a vote okay thank you for that
clarification that's slightly different
than what I had
uh enumerated to the committee uh but
let me ask you this also while you're
here is would it be appropriate
uh when this is uh when this particular
vote is complete that if somebody on the
committee
made a motion to reconsider
that particular bill that a new vote
could be taken
and the the member that was
was virtually absent for the first vote
could vote that second time uh if if the
voters reconsidered uh yes Mr chairman
that is a courtesy frequently extended
uh that we actually had a similar
situation in another committee today
where that uh that variation came up and
a vote was reconsidered and uh a member
who was not able to participate in the
first vote was able to in the second so
yes that is certainly uh within the
purview of the committee if they so
choose to uh to to take the motion to
reconsider
thank you Paul really appreciate that
that's uh was clarifying for both me and
the committee anytime sir
okay uh
so is there a uh so we are about a
discount uh representative McBride's
vote and Mr Clark how is that the vote
that that how is the total may vote if
that's discounted it'll be nine through
99. so we have a nine to nine vote
for the committee for the for an Ott as
amended uh is there a situational motion
to be made Mr chair yes I make a motion
to reconsider a second I was still
motion's been made to reconsidered 433
representative Melville as uh seconded
is there any are there any discussion on
the reconsideration to reconsider
seeing none uh I asked the
clerk to take the role on both to
um
yes
representative chip yes
adjustment
s
I keep getting unmuted uh mute or
something for some reason
we're removing you from the controls
desk up there okay fine
representative yes
representative Pride yes
representative Melvin yes
yes
representative power yes
representative
no
uh
representative
no
representative Davis
um
no
representative
um no
absolutely
oh
for reconsideration uh before we vote
before we hear any uh additional motions
let me say that uh
uh I think is that a teachable point of
view from the house clerk uh and I stand
corrected that anybody who is
not on screen uh during the when the
question is raised
or during the voting itself will be
excluded from future votes so that's a
that's hopefully something we just all
took away from that discussion with uh
with Paul uh so Paul Smith so uh please
let's keep that in mind
and uh I'll accept a motion Mr chair or
yes I'd like to make a motion on on
House Bill 243
ought to pass as amended I guess is the
second second
okay uh representative Melville has uh
Melvin Melvin I'm sorry
is there additional discussion on the
motion
seeing on the house of clerk to take the
role
yes
representative yes
representative Guffey yes
representative Salas
yes
you come off of me with their
representative McBride
yeah I'm sorry Mr chairman make your
video
yeah hold on I'm sorry there you go I'm
sorry yes Mr chairman okay you touched
the wrong button okay yeah I did pushed
um
no
representative jury no
it's famous no
Representative no
representative
no
representative please
representative Gallagher no
champions
yes uh
okay at this point I'll accept the
I like to make a motion that we ICL
house bill 415. is there a second second
Mr chairman most of the million seconds
discussion
yes
acknowledging yourself
[Music]
yes
we're just uh making sure our paperwork
that the clerk is processing is correct
because I can say we're at the at the
house deadline and we don't want to
yes
[Music]
representative
yes
[Music]
representative yes
representative please yes
yes
but as a representative
will write the majority of being do we
have a volunteer to write the minority
there will be one I'm not sure who will
be writing in
nobody wants to volunteer right now it's
fine okay
yeah
the chair
I apologize this is representative
majority I'm just I'm just curious we
only need them The Minority Report on
243 right because 4 15 and I imagine 454
are going to go in consent I imagine
correct that objection output 4.59
percent
so we just need a committee report even
if it goes on consent but we don't need
a Minority Report so I'll ask for every
10 minutes to write that
as the uh as the one who made me made
they're uh
I
promotion uh House Bill 454. yes I make
a motion with itl
is there any discussion
[Music]
seeing none uh after the clock to call
the role 54.
[Music]
okay Excuse me
representative Guthrie yes
representative yes
uh representative power yes
yes
representative
sorry my computer had a hiccup
yeah
representative Gilman
uh we need you you yeah yes
thank you
representative majority yes
yes
representative
without objection I'll place this on the
consent calendar as well
284 was uh 18 to nothing but that wasn't
put on consent calendar I just wanted to
bring it to your attention Mr chair
ready
284 yeah yeah so what I did put that on
consent thank you I didn't catch it
forward
that was the vote was 19 to nothing
until 34.
okay
I'm sensing a a little bit of a low
energy point in the committee so
let me encourage you to file more and uh
and understand the sun will come up
tomorrow
all right the next bill we're going to
consider is house bill 512.
which is the I can remind you that's the
one about emergency housing assistance
if you uh hopefully you have that uh
some notes in front of you on that uh
I'll be looking for a motion I'd like to
make a motion we itl
house bill 512. is there a second second
Mr chairman motion's been made in second
it's a discussion on this bill before we
uh yeah yes Mr chair yes representative
I can't find my my hand
right now okay good
um
I think this is an important bill
um and I I think we had an amendment
that fixed it so that it it was clear as
to what would happen
um
if a community is forcing
there's a community is making it a
requirement that a house that someone is
living in be inspected before they get
emergency aid to help them with their
rent
and the owner of that house refuses to
have that inspection done as is their
right
then the renter
will not be able to afford their rent
and will therefore be evicted from that
home and become perhaps homeless because
through no fault of their own simply
because their landlord refused to have
this house that they are living in
inspected I think it's important for us
to realize that in this housing crisis
that we have there are no places for
people to go and find affordable housing
especially for the poorest of the poor
and when they are evicted from the
housing that they do have they become
homeless
this is a this is a humanitarian Bill a
bill to help someone who's in Dire
Straits
well I have to go live on the streets
and I think it's an important bill and
to itl it
is painful to me
I understand uh representative Davis do
you have a comment
I would like to speak to my Amendment
what I'd like to speak to my Amendment
oh yes the amendment
list it was under the under the auspices
of an
OTP motion so if this motion fails itl
then then we'll get into the amendment
okay is there other is there additional
uh
representative lasalles did you know
before about uh
let me uh let me just say that I know
that there has some there is some
concern I know I have some concern
uh about
the most vulnerable among us and we're
that's what we're talking about I'm
thinking of a of a young mother with uh
without a father and children that are
in need
and
one of the concerns was that
in a emergency situation these people
may be placed in unsafe
uh
unsafe
housing where there could be
bed bugs or Vermin or whatever and that
uh the
the code enforcement folks that would
look out for this uh wouldn't be able to
intervene and uh so the question that
haunts me is is uh how would I feel if
somebody in that situation which they're
unlikely to be picky and say no I don't
like this place let me look at someplace
else
uh they're probably going to be such
desperate need that they're going to
take whatever they get that they uh
they won't be able to uh to push back
and and they may end up in substandard
housing uh that could put them or their
children
so uh representative status did you have
a comment that was that is that an old
hand up oh it's a new hand up I do have
a comment yes
by the image of a young thought
with no mother for his children
not being able to find a roof over his
head because this bill doesn't last
there is nothing more dangerous than
living in outside
in dire conditions in a car or in a tent
and this girl would alleviate that
problem
and I would remind the chair and my
colleagues on the committee the towns
and cities in New Hampshire are required
by law to provide emergency housing
assistance it is not optional
representative Gallenberg you had a
comment
yeah
um
so
ask one of those vulnerable persons who
is currently living in what could be
described as substandard housing I have
had major bed bug problems here recently
I can I can say for certain that I
definitely prefer
having housing even if it is substandard
over possibly being homeless so yeah I
would say that
give yeah given the choice between the
two I I think this bill is the right
direction and that housing is good even
when substandard
yeah I think I think we're putting it
back on the towns and um
usually if someone in our town becomes
homeless we put them up in a hotel
in the meantime we notify the federal
government because most likely they're
going to go to section 8 housing because
they're you know apartments and stuff
are section eight we have them we know
those are inspected by the federal
government they're maintained by federal
government and if they don't pass the
inspection
they can't they can't move in they don't
get to collect their rent from the feds
that's how it's done usually
thank you uh representative
thank you Mr chair uh in Nashua that
housing is such a big crisis in terms of
not having enough housing for people
that need
uh Section 8 Housing section 40 housing
senior housing there's a long waiting
list so if I am living in a substandard
housing and I don't have the
um way of getting help
and I get evicted because the landlord
doesn't have to abide by what my
requirement is I have no place to go so
the vulnerable it's not just the uh one
particular segment it can be any segment
of perhaps the most vulnerable poorest
of the poor yes HUD does provide Health
but there's a long waiting list
there's minus 1.5 percent vacancy rate
how do you explain to that uh so to me
this is unconscionable it's very
difficult for me to look the other way
and in a cold country
this is difficult thank you
yes my understanding of this bill is not
about placing people in substandard
housing it is about providing uh funds
from the town to pay the rent for
someone who is in a building and cannot
pay their rent currently uh the way it
was originally written if the landlord
would not allow an inspection of the
unit that the person is already living
in then the town could not disperse
those funds as they are required by
Statute to do so this is not about
putting people someplace worse than they
are now it is about putting them on this
street and I definitely think that we
should pass this because we have an
emergency
thank you representative Missouri were
you able to allow me to co-host
Ivory thank you Mr chair I did ask
Christina Dyer
to do that unfortunately it's not a not
a power that I have
but it doesn't yeah she did do that you
are a co-host you're all set okay thank
you thank you Christina
uh thank you Mr chair I too think this
is a very important bill because
especially the word emergency so we're
talking about an emergency keeping
someone in place or putting them in
place because it's an emergency and
oftentimes the housing inspectors or the
building inspectors in towns or
communities are swamped with their work
and I get that and we don't want people
in the street I've lived in a car I've
lived in a mobile home I've lived on
people's couches luckily I've never
slept in a tent or in the woods but
there are lots of people who are doing
it now and I would prefer that we have
less people do it if at all possible
representative care I I take your point
that a town will put someone in a motel
federal government covering it and if we
could do if we could bridge that Gap and
help them that would be very important
to the population of New Hampshire thank
you and representative uh Porter if you
had an additional comment
things are representative I think you've
misunderstanding this bill and that's
why we had the amendment made this bill
does not Place anybody in a home this
bill this bill just allows the town to
give money to someone who needs money to
pay their rent they're not putting them
any place that they're not already so
that's that's why we have the amendment
made so that that would be clear and
number two can we take a potty break
yes I've seen that from a couple of
people so I see representative Ayer and
representative
comments if you hold your comments
rather than holding the potty break
all right so we'll come we'll we will
take a five minute recess and we will
reconvene with those two Representatives
up first thank you
thank you
foreign
[Music]
okay we are I believe unmuted now uh do
a sound check if anyone out there give
me a thumbs up that we're we're in uh
okay good
so I have uh we're back
it's got some executive Section House
Bill 512 and we have two speakers
at least at least three speakers I think
uh representative air and then
representative plea and then
representative poorer
again so uh representative Air Europe
first
we have public assistance people it'll
pay you rent your light bill your oil
bill whatever you need and and I believe
they go and they inspect
you know they don't have any it's not
you know put on the building inspector
the public assistance people do it not
uh
not the building department put the
building code department they go and um
there's never been a problem
we've always been able to go in
is that it let me ask you does that
include emergency housing as well
yes when it's an emergency say you don't
have your rent or you don't have oil or
the town the town will buy you your oil
pay your light bill if they have to then
make sure you get heat you can't pay
your rent they pay you rent you don't
have food to get your food
I just heard testimony last night at a
town council meeting in Londonderry this
is County specific but Rockingham County
has
a lot of money right now uh for people
if they to apply for if they're having
trouble meeting their rent so they're
paying their light bill or whatever and
uh for people who are needy so uh you
can call uh former colleague about Brian
Brian uh
tootsello who is a former representative
now as a county commissioner and he will
help you in at least in Rockingham town
to get the get access to that money so
they would like to spend that money and
not just sit on it so if you have a
concern and you need need that type of
assistance please call up the county
office and ask to speak to Brian
all right now we uh also uh next we had
representative Klee who had a comment
you wanted to make
yes thank you Mr chairman um first I I
want to make a comment about uh bed bugs
um just disgusting Little Critters as
they are and I'm sorry that anyone has
to live under those conditions but um as
a person who has fought for constituents
bed bugs believe it or not are not
considered substandard don't ask me why
but they're not considered substandard
but
um
I I specifically asked this question
when we had the public hearing is this
for displaced people as we had had here
in Nashville when we had a facade that
fell off um and we had a head of fire
and I was told no that that was not the
case this was for people who were
currently in housing
um and whether or not that they would
get help with their rent or whatever the
the situation was
um so I think we really do need to
clarify that and I think my colleagues
have also brought that point up I think
it's extremely important that we realize
that this has not been displaced
um individuals rather it is for
um to basically stay in place
thank you thank you representative
Porter you had an additional comment yes
I I did thank you Mr chair for letting
me speak representative air I think this
bill is aimed at those communities in
your community it's things are working
fine but in other communities
they may not this bill would prevent
someone from being
would make it so that inspections would
not be
have to be made some communities are
inspecting and then refusing to give the
aid because it's a substandard house and
that's what this bill is trying to
accomplish not all communities do it the
same way so in Hillsboro we might not go
and ask for an inspection we just
automatically give the money to help
with the rent but in another Community
when someone comes in for to ask for
help with the rent they might send the
inspector out and if the if the landlord
refuses the inspection then they won't
give the help and it might not be very
many communities but it does happen in
the state and that's why the sponsors of
this bill brought it forward as a as a
piece of legislation so that to prevent
someone from doing that so if that
clarifies for you thank you
from our distinguished ranking member of
Representative mangiori you have uh the
next uh opportunity to speak
and thank you Mr chair and thank you uh
for I guess I guess taking the question
actually I was going to say piggyback on
what representative Porter just said I
was speaking with the former uh
inspector uh who I just happened to bump
into a couple of days ago who's in a
town not too far away from where one of
these both of these sponsors live and
said exactly what uh representative
Porter said there are instances where
they find themselves saying no uh and
and I'm I'm just going to ask I'm going
to implore that the the committee
seriously consider voting down the itl
so that we can that we can reconsider at
least have the discussion about how this
yeah we just we just had a big fire and
a big apartment house burnt down and the
state stepped right in gave us forty
thousand dollars for the people that got
burned out for their first month's rent
in a security deposit
that came from the state
and we also had other monies we gave
them to keep them in the Exeter in
for the whole time that they were until
is out there
thank you uh representative hand up I
put it down did you still want to see
um thank you Mr chair I wanted to ask if
representative McBride could put himself
on mute he's married
I apologize I apologize no thank you I
appreciate that that's all I wanted to
say thank you thank you representative
magic Rudy
thank you Mr chair uh I just want to add
another comment it's not a you know yes
our city does a wonderful job we have a
shelter we have transitional home all
those stuff but the problem right now is
that such a big demand for housing if
something happens if I have a roof over
my head and if that needs funding to fix
it I have no choice to be on the street
or all the Emergency Shelters and uh
motels where they usually put up
are full so in a situation like that
this is something that would help to
alleviate if I am the renter I'm the
landlord I can't afford I've fallen
under the uh what is the I can't fix up
my rental property and but I don't want
my rat talents to go because I can't fix
it because of covet at least we have
that opportunity this will help those
this is an emergency housing assistance
so I think they have to look at it and
my other question also is we have there
is a uh Amendment itl will not give us
an opportunity to do that so isn't that
uh
reverse of it that we look at it if it
doesn't work then itl is the option I
I'm just trying to figure out how this
whole process procedure is working
um Mr chair sorry I'm I'm just so
confused as to how let me see if I can
help but under this scenario
if the itl passes
I'm sure given the comments we had this
will be a very energetic conversation on
the house floor and there will be an
opportunity at that point to offer an
amendment on the house floor and that so
that that opportunity does not go away
it just moves it to a different thing
representative status you had a comment
two amendment to HB 284 before we
considered the bill earlier today that's
just a process thing process question so
we have an amendment here but we're not
considering it before the bill we're
the amendment was considered
um in uh conjunction with the offending
OTP uh
emotion because you can't
you can't amend something in an itl
environment you only amend something in
an OTC environment so I know that sounds
a little confusing but uh it does in
fact representative Porter uh had said
that historically you take the motion to
uh OTP first and then the amendment if
you took if we followed that scenario uh
if the motion was to ITP there is no
opportunity to offer Amendment so either
way uh we kind of stuck where we are
right now so I'm sorry sorry please
important and and the wonderful job that
his town is doing
I chair the board of directors of the
largest Social Service Agency in the
Upper Valley we
House people we feed people we keep them
warm there are no Services here to do
Building Inspections from our agency
that just would it would never happen we
don't have the capacity all this bill
does representative air and and dear
colleagues is prevent a municipality
from refusing to provide the emergency
assistance that is required by law
based on a landlord or an owner's
refusal to do a building inspection it
does not create housing it does not
create rat traps or tent cities it just
ensures that the hosing the assistance
that's required by law that there's no
impediment to Distributing it and why on
Earth
that could be opposed when it is in the
law in black and white that this
emergency assistance is to be given is
beyond me I'm sorry to be so emotional
but it's just beyond me
uh thank you Mr chair and um I mean my
comments with with all respect
um as as a former chair
um I truly do mean this in in in full
respect but
um shouldn't we be you know you
mentioned something about that we could
take this and fix it and do whatever on
the floor but shouldn't the work be done
in this committee and if we I tell it
then we're not where we have we know
that there's an amendment
um out there
um just ready to be discussed and talked
and and possibly worked on
um wouldn't it be best to to do that
first rather than to send it down to the
floor where for a hundred of us will
have to learn and discuss et cetera et
cetera and I don't and I mean no
disrespect to my fellow colleagues on
the floor either I just think the work
should be done in the committee and
thank you for listening thank you let me
ask this we have a
a representative on the committee that's
made a motion to
itl uh with the with that representative
would like to withdraw their motion
no
so so in that case we are
in the voting mode
um
and
um the next offer an amendment would be
on the floor when it comes before the
the whole house so uh we have a motion
yes
representative Guthrie yes
representative Salas yes
right yes
yes
no and I did not hear representative
powers answer
representative power was was a yes thank
you
no
representatively no
representative
no
Representative no
representative gallery no
the voters ten to nine I'll ask
representative fiamonte right from the
jury committee report and do I have a
volunteer ranked in Minority Report for
the committee I will write The Minority
Report Mr chair
thank you representative reporter and
I'm happy to see less of a sense of
urgency on everybody's face after that
recent break so that's a positive foot
positive development for the committee
and the next bill we're going to take up
is uh represent is Bill House Bill 552
hopefully you have your your notes and
your maybe a printout of that the bill
of hard copy or a soft copy if you're
online uh this was the bill as a
reminder that suspended
tax revaluations per year and we heard
the
uh
some testimony on that we have a motion
pending for that yes sir representative
of the salad
Mr chairman I make a motion uh to uh
have
House Bill 552
in expedient legislate thank you is
there a second
Mr chairman okay the second was ever
McBride the the first the motion to IPL
was
is there a discussion before we uh head
down the road to vote Yes sir
representative majority
oh whoops sorry about that I I was just
going to ask if there's any interest in
retaining this bill has been suggested
by the sponsor to see what happens with
Senate Bill 102 but we are already to
itl the IPL fails that motion would be
I'm sorry sir my hand just did not go
seeing no further questions
Mr clerk would you call the roll on 552.
yes
[Music]
I can't hear you
did you wanna did you want to uh
you want to vote on five five two I'm
I'm voting yes but I can't hear this the
clerk
pardon me I said I misspelled it you
misvoted
at the uh
consideration unless the committee
objects representative Tripp would like
to recast is both
uh has anybody object to that
all right
yes
representative yes Mr Clark please
continue
representative missiles yes
yes
representative
no
yeah
representative fan yes
representative
yes
representative Gallagher yes
I don't think that's
something that uh
no no all right so I'm gonna without
without objection I'll put that on
consent
it was wonderful can I ask questions yes
groups
representative majority is there any
objection before that on consent
I have no objection Mr chair my vote for
no just just to be clear to everybody
was in the hopes that we could uh retain
okay thank you you don't owe us an
uh
works on the sales to do the majority
report
and uh representative uh majority you do
The Minority Report
I don't need one for
you that's right yeah I I would not be
offering one yeah sign consent that's
all right um I'm gonna hold
573 and 574 and exec those on Monday
there is a rumor that they
amendment that may be offering element
if uh
originate as an opportunity to uh to
bring forth that amendment when it's not
pending now but uh
it's not ready on Monday we will vote
um
I know we were going to hold 588 for
Mr chair yes ready for for a motion
I'm just thinking out loud here make
sure we do this correctly
we we have pushed just uh FYI we have
pushed a number of things to the eighth
and I'm just getting a little nervous
that we're going to overload ourselves
on the AIDS to be uh be working through
supper time I'd rather not do that to
you all
um
I'm just right now considering 616 this
is the one I'm planning for a decision
requiring a bond to be posted uh it's a
playing board is going to be doing uh
rather if the if the Builder does some
significant changes
um
if you want
put your motion
my motion is Ito
second
okay then there's better motion
and a second by representative Davis yes
is there any discussion on the itl
motion speak to my motion when I first
read this bill to my husband who's the
planning board uh chair here in town he
thought it sounded pretty good but as I
started listening to some of the
objections that uh Mr Johnston had this
morning I began to realize that
this might be a good bill for planning
board members but it might not be such a
good bill for the members of the public
who have an appeal that they would like
to bring forward
um it would cost them an awful lot of
money and I think they have a right to
that appeal to appeal a decision that
the planning board has made and it
shouldn't end up costing them two or
three thousand dollars to do that so I
think this bill just isn't ready for
prime time yet and emotions been made
and seconded is there other is there any
no
no can't hear is the roll being called
sir it is uh representative piamonte uh
voted no you can't hear them okay those
of you in the LLB are actually to speak
representative
I can't hear him
representative Guthrie uh if you could
unmute you can accept your vote I'm okay
uh Representative no
representative
yes
representative Gilman yes
representative majority yes
representative yes
representative fan
yes
representative please
no
no tonight
okay uh
volunteer to uh to
representative of the volunteer right
the majority report
[Music]
the minority of volunteer rights of
minority
foreign
representative Guthrie would you
volunteer to write The Minority Report
I'm not going to be around so you're
going to be on vacation that's okay
representative Piemonte I'm going to put
it on you all right sorry about that Mr
chair
um hold on hold on
okay
right majority reporters quarter
minorities Diamante
and it's best for
616.
yes uh representative
all the uh builds that we took today we
voted on exacted on today
when will that leave physically leave
the committee room to the
uh Clerk's Office
depends on our Clerk and uh and when the
the uh the uh committee reports have to
be written as we've just discussed they
have to be sent to me I approve them
or disapprove them and then they they uh
once they're approved they're included
in the
in the file folder and sent on to miss
goalie and uh she transmits them to Ms
Fitzgerald once they're transmitted to
Vince Fitzgerald who's which is an arm
of the uh Mr Smith's office and that's
when they are considered gone if you
will so uh I would suspect that given
the time frames we're working with uh
all all our folders should be
transmitted no no later than Tuesday
next Tuesday
some of them before then but no later
than Tuesday that's that's where our
goal is
uh we're also going to we're going to
miss the calendar I understand the
speaker just put out some additional
guidance that extend it's going to
extend some of the deadlines but I I
haven't heard directly what that means
and which deadlines are extended so we
may have more time but given the current
calendar deadlines that we have without
the speakers intervention today
I suspect that all our folders will be
transmitted no later than I would say
lunchtime on on Tuesday
okay
that's uh Mr chair
are you thinking about reconsideration
that process
I'm just thinking some days it's a few
days some days it's over two weeks so
I'm just trying to wrap my head around
what the process is in this committee I
know I'm a newbie I'm first time on this
committee I don't know the workings of
it I can tell you that when we we're not
up against the deadlines
and when we're still learning our
process which many of us have been this
term we've been a little slow to
transmit a lot of these folders as we as
we complete new paperwork that the
clerk's office has asked us to complete
in some cases we don't know the
paperwork has to be completed until
after the bill is done and so it comes
back and we finish it and then we send
it Forward we're getting a little bit
better and our learning curve is is uh
is being capitalized on so we're a
little fast enough and the fact that
we're up against the deadline we're
being uh a little quicker also so uh you
can't hear me
can you guys hear me are you just making
fun of me no we're not making funny I'm
saying goodbye to just to representative
I have fans so and we were we were
making fun of each other because we were
waving at each other
our apologies Mr chair okay but I can
tell you just if you're getting ready to
leave the last two actions we have is
House Bill 67 and
House Bill 431 so if you want if you
want to hold on for those two it might
be fast but uh I have a meeting I have a
meeting I have to open at four o'clock
so I have to go I'm really sorry and
representative true 11 has to go get her
second vaccine shot
oh you first my first vaccine shot and
you jinxed me this morning Mr Chair by
saying oh we'll be done long before then
anyway in any case I do have to go and
and again I'm sorry that representative
treeleven and I were being silly
thank you for your participation and for
your endurance this has been a long day
so and I appreciate that see you Monday
all right 8 30.
all right so uh
uh where was I
um
and right now we're looking to
exec
573-574 and 588 on Monday that's that's
the plan
and uh
so what's up Nick what's up next is
we have uh I believe we have an
amendment for that bill as well so I'll
be looking for a motion on the amendment
and
that if representative Porter
would like to uh see it's out a little
differently I'm okay with that if we
wanted to just take a motion on the bill
first and then we'll consider the
amendment afterwards how's that sound
I'm confused Mr chair I really am and
how
we had to make the motion
of ought to pass and then move the
amendment so the amendment went along
with the ought to pass motion that's
what we're going to do this time okay
thank you very much because I don't and
I don't have I don't know if I have the
amendment okay
um we can read it to you if you don't
have it
um
I think it was sent to the whole
committee but it might be buried in your
email and I I that's
quite a bit so the uh which Bill are we
talking about it was about Animal
I'm saying House Bill 67. okay is um was
from uh Representatives March
I like to make a motion not to pass on
that okay there's a bit of motion made
off the path I just like to remind you
[Music]
this week this bill requires that
original warrant articles be placed on
the official ballot at certain meetings
even if such articles have been amended
during the first session of the meeting
2021-0553 H is in hotel
and it the amendment basically says that
no petition Warren article shall be
a very short Amendment but uh there's
not nevertheless amended so we're we're
talking about the bill
uh
and
it's been the emotions been made to OTP
but we're going to first vote on the
amendment so that we can eventually vote
on the bill as amended
I have enough yes
all right uh so so Mr
representative Market you want to make a
motion on the amendment have you already
uh
well then we really want to have a
motion on OTP as amended so
so now that we have a motion on the OTP
is it your experience representative
Porter that we stop at this point and
move right to the amendment you move
ought to pass and then you say and I
have an amendment and then you vote on
move the amendment
ought to pass and then you vote on the
octopath as amended if the amendment
passes all right is there is there a
motion to pass the amendment
I made I make a motion to pass the
amendment
2021-0553h okay is there a second on the
amendment yes representative power makes
a second is there any discussion on the
amendment
saying no discussion uh we take the roll
e yes
representative yes
representative
yes
representative yes
again
yes
no
representative Gilbert
representative Davis
no
yes
the amendment passes ten to seven so now
look for a motion to
OTP as amended to make a motion on House
Bill 67
OTP as amended
is there a second
yes
most have been made in seconded by
representative Powell follow the World
Series no sir I'd like to speak to this
please
oh I'm sorry uh discussion on the uh
representative
yes go ahead please representative
Porter
this
it seems to me that every time I've
serve the four or five terms I've served
on this committee we've had an issue
with
towns that use the official ballot or
the sb2 method
the original intent of sb2 was to allow
everybody that wanted to to vote by
ballot on the town issues
because they said people couldn't get to
the town meetings it was
disenfranchising old people families Etc
so the best solution was to have this be
on a ballot that everybody could vote on
on Tuesday or Saturday or whenever it
was held but in order to continue the
kind of
self-roove that we like to have in New
Hampshire the town meeting self-rule we
needed to have a Time the delay when the
members of the public could come in and
hear from the Selectmen or the school
board and ask their questions and amend
things that would go on about you this
used to be done at the town meeting but
because of the way things would change
for sb2 it now went to deliberative
sessions now the complaint is that at
deliberative sessions only a few people
go and they and it's not fair because
people don't come out you know the only
the people that want something show up
the problem that we have here isn't
it
the problem it seems to me the problem
that is the problem is that people don't
come to our meetings so if you're really
interested in something you'll go to the
meeting if you're not really interested
you don't go to the meeting so the
people that show up are the ones that
have the control
to allow
a petition a petition Warren article
that comes before a deliberative session
gets deliberated by the people of the
town and they change it just like they
would have done at the town meeting they
could change it but instead of voting at
it at the deliberative session it goes
on the ballot now if someone is in a
traditional town meeting and someone has
brought a petition warrant article and
it gets amended it only gets voted on
once at the town meeting
this bill would allow people to have
their petition Warren article debated at
the deliberative session amended at the
deliberative session but then the
original warrant article goes on valid
it's not fair it's not the way the
process works and and to have two
items on the ballot the original warrant
article in the amended warrant article
it's confusing to the voters if they
both win what happens I it's just
misusing the process of what sb2 was
designed to do so in every term we have
this issue and every term we have to
explain again why it's not fair that
some people get to vote have theoretical
voted on twice and other people don't so
I'm just really against things that are
changing how warrant articles are done
at town meeting or deliberative session
it has to be consistent throughout the
state well not addressing the question
of fairness I can't tell you one answer
to your question if both if both the
amended article and the original article
both passed then the amended article is
what's adopted well how do you know what
people want then
but then they want both of them
well uh if they if they both pass they
only get one
they get the amended one
that's the way the legislation is
written yes I can't I'm not arguing in
favor of the legislation I'm just
any further discussion before we take a
vote
we have a comment from
representative Tripp
uh
the new amendments they don't they don't
realize that uh
the original bill is replaced entirely
the uh the bill which would have put the
original
petition or an article on the ballot
it's gone and it's replaced with the
amendment which says no petition or an
article shall be amended to change
two balance
yeah
Mr chair can I ask you a question
the representative Tripp just said that
I thought
I thought that both amendments get put
on an article
sentence
did the amendment replace the original
bid
so just so you can hear what we're
talking about we're looking at the
original
Bill paragraph d
and the amended the amendment which is a
which takes the original D out and puts
thank you
would it be possible Mr chair to have
them speak into the microphone just for
91a
yes uh I'm sorry the uh
the question that we're wrestling about
is looking at the original
Phil 67 section D which talks about uh
both amended and the uh
article in the original article both
being on the ballot that that was my
understanding and I and as I've now
looking at the amendment it looks like
that whole paragraph has been stricken
as as representative Tripp just
mentioned and it's replaced with the
fact that no petition worn article shall
be amended to change its specific intent
so both articles do not appear on the
warrant and the the only article that
will appear on the warrant is is the
original or the amended article without
changing the specific intent of the
I don't have the amendment can it be
emailed or I'm voting on something that
I have no copy of it okay I I think it
was email but I
I'll read it to you it's just one line
no but I I you know I usually I have my
iPad right here looking for email so I
just want to see a category categorize
it I'm a visual person Mr chair and if I
can't
you have it's still in
it's soft traffic
because you you emailed it to me
I believe see if I can find the
was sent out to Heather goalie on Monday
okay so if I know who sent it I will try
to locate that give me just a couple of
seconds please it was sent out on Monday
by by uh representing by uh by Heather
goalie she's a committee assistant
and if you're still having trouble with
that we can resend it to you or if
anybody else still sees it in their
inbox if they could just reply all and
uh and resend it
um amendment number Mr chair I can put
it up on the screen the amendment number
is
2021-0553 Hotel thank you I found it Mr
chair
okay Mr chair I've had my hand raised
for quite a while now yes I'll I'll I
see it
so representative Andrew booty are you
uh are you good with the uh
possession of that you want to take some
time to read it and understand it are
you good
I would like to take a couple of minutes
thank you okay in the meantime
representative stavis you had a comment
yeah I wish I could have asked this um
closer to what I had heard so it may
make a little less sense right now but
do I hear someone ringing a bell a while
ago is that something we need to pay
attention to I'm not quite sure oh that
that is that is a little bit of a a joke
uh representative Tripp has been having
trouble getting my attention here in the
LLB when he wants to ask a question so
he brought a little cowbell with him to
help help get my attention I see that's
helpful to know thank you
the people that are in the LLP don't get
uh
the third season cheers attention as
much as the people that are on to right
the the folks in the LLB don't have an
opportunity to raise their hand
electronically and sometimes as I am
becoming hypnotized by my screen I don't
see
uh some and representative lasalles has
had the same problem as representative
uh Guthrie when he's here and Melville
also
so uh I am
trying and uh
trying to make sure that I recognize
everybody I'm trying to be fair so
please uh please bear with me um
representative majority you got a
comment
I apologize Mr chair I I um I was going
to this very point and forgot to raise
my or forgot to lower my hand about
having this complete change to the
amendment thank you okay representative
Porter
okay Mr chair I'm feeling uncomfortable
now
um because I don't believe that the
changes that this makes we've had a
chance to hear from any members of the
public on this change because this is a
significant change
um and and I'm
I'm just uncomfortable so I will
probably be voting against Dr pass as
amended because
I'm not comfortable that we heard what
this amendment actually does I
understand
I'm sorry it just was a long time ago
that we heard this bill and I I know
it's been a while a normal process
however is that we don't go to the
public during executive session I know I
know this bill is now our bill it's no
longer the sponsors bill and we can
change it as we see fit uh if you don't
feel comfortable with this change you
should vote against it
we took a vote on the amendment and the
amendment passed ten to seven and we're
about to take a vote on the bill uh as
amended
okay that's amended
any further discussion before we go in
the voting Mr chair yes
I would just like to speak to the
amendment that in my view this amendment
simply clarifies but is already in
statute
so there is no significant um
change that's that's being made with
this amendment to you know within this
bill it just clarifies existing language
uh
dick are you good no I I do have a
comment now
um uh if I may Mr chair wait a wait a
sec we had I was recognizing
representative I'm sorry I'm sorry yeah
but the original discussion on the the
the delivery session was held in a
location that was difficult for the
majority of the people in the school
district to get to and uh
what would happen in the delivery
session as uh representative Porter
said earlier this
is amended and changed to where the uh
the intent was negated entirely
uh
the solution that the sponsor
that would work was to keep
uh
so both of those on the ballots uh
during the hearings it was discussed
that that would be confusing to people
that they wouldn't know what what was uh
I was asked to look at this and uh
percent
the uh the effect solution
this is
not a DC solution but uh what I finally
come up with is I said well
we'll find out
if the wording that I've suggested in
the amendment is acceptable too
committing it to the uh
house on the floor so I spent at the
uh thank you representative
thank you Mr chair
um I want to thank representative Tripp
because I love this amendment I mean I
love the idea as a board member of nhma
and a selectman for the last 100 years
that I've been
um I I can I can promise you and if
Cordell was on the line he would he
would confirm and if Steve Buckley and
Nate Graves is on the line they would
confirm from legal that one of the
biggest questions that that we get is
can we change the intent you know can we
make the police car a fire truck can we
make the police car red instead of blue
so intent I I mean this this if you say
you can't change the intent I'm all in
favor of this however that said this is
a completely different Bill than what
was submitted and what we discussed in
the public hearing so I I am I am
totally torn I love the idea and I want
to vote in favor of it but if it's just
not what was submitted to the public and
I I just don't know what we're supposed
to do in that instance I know the bill
is ours I understand that but the public
did not weigh in on the amendment on on
this on this on the on the dramatic
change to the amendment and I have to
voice my concern in that respect
I think my explanation uh
to the public is that
that once we uh once we have the bill
and then it goes from the uh
the sponsor and the originator of the
bill to the committee's bill and and
once we're in executive session then
it's up to us to decide if we want to
edit or change the bill and that's what
one of our one of our members committee
members did and it's brought back an
amendment to change the change the bill
that was brought forth and debated
in the hearing process if you don't
believe
that we should be doing this because of
the content and the fact of the public
hearing and so forth then I would
encourage you to vote your conscience
going forward but it is certainly within
our process
to take control of the bill and then
edit it to what the committee would like
thank you without without further
comment
um
I'm gonna I'm gonna look to
for the committee to vote
OTP as amended and I'd ask the clerk to
call the rule
yes
representative Guthrie and EU come off
mute
let's toggle switches at all right
here we go
yes yes
representative crime
yes
nothing yes
okay
yes
City Power yes
no
um
representative
no
she said she's gonna help a
representative
no
yes
okay the bill
has amended is uh 10-7
and uh past
um
report
the majority
and then if we have a volunteer to write
I will find somebody
I'll take care of it thank you Jim
representative thank you
for volunteering okay we're down to our
uh that's HP 431 that's this is the bill
you remember was about the Animal
control officer
that was elected
issues with their local uh
Mr chair and I'd like to make the motion
yes please
I'd like to make a motion we retain
House Bill 431
okay motion made to retain is there a
second yes
motion's been made in second
uh the discussion this representative
Porter
thank you Mr chair um
standing tradition in this committee to
not pass legislation to solve a
Personnel problem in one small community
so I'm just putting that out there for
you to consider when it's time to Recon
if this Bill gets retained um because
mediation is an option that they have
and we don't usually serve that function
and if I remember correctly last year we
had a bill that came from Hopkinton
about a town clerk issue and we would
not deal with the town clerk issue
because that's up to the voters
so just letting you
think about that
yes thank you thank you I I don't
disagree with you on that representative
thank you Mr chair I'm I'm just like to
uh put the question out as to
what if we retain and we're going to
work on this so if there's going to be
work what is the work the bill is CL it
seems clear to me I'm just looking for
why I would vote in favor of of
retaining this bill because again it
it's perfectly clear what what the
intent is
okay that's that's a good question I I
let me I don't speak on behalf of the
committee but I would say that if I were
to vote for retain it would be to get
the
give the community an opportunity to
work this out this is kind of a dirty
laundry issue uh work it out and
hopefully uh they can decide either to
change the legislation with an amendment
for uh
or if it comes back to us in an
unchanged uh manner I think I would be
on an itl side of this
uh representative Gilman you had a
comment foreign
yes along with going along the lines of
what you just said Mr chair
um if a position has been created as an
elected official wouldn't the
legislative body have to be the ones
that decide if it's uh elected or not
for their particular Town wouldn't they
have to resend or repeal that position
is being elected yeah yes it would and I
think that's my point as well is that
this is a dirty laundry issue that the
community should work out on their own
but uh I guess I'm I'm well at this
point I'm willing I'm willing to go
along with a retained motion to give
them an opportunity to do that and
hopefully coach them along those lines
Representatives Davis
isn't voting itl doing exactly that
telling them you have to work this out
on your own yeah that is a that is I
guess a similar message that would be a
similar message yes then why are we
I'm sorry that question was out of line
I apologize Mr chair I I guess I'm just
I'm frustrated I'm frustrated with the
process and I'm frustrated with
some contradictions that seem to be
cropping up
okay I apologize for my for my tone
that's okay
Is there further comment uh before we go
seeing that I asked the clerk
representative comment
forgot to lower my hand all right
yes
right
and again it can't come back in the same
with the same wording uh I just can't
repeat that they have to change the
legislation to bring it back
to retain it it stays the same unless
it's uh it's it's uh altered the
amendment uh either by the committee or
by a combination of the committee and
so is there are there any more comments
seeing none I'm going to ask the clerk
to call the roll
um yes
yes
approaches
representative Guthrie we need your your
vote
representative LaSalle
yes
representative
no
oh yes
yes
the boat is 12 to 5. in favor of the
um
so is there
I think that's the last piece of
legislation that uh
I'm going to take up today
as a reminder remember please remember
we're going to start at 8 30. on Monday
and plan on a long day Monday because
we're going to try to finish up our
business on Monday for the for this
first half of the
legislative session
and uh
I don't think we have any any pending
business does anybody have any
any
last-minute comments that they want to
make Mr chair are we hearing
six bills on Monday and then executing
everything that's left yes and then
we're executing the bills we're hearing
Monday on Monday yes
thank you my understanding is we need to
have
if we were gonna what would be more
ideal than what I tried to do is try to
do the exact thing on Wednesday
but I was told that that's too late that
all our business has to be done by close
of business on Tuesday or first thing
Wednesday morning and it doesn't give us
an opportunity to get that last piece of
executive gun so unfortunately we're
going to uh
we're going to have a full day money yes
follow-up yes a follow-up thank you we
had a similar Bill to HB 266 last year
and the hearing was quite lengthy are we
anticipating that we're going to have
that many people uh testifying on this
bill this time
266 that's the uh Sanctuary bills
yeah I would imagine that's going to be
a lively debate I I would be uh I would
not be truthful but I didn't think and
that's one of the reasons why I put it
last
if it's a lively debate and starting at
11 o'clock that means likely if it was
like last time it will be at least one
or two in the afternoon before we stop
hearing um hearing testimony yeah it's
very important thing about the length of
the day to be honest with you because
this day today was brutal for me I'm in
a lot of pain from sitting this long so
I'm just trying to figure out how to
handle
another day like this next week if you
um
if you would like I certainly wouldn't
object if you wanted to bring your lunch
uh and uh
and have and we could work through a
lunch if you're comfortable doing that
uh and that as long as we can ask
everybody to chew with their mouths
thank you representative you have a I
just wanted the process is going to be
be here uh public hearing and then turn
around and do the exact what would be
the process so I know I can prepare
myself better what to anticipate
uh well we're going to expect that we
have a couple of leftover bills from
today we have
573 574 588
left over from today
not that was not my question uh just
saying that we're gonna we'll exec those
and we'll we'll have the hearings from
for the other bills that have been
noticed for hearing and then we'll
accept them as well no I was are we
going to have public hearing first and
then exact session or are we going to
intersperse exact public hearing exact
public hearing like that that's our
intention to have public hearings first
and then execs afterwards unless I can
sense that that we have a bill that we
have a public hearing and I can sense
that this there is a A 19-0 or something
like that among us and then we just exec
it immediately but that I don't
anticipate that but if I if I sense that
I'll try to do that to make us make
things move along a little faster but uh
my my plan is to have pairings first
starting at 8 30.
and uh in fact there was one hearing we
were going to uh planning on doing right
away
I can't remember right now but we'll
have I'm sorry representative Porter you
no no what we just killed 512 I thought
it was Bill 512 but it's not
right so but but representative major
putty my plan is to do public hearings
first and then exec afterwards
okay
thank you for uh
for enduring and uh and I think Monday
may be just as long if not longer and uh
well maybe we'll take a couple extra
breaks so that uh to relieve some of
your uh
some of your uh
pension and and also those who you are
who are in pain with their facts or
whatever uh
yeah I have I am confident that my man
flu will not extend into Monday so I'll
be fine and who is it that had their
first shot today was it representative
I think she'll be fine first shot's
all right the representative manager
Cody is that an old hand you have up or
an old hand okay
all right thank you all and uh
I'm gonna end our session for the
committee today thank you very much for
you know it's actually coming today
could you uh